ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN BERMAN
BIGELOW. BLOOM BURNER HORVATH.
BONTA BRO WORK. CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU TRAN
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DEEP. EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER.
XENA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON. GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
GRAYSON. ALL THEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON ALONE
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN. MULTI
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY YES THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS
WOULD. SPEAKER
. MEMBERS. QUORUM
IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY OSHA REPETITION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. A BRIEF REFLECTION
ON LOS. ONE OF THE MOST
ESSENTIAL REALITIES OF LIFE IS
TO UNDERSTAND THE EVERYTHING IS
CONSTANTLY CHANGING NOTHING CAN
LAST FOR EVER. IMPERMANENCE IS
NOT GOOD OR BAD IS REALITY.
BECAUSE OF CHANGE WONDERFUL
THINGS HAPPEN WE WILL GROW
LEARNING EXPERIENCE NEW THINGS
MEET NEW PEOPLE FALL IN LOVE IN
BECAUSE OF IMPERMANENCE IN
LIVING LIFE. IS IN EVER ROLE
THAT WE MUST IN TIME LOAN LOSS.
EXPERIENCING REAL LOSS WILL
ALWAYS BE ONE OF THE HARDEST
THINGS WE MUST EVER INTER.
HOWEVER I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPERMANENCE THERE'S ALSO THE
SEED OF WISDOM. LIVING WITH
AWARENESS OF IMPERMANENCE CAN
AWAKEN US TO LIVE LEVINE DEEPLY
FOR WE NOTE THERE WHAT WE LOVE
CAM THE LOS. THIS IS SEEK TO
LIVING WITH GRATITUDE AND
TAKING NOTHING FOR GRANTED.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER SEE WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS. THANK YOU REVEREND ASHA
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE. HEAD
OVER HOT. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE. ISRAEL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MOVING TO THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO THURSDAY
AUGUST TWENTY NINE TWENTY
NINETEEN RECENTLY MADE A SEVEN
AM ON WILL WILLIAM BROUGH
ASSEMBLY MEMBERSEVENTY THIRD
DISTRICT PRESIDING CHIEF COOKIE
DOTSON WILSON AT THE DESK WE
LIKE HAVING AN LIST READING ALL
THEIR OWN MOVES TO MISTER MAYES
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
ABSENCES THERE ARE NO ABSENCES
TODAY
. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RAISING
GALLAGHER. TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
MEMBER TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILL TO THE
INACTIVE FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN
SB SIXTY SIX ATKINS. THE CLERK
WILL NOTE. AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE TRY THE
FOLLOWING VETOES. FROM THE FILE
ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT AB SIX
EIGHTEEN STONE AN ITEM ANYONE
AB FOR TWELVE QUIRK SILVA. THE
CLERK WILL NOTE. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY WILL SEVENTY SEVEN THE
ONE DAY WAITING PERIOD FOR
CONCURRENCE IS. ON ITEM SIX
THROUGH EIGHTY SIX TO ALLOW
AUTHORS TO TAKE UP THEIR BILLS
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE ORDER. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO RULE ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I'M
REFERRING THE FOLLOWING BILLS.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB SIX
EIGHTY ONE THE ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FIVE. TO THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
FOUR AB EIGHT NINETY THREE
GLORIA AT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
FOUR AB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT LOW
TO THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE. AND ITEM EIGHTY ONE
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE SANTIAGO
TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE SECOND READING THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL SIX OH
SIX. ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOVING TO CURRENT THIS IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS FILE ITEM
THREE AB AT THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY BY FAMILY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE AND ACTUALLY
TO TRANSPORTATION MR OPEN UP TO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN OF THE
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED THE
REQUIREMENT THAT TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES MUST CONDUCT
BACKGROUND CHECKS ON THEIR
DRIVERS AND ALSO ESTABLISH A
LIST OF OFFENSES THAT ARE
DISQUALIFYING FOR THOSE
DRIVERS. AS IT LEFT HIS CHAMBER
THIS BILL WAS MERELY A CODE
CLEAN UP TO THAT SECTION BUT IN
THE SENATE WE'VE ADDED AN
OFFENSE THAT WAS INADVERTENTLY
LEFT OFF THE LIST OF
DISQUALIFYING FOR DRIVERS AND
THAT IS THE OFFENSE OF FELONY
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THAT HAS A
DIRECT NEXUS TO CONSUMER SAFETY
IN THESE INDUSTRIES AND I HOPE
YOU'LL AGREE THAT IT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE THAT IT BE ADDED TO
THAT LIST. SO I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
CONCURRENCE IN THAT SET AN
AMENDMENT. MR OBERNOLTE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERTED BOTH.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
TWO NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FOR
AB TWELVE SIXTY FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ AS A LEVEL TWELVE
SIXTY FOUR BY SOME THE NUMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY HEALING ARTS DECLARING
THEIR IT'S EITHER UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
ASK FOR YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT
FOR AB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR AT
THIS BILL CLARIFIES BAG TELL
HEALTHCARE LIES IN ORDER TO
REMOVE MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY
BARRIERS TO PRESCRIBING AS YOU
MAY RECALL THE ORIGINAL FOCUS
AT THIS BILL WAS REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE AS WE MOVED THROUGH
THE PROCESS AND AT WORK WITH
OUR COALITION PARTNERS. IT
BECAME CLEAR THAT TAD THIS WAS
RELEVANT BEYOND THE AREA JUST
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AS WE
EXPANDED THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
ACCORDINGLY AND THAT'S WHAT
SENATE AMENDMENTS HAVE DONE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EYES.
THANK YOU MISS PETER NORRIS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR
VOTE
. THIS PETRIE-NORRIS MOVE
THE CAR
. WE TO FILE ITEM FIVE
A. B. FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ AS A LEGAL
FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE BY SOME THE
MEMBER LOW ACTUALLY THE CAMPUS
GOING THERE TO SEE THEIR UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY MR LOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MASSACRE MEMBERS IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LET. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
YEAH. ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERT
ABOUT THIS FIRST FIFTY FOUR.
WE'LL DO IT NOW. WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE
FIFTY FIVE NEWS HERE ON THE
URGENCY ICE FIFTY FIVE NEWS
HERE ON THE BILL SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS WITH FUTURE NURSES
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM FOR AB TWELVE SIXTY
FOR THE CLERK WILL POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESIRE
TO VOTE THIS FIRST FIFTY FOUR
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM SIX AB
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE MY FAMILY
MEMBER GONZALEZ AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE. THIS
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB FIVE ON
CONCURRENCE AFTER SIGNIFICANT
DISCUSSION AND DELIBERATIONS
WITH A WIDE VARIETY OF
INDUSTRIES AND STAKEHOLDERS.
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE OUT OF
THE FOLLOWING PROFESSIONAL
EXEMPTIONS. IF NOBODY CARES I
CAN JUST SAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR- VOTE ON CONCURRENCE
OKAY WE DO HAVE SOME PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT THE EXEMPTIONS NOW.
I'M GET. I'M TO GO THROUGH THEM
QUICKLY THEN. DENTIST
PODIATRIST CYCLE WHAT
PSYCHOLOGISTS LAWYERS
ARCHITECTS ENGINEERS VETERAN.
VETERINARIANS PRIVATE
INVESTIGATORS ACCOUNTANTS
COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN AND
REPOSSESSION AGENTS. THE BILL
CLARIFY THE PROFESSIONALS
PROVIDING SERVICES AS A SMALL
BUSINESS ENTITY COULD CONTINUE
TO MAINTAIN THEIR BUSINESS
OPERATIONS UNDER THE PREVIOUS
FOR OUR STANDARD. THESE
PROFESSIONALS INCLUDE MARKETING
PROFESSIONALS ADMINISTRATORS OF
HUMAN RESOURCES TRAVEL AGENTS
GRAPHIC DESIGNERS GRANT WRITERS
FINE ARTISTS ENROLLED AGENTS.
PAYMENT PROCESSING AGENTS
FREELANCE PHOTOGRAPHERS
PHOTOJOURNALIST WRITERS EDITORS
AND CARTOONIST WHO SUBMIT TO A
PUBLICATION NO MORE THAN THIRTY
FIVE TIMES A YEAR CAN CONTINUE
TO DO SO. AND LICENSED
COSMETOLOGIST BARBERS
ESTHETICIANS ELECTROLYSIS.
MANICURIST GIVEN THAT THEY
PROVIDE A FORM TEN NINETY NINE
TO THE SALON WHEN THEY ARE
RENTING BUSINESS SPACE CAN
CONTINUE TO CONDUCT BUSINESS AS
AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR SMALL
BUSINESS. THIS BILL ALSO
EXEMPTS TRUE BUSINESS TO
BUSINESS CONTRACTS SUCH AS
CONTRACT WITH THE LICENSE
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTOR
INCLUDING FOR SUBCONTRACTOR
CONSTRUCTION TRACKING SERVICES.
AND LET ME TALK FOR ONE MINUTE
ABOUT TRACKING BECAUSE I KNOW A
LOT OF YOU HAVE COME UP TO ME
WITH CONCERNS ABOUT TRACKING
THEIR TWO THINGS IN THIS BILL.
IF YOU ARE AN OWNER OPERATOR
AND YOU YOU LICENSE ARE YOU
CONTRACT WITH A CONSTRUCTION
COMPANY FOR THE NEXT TWO YEARS
YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
ABLE TO CONTRACT IN THAT WAY
DIRECTLY WITH A CONSTRUCTION
COMPANY THAT SUNSETS INTEREST
YOUR SO WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT AND SEE IF IT NEEDS TO BE
CLARIFIED. IF YOU ARE A OWNER
OPERATOR BASICALLY OUTSIDE OF
CONSTRUCTION THERE ARE FEW
THINGS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
YOU YOU CAN BECOME A LEGITIMATE
SMALL BUSINESS WHICH CASE YOU
CAN DIRECTLY CONTRACT WITH A
BUSINESS FOR EXAMPLE IF YOUR
FARM AND YOU NEED TO DELIVER
YOUR PRODUCT YOU CAN HIRE AN
INDIVIDUAL. HAS A SMALL AS TO
DELIVER YOUR PRODUCT. YOU DON'T
WANT TO START YOUR OWN BUSINESS
YOU CAN BECOME AN EMPLOYEE OF A
LARGER BUSINESS IF YOU'RE THAT
AN EMPLOYEE OF THAT LARGER
BUSINESS. YOU CAN ACTUALLY
UTILIZE YOUR TRUCK THAT YOU
HAVE BOUGHT IN THE BUSINESS HAS
TO REIMBURSE YOU FOR THAT SO WE
THAT'S WRITTEN SPECIFICALLY IN
THE BILL WE ARE NOT LEAVING
PEOPLE WITH A TRACK IN NO WAY
TO USE IT. WE ARE HOWEVER. IT
OF AN OUTDATED BROKER MODEL
THAT ALLOWS COMPANIES TO
BASICALLY MAKE MONEY AND SET
RATES FOR PEOPLE THAT THEY
CALLED INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
THAT ACT A LOT LIKE EMPLOYEES.
IT'S A COMPROMISE I THINK WORKS
FOR THE ACTUAL WORKER. THE
MEMINTA THE SENATE ALSO CLARIFY
THAT BUSINESS ENTITIES PERFORM
WORK. FOR CLIENT OR BUSINESS OR
REFERRAL AGENCY ARE NOT SUBJECT
TO THE TEST UNDER DYNAMAX THE
COVERED BUSINESSES AND THIS
MEANS THE REFERRAL IN AGENCY IS
NOT. COVERED THE BUSINESSES
INCLUDE GRAPHIC DESIGN WEB
DESIGN PHOTOGRAPHY TUTORING
EVENT PLANNING MINOR HOME
REPAIR MOVING HOME CLEANING
AARON'S EVENT PLANNING.
FURNITURE ASSEMBLY ANIMAL
SERVICES DOG WALKING DOG
GROOMING PICTURE HANGING POOL
CLEANING AND YARD CLEAN UP AS
LONG AS YOU HOLD A BUSINESS
LICENSE. DUE TO CONCERNS FROM
BUSINESS COMMUNITY REYES
REGARDING RETROACTIVITY THE
BILL MAKES CLEAR THAT ALL
EXEMPTIONS IN THIS BILL ARE
RETROACTIVE. IN ADDITION ANY
NEW OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE BILL
WILL BE APPLIED PROSPECTIVELY.
WORKERS COMPENSATION
REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT
RETROACTIVE IN WILL BE
EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY. AB FIVE TERRIFIED AT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
SPECIFIED CITY ATTORNEYS CAN
ENFORCE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
BY SEEKING INJUNCTIVE RELIEF TO
STOP THE EXPLOITATION OF
MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS.
COLLEAGUES AB FIVE DOESN'T
ADDRESS EVERY SINGLE ISSUE
BROUGHT TO US. BUT IT GETS
THAT'S PRETTY CLOSE THERE AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
OUTSTANDING ISSUES WITH THOSE
YOU HAVE BROUGHT SPECIFIC
INDUSTRIES TO US THAT MAKES
SENSE. IT'S A COMPROMISED
APPROACH FOR THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND ALLOWS CLARITY
FOR A LOT OF BUSINESSES AND AT
THAT SAME TIME. AND MAKE SURE
THAT THE ONE MILLION
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS IN
CALIFORNIA. GET THE WAGES AND
BENEFITS THAT THEY DESERVE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU VOTE
CONCURRENCE ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MISS GONZALEZ MISTER
O'DONNELL TO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE. WHEN
THIS BILL LAUGHED THE ASSEMBLY
I REYES SOME OBJECTIONS TO IT
AND I WAS IN HOPES THAT AS THE
BILL MOVES THROUGH THE SENATE.
THE PROBLEMS WITH THE BILL
WOULD BE FIXED IN A BROADWAY
THAT APPLY TO ALL THE DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA BUT
INSTEAD WHAT'S BEEN DONE. IS A
LAUNDRY LIST OF EXEMPTIONS HAS
BEEN NEGOTIATED THAT ANY
INDUSTRY WITH ENOUGH MONEY TO
HIRE A GOOD LOBBYIST YOU GET ON
THIS LIST ALL OF THE INDUSTRIES
THE COULDN'T ART. AND MY
BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH THAT
APPROACH. IS THAT IT STIFLES
INNOVATION AN ENTREPRENEURIAL
ISM HERE IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
WHAT ALSO IS NOT ON THAT LIST
AS ALL OF THE INDUSTRIES. THAT
ARE UP AND COMING. THAT DON'T
HAVE AN ESTABLISHED. WE DON'T.
TELL PREVENT THOSE BUSINESSES
FROM BEING STARTED HERE. WHEN I
TESTIFIED BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY I
TOLD YOU THE STORY OF HOW I
STARTED MY BUSINESS OUT OF MY
DORM ROOM THIRTY YEARS AGO. THE
BILL WOULD HAVE MADE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME TO DO THAT
BECAUSE OF THE SO CALLED B.
PILLAR. IN THE DYNAMICS TEST
AND THAT SAYS THAT YOU CAN'T
CONTRACT OUT ANY WORK THAT IS
IN THE NORMAL COURSE OF
BUSINESS FOR THE BUSINESS THAT
YOU'RE OPERATING AT ALL HAS TO
BE EMPLOYEES. I WAS A KID IN MY
DORM ROOM I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE OUR
WORKERS COMPENSATION OUR
POSTING REQUIREMENTS ARE WAGE
ORDERS OR ANY OF THAT. AND
FRANKLY IT WOULD HAVE BEEN TOO
DAUNTING FOR ME TO TRY AND
START A BUSINESS AND THINK
ABOUT COMPLYING. WITH THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. SO THAT BUSINESS
WOULD HAVE NOT BEEN STARTED
HERE WE HAVE BEEN STARTED
ELSEWHERE. AND THE HUNDREDS OF
JOBS THAT MY BUSINESS IS
CREATED IN CALIFORNIA OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS. WOULD NOT BE
IN CALIFORNIA THEY WOULD BE
ELSEWHERE. WHAT HAPPENED TO US.
CALIFORNIA USED TO BE. A PLACE
WHERE THE ENTREPRENEURIAL
SPIRIT. WAS NURTURED. WE'VE HAD
INCREDIBLE SUCCESS AND HAVING
COMPANIES START HERE COMPANIES
LIKE APPLE AND GOOGLE AND
FACEBOOK AND MY COMPANY. I FEAR
THAT IF THIS IS THE THINKING OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND THIS IS THE
THINKING OF OUR GOVERNOR I
REALLY FEAR FOR THE FUTURE OF
OUR STATE. AND ONE THING THAT I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT IN
CLOSING HERE IS THE FACT THAT.
I'M TIRED OF HEARING PEOPLE
SAY. THAT THIS BILL EMPOWERS
WORKERS THIS BILL DOES NOT
EMPOWER WORKERS THIS BILL
DISENFRANCHISES WORKERS IT
DISEMPOWERED AS WORKERS AND IF
YOU WANT PROOF OF THAT. YOU
NEED LOOK NOFURTHER. THAN THE
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDED FROM THIS
BILL WHICH ARE THE
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES LIKE UBER AND LEFT
RIGHT NOW IF YOU'RE A DRIVER
FOR THOSE TNC IS YOU GET TO
DECIDE ON YOUR OWN. WHERE YOU
POSITION YOUR VEHICLE AND WHEN
YOU DRIVE AND THAT WILL BECOME
IMPOSSIBLE AFTER THIS BILL
BECOMES LAW. AND I'VE HAD
PEOPLE SAY WELL NO THE BILL
DOESN'T DISALLOW IT WILL YES IT
DOES ACTUALLY IF YOU READ IT IT
SAYS THAT THOSE DRIVERS HAVE TO
BE EMPLOYEES WHICH MEANS THEY
HAVE TO BE PAID MINIMUM WAGE
WHICH MEANS THAT. IF YOU'RE
OVER LEFT YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO EXERCISE CONTROL OVER WE'RE
VEHICLE IS LOCATED AND WHEN A
DRIVER DRIVES YOU'RE NOT GONNA
BE ABLE TO ALLOW THE DRIVER. TO
POSITION A VEHICLE IN A BAD
SECTION OF TOWN AND DRIVE A TWO
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING BECAUSE
THEY ARE UNLIKELY TO MAKE UP
THAT MINIMUM WAGE THAT YOU'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BE REQUIRED TO PAY. SO
I FEAR THAT THIS IS REALLY
GOING TO DO DAMAGE TO OUR
ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA I URGE
YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
OPEN ALL TEAM THIS EGGMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH UP IN A SPEAKER MEMBERS I.
I RISE. ONLY I FEEL IT MY DUTY
OBLIGATION AS THE CHAIR OF BAG
TO BE ABLE TO GET UP AND SAY
THIS ISSUE THAT WE- CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT. IS TRUCKERS THAT
ARE HAULING THINGS FOR
AGRICULTURE UP AND DOWN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT REMAINS
AN ISSUE. ONE OF MY COLLEAGUE
SAID WE WILL BE DEALING WITH
THIS. ISSUE FOR THE NEXT
PROBABLY THE REST OF OUR TIME
IN THIS HOUSE WHICH I THINK IS
PROBABLY TRUE. AS THE YEARS
CONTINUE TO GO ON A NEW ISSUES
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO REVISIT THIS ISSUE.
SO I RISE ONLY TO RAISE A
CONCERN THAT I THINK THEY'RE
STILL. I APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE I THINK
THERE'S MORE NEAT WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN MISS
WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY AS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
OPPOSED TO AB FIVE. IN THE WAKE
OF THE SUPREME COURT'S DECISION
IN THE DYNAMICS CASE. IT WAS
CLEAR WE HAD TO DO SOMETHING
WITHOUT ACTION THE SUPREME.
COURT'S DECISION WOULD WRECK
OUR STATE'S ECONOMY. BUT THIS
BILL ISN'T THE ANSWER. RATHER
THAN FIXING THE WAVE WE DEFINE
AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR TO
STOP BAD ACTORS AB FIVE MAKES A
BAD LAW WITH A- LITTLE LESS BAD
AND CARVE OUTS FOR THE TRADE
GROUPS. WITH THE BEST LOBBYIST.
WHAT ABOUT THE WORKERS WHO
DON'T HAVE THOSE LOBBYIST. I
WAS FORTUNATE WHEN I STARTED MY
BUSINESS. BY HARD WORK AND IT'S
CERTAINLY HARD ENOUGH
ESPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA TO
START A BUSINESS. AND MAKE IT
SUCCESSFUL. AND YES. I HIRED
FOLKS. MANY OF THOSE WERE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. ALMOST
ALL SECOND CHANCE THERE'S- MANY
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED.
SEASONAL AND SHORT TERM
EMPLOYMENT ALLOW FLEXIBILITY IS
FOR THESE WORKERS AND OTHERS.
TO PURSUE EDUCATION WHILE
GAINING NEEDED EXPERIENCE IN
THE WORK FORCE. FOR MANY
BUSINESSES THAT WON'T BE
POSSIBLE UNDER THIS DYNAMIX
RULING. SO MANY PEOPLE HAVE
CALLED US ABOUT THEIR TYPES OF
JOBS ARE THEY EXEMPTED ARE THEY
NOT THEY WON AN EXEMPTION LIKE
EVEN THIS MORNING INTERPRETERS
FROM ESCONDIDO CALL WANTING AN
AMENDMENT TO ADD THEM IN. SO IF
WE NEED THAT MANY EXEMPTIONS
AND THE LIST. WAS I COULDN'T
WRITE FAST NOW FULLY EXEMPTIONS
IT'S BASICALLY LIKE A SWISS
CHEESE WITH A LOT OF HOLES IN
IT. AT SOME POINT IT'S JUST NOT
A GOOD BILL. GET WORKERS WILL
LOSE THE FLEXIBILITY TO WORK
WHEN AND WHERE THEY WANT IT'S
ABOUT HOW THEY WANT TO RUN
THEIR LIVES MANY WILL SEE THEIR
WORK OPPORTUNITIES ELIMINATED.
THE IMPACT OF THE DYNAMICS
DECISION WILL BE TRAGIC AND
SEVERE FOR WORKERS WHO RELY ON
CONTRACTING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
OR BUILD THE BUSINESS OF THEIR
OWN. WE OWE IT TO THEM TO
DELIVER A THOUGHTFULLY CRAFTED
SOLUTION. THAT STOPS MISS
CLASSIFICATION WHILE PROTECTING
THE INDEPENDENCE OF CONTRACTORS
WHO VALUE THEIR FREEDOM TO WORK
WHEN AND WHEN THEY ONCE WERE.
IN THIS BILL FALLS SHORT OF
THAT STANDARD AND I URGE NO
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WALDRON
MEMBERS OF YOUR SEEKING
RECOGNITION PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MIKE'S. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND I'LL JUST SAY THAT.
IF WE DON'T PASS THIS BILL
THERE ARE NO EXEMPTIONS
NOBODY'S GONNA BE EXAM BECAUSE
IT'S ALREADY IT'S A DREAM COURT
DECISION SO EVERYBODY'S GONNA
HAVE TO FOLLOW THESE RULES THIS
BILL ALLOWS THE BUSINESSES.
THAT ARE IN THE BILL TO HAVE AN
EXEMPTION WHERE THEY WOULDN'T
OTHERWISE HAVE IT BECAUSE IT'S
ALREADY THE LAW OF THE LAND.
NOW BEFORE I CAME HERE. I HAD A
SHORT STAND IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR I WORKED IN PRIVATE
SECTOR FOR A COUPLE YEARS AND I
WAS IT WAS CLASSIFIED WORKER. I
WORK FOR A COMPANY THAT WAS
OWNED BY BAYER CORPORATION. AND
THEY MADE AN INDEPENDENT COP
ACTOR THEY MADE ME AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR. BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T WANT HAVE TO PAY
THE BENEFITS OF WHAT THEY WOULD
PLAY A NORMAN CHLOE HOWEVER. IF
I WAS AN EMPLOYEE I WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE WHICH I DIDN'T HAVE A
WHOLE TIME I DON'T HAVE ANY
HEALTH INSURANCE IT WOULD MEAN
A LOT MORE BENEFITS THAT I
WOULD'VE BEEN ABLE TO BEEN
AFFORDED HAD I NOT BEEN DEEMED
AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR BUT
MY WORK LOAD WAS SO RIGOROUS
THAT THERE WAS NO WAY I COULD
HAVE BEEN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR WAS NO WAY I WASN'T
ESTABLISHED BUSINESS THERE WAS
NO WAY THAT I'M COULD HAVE HAD
ENOUGH TIME TO TAKE ON ANY
OTHER CLIENTS THEY WERE MY ONLY
CLIENT THAT WAS ALL THE
WORKLOAD. WAS TOO GREAT THE
SCHEDULE WAS TOO DEMANDING AND
SO I WAS AN EMPLOYEE THAT WAS
CLASSIFIED AS AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR AND I WAS TREATED AS
SUCH EVEN THOUGH THE WORK I WAS
DOING WAS THE WORK OF AN
EMPLOYEE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION TO HAVE AND WHAT
IS FORCE US TO DO NOT JUST US
IN CALIFORNIA BUT IT'S FORCED
THE NATION TO TAKE A LOOK WHAT
THE WHAT THE FUTURE OF WORK IS
GONNA LOOK LIKE SO THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT. AND IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US THOUGH CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I CAN'T
SAY THAT OUR TRADITIONAL IDEA
OF WHAT WORK IS EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
IF THAT'S ALL THAT THERE IS I
CAN'T SIT HERE AND TELL YOU THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION I THINK
IT'S ON US TO CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE THIS BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO STOP CREATIVITY YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO STOP INNOVATION IF
THEY CONTINUE TO HAPPEN AND OUR
WORK. OUR OUR LABOR LAWS NEED
TO CONTINUE TO FOR THE ABILITY
FOR US TO ALLOW ALL TYPES OF
WORKERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO THIS CONVERSATION
ISN'T STOP HERE BUT I REALLY
COMMEND THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR
NOT FOR ANYTHING AND SHE'S DONE
AND I COMMEND EVERYBODY ON ALL
SIDES COME TOGETHER ON THIS
RECEIPT. IN IT'S IMPORTANT THE
CONVERSATION ISN'T OVER. HEY
BUT TODAY THIS IS THE ACTION
THAT NEEDS TO BE TAKEN SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON
MISTER WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU AMANDA SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AYE AYE AYE AYE RISE I
I'D SUPPORT THE BILL WHEN IT
WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT I DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT SOME
OF THE BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIPS SPECIFICALLY
AROUND HOSPITALS AND NURSING
REGISTRIES SO. WHILE PARTS OF
THIS MAY WORK REALLY WELL IN
LARGE URBAN AREAS WE RELY ON
NURSING REGISTRIES IN SOME OF
OUR RURAL AREAS TO HELP
SUPPLEMENT NURSING STAFF IT'S
HARD TO GET NURSES TO SOME
COMMUNITIES IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT YOU PAY PEOPLE SOMETIMES
TO LIVE IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
THEY SIMPLY MAY NOT WANT TO
LIVE THERE AND SO I HAVE REAL
CONCERNS THAT THAT THIS PART OF
THIS. MAY NEED TO BE LOOKED AT
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT WE WORK
TOGETHER WITH THEIR OWN
SYNDICATE BUT I THINK THAT THIS
COULD HAVE A DETRIMENTAL EFFECT
TO ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES AROUND
HOSPITALS IF WE DON'T FIX THIS
PART OF IT SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT I
LOOK FOR TO WORKING ON THIS IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU MISTER
WHAT MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I MOVED TO
AMEND THE BILL IN CHIEF TO
EXEMPT OWNER OPERATOR TRUCKERS
WITH OWNING FIVE TRUCKS OR LESS
.
MR GALLAGHER THE BILL IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE SO WE CANNOT
AMENDED ON THE FLOOR AT THIS
TIME. WELL I WOULD I WOULD JUST
ASK THAT WE DO THE SAME THING
THAT WE'VE DONE FOR SEVERAL
OTHER BILLS THIS WEEK WAVING
RULES TO MAKE AMENDMENTS. TO
ADDRESS URGENT ISSUES AND I
BELIEVE THAT THIS THIS INDUSTRY
IS ONE THAT DESERVES THAT
RECOGNITION. MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THE
GENTLEMAN TO NICOLAS WOULD LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT THE BILL HE'S
MORE THAN WELCOME TO DO SO BUT
THIS IS THE BASED ON THE BILL.
HE NEEDS TO KEEP HIS COMMENTS
SPECIFIC TO THE DEBATE. ON THE
SPECIFIC ITEM. SEVEN THREE
GALLAGHER AMENDMENTS ARE NOT IN
ORDER AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK ON THE BILL. AND I WOULD
ASK THAT WE SUSPEND THE RULES
SO THAT WE CAN AMEND THE BILL
IN CHIEF AS I REQUESTED. AND
NATION IS SPANISH RULES AT THIS
TIME IS A VIOLATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND IS OUT OF
ORDER. IT'S ALSO A VIOLATION OF
THE CONSTITUTION NOT TO HAVE
AMENDMENTS IMPRINT SEVENTY TWO
HOURS IN ADVANCE AND WE HAVE
BROKEN NOT ROLL SEVERAL TIMES.
IS YOUR GALLAGHER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SPEAK ON THE BILL. I
WOULD LIKE A VOTE ON MY MOTION
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BROUGHT THIS UP AS AN
ISSUE AND- AND WOULD LIKE TO
VOTE. ON THE ABILITY TO AMEND
THIS BILL. YOUR POINT OF ORDER
IS NOT WELL TAKEN IN YOUR
MOTION IS OUT OF ORDER I'M
SORRY I HAVE APPEALED THE
RULING OF THE CHAIR
. MISTER
GALLAGHER IS APPEALING THE
RULING OF THE CHAIR WE WILL
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON MISTER.
THE QUESTION BEFORE THE BODY.
IS SHALL DECISION OF THE CHAIR
BE OVERRULED. MR AT GALLAGHER
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE. IN A DEBATE THE APPEAL.
LOOK AT THE EXIT DOOR TO TAKE
THE MAJORITY OF THOSE PRESENT
IN VOTING. AND YOU GET TWO
MINUTES TO SPEAK ON YOUR BILL
MISTER GALLAGHER. THANK YOU
MADAM. SHARE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXERCISE MY RIGHTS. AND THIS IS
ALSO THIS BODIES. OPPORTUNITY
TO EXERCISE ITS RIGHTS. THIS IS
A BIG DEAL WE ALL KNOW THAT AND
SEVERAL PEOPLE OF ALREADY
SPOKEN. ABOUT HOW THIS BILL IN
THE WAY THAT THINGS HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTED ONLY CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES HAVE GOTTEN
EXEMPTIONS AND IT DOES SEEM
LIKE. THOSE THAT HAVE THE BEST
LOBBYISTS. THOSE THAT ARE
WEALTHIER INDUSTRIES HAVE
GOTTEN THOSE. THOSE EXEMPTIONS
FROM THIS BILL WHILE OTHERS
HAVE NOT. WE'RE THE VOICE OF
THOSE PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE A
LOBBYIST. AND ONE OF THOSE IS
THE TRUCKERS WHO'D JUST EARLIER
LAST WEEK YOU HEARD THEM ALL
HONKING OUTSIDE. THAT'S THEIR
VOICE BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO WORK.
THEY HAVE TO WORK EVERY DAY AND
TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE. MANY
OF THOSE TRUCKERS ARE MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES ARE GALLAGHER
ASK THE SPEAK TO AMERICA YOUR
APPEAL YOU CAN ALSO SPEAK TO
THE MERITS OF THE BILL THAT
YOU'VE ASKED TO SPEAK TO YOUR
APPEAL I WILL CONTINUE TO THE
TO SPEAK TO THE MERITS OF THIS
APPEAL WHICH IS. US HAVING THE
RIGHT TO SAY NO WE'RE GOING TO
DO THINGS A DIFFERENT WAY. WE
STILL HAVE THIS BILL WE HAVE
THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CHANGE WE CAN SUSPEND THE
RULES. AS WE DID FOR OTHER
BILLS THIS WEEK. WHEN WE
THOUGHT IT WAS URGENT ENOUGH.
TO SOLVE THAT PUBLIC POLICY
ISSUE. OUR OWNER OPERATOR
TRUCKERS. THIS IS THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL THEY WORK FOR A
LOT OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE THEY
CONTRACT INDEPENDENTLY. AND
THEY HALL OF. GOODS THAT YOU
ALL OF EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM
THIRTY SECOND RELIES. ON EACH
AND EVERY DAY. THE VERY LEAST
THAT THEY DESERVE SOME
RECOGNITION IN THIS IF WE STILL
GOT TO FIGURE IT OUT GIVE THEM
THE EXEMPTION NOW. I BEG YOU
MEMBERS DO THE RIGHT THING
WHAT'S ON YOUR CONSCIENCE. WE
CAN DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY AND
WE SHOULD. THANK YOU MISTER
GALLAGHER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE THE QUESTION OF THE
BODY IS WHETHER TO OVERRULE THE
DECISION OF THE CHAIR MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR. A NO
VOTE MISTER GALLAGHER IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THIS IS A
MAJORITY OF THOSE PRESENT AND
VOTING MISTER CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. MISTER
GALLAGHER IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE AGAIN MISTER GALLAGHER
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR
NO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE
. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTEEN KNOWS FIFTY. THE
RULING OF THE CHAIR IS
SUSTAINED JUST FOR A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION THE DESK HAS
INFORMED ME THAT THE BILL HAS
BEEN IN PRINT IN ITS CURRENT
FORM SINCE SEPTEMBER SIXTH AT
EIGHT PM. MORE THAN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS MOVING BACK TO DEBATE ON.
AMERICA THE BILL. THIS RACE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I RISE. IN
FAVOR OF AB FIVE AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW I IN MY PRIOR LIFE I WAS A
WORKERS COMPENSATION ATTORNEY
REPRESENTING INJURED WORKERS
AND IN THAT CAPACITY I HAVE
MANY WORKERS WHO WERE DENIED
WORKERS COMPENSATION BENEFITS
BECAUSE THEY WERE CLASSIFIED AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS IN ALL
OF THESE CASES WE HAVE TO GO TO
TRIAL AND ALL OF THESE CASES WE
WON BECAUSE WE WERE ABLE TO
PROVE THAT REALITY THEY WERE
EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE BEEN
PROTECTED UNDER OUR WORKERS
COMPENSATION. LAWS. AS OUR
MEMBER FROM WHAT HERE IS
INDICATED IT MAY NOT BE THE
PERFECT BILL BUT WITHOUT A
DOUBT IT IS A NECESSARY BILL WE
NEED TO HAVE SOMETHING IN. IN
PRINT SOME WE NEED TO PASS THE
LAW THAT PROTECTS OUR WORKERS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
COVERED AS WORKERS AND NOT MISS
CLASSIFIED AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
WRATH MR BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE AND THANK
THE AUTHOR FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
THE VERY HARD WORK THAT SHE'S
PUT IN OVER MANY MONTHS ON THIS
BILL. WHILE THE MACRO ECONOMY
IN CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO DO
PRETTY WELL THERE ARE A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR STATE WHO
HAVE NOT REAP THE BENEFITS OF
THAT ECONOMY. I'M IN A
PARTICULAR WE KNOW THAT GIG
WORKERS WHO ARE OUT THERE ARE
NOT REALLY SHARING IN THAT
ECONOMY THEY'RE MAKING VERY
SMALL AMOUNTS OF MONEY THEY'RE
NOT GETTING THE BENEFITS. THAT
THAT OTHER WORKERS GET. UP SO
THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS OUT
THERE WHO ARE NOT SHARING IN
THE ECONOMIC BENEFIT OF THE OF
THE RESURGENCE OF OUR ECONOMY
OVER THE PAST DECADE OR SO. AND
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG WHEN
THE OWNERS OF SOME COMPANIES
WALK AWAY WITH BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND THEIR WORKERS ARE
NOT ABLE TO MAKE ENDS MEET AND
DO NOT RECEIVE BENEFITS THAT
THEY SHOULD BE ENTITLED TO. THE
AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED MANY
AMENDMENTS ON THIS BILL FOR
GOOD REASON THIS IS A VERY VERY
COMPLICATED LANDSCAPE. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF PRUNING THAT'S
NECESSARY. I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS MANY OF THESE ISSUES
MANY OF THE AREAS OF EMPLOYMENT
THAT STILL NEED WORK I'M ONE OF
THOSE THAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT.
A PARTICULARLY IN MY DISTRICT
BUT REALLY ACROSS THE STATE. IS
THAT OF MUSICIANS AND WHILE
SOME MUSICIANS ARE COVERED
BECAUSE IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT
THEIR EMPLOYEES IN THE SETTING
THAT THEIR THAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY IN. SUMMER NOT AND I
DID WANT TO ASK A QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR MADAM SPEAKER. AND
THAT IS WHETHER OR NOT. A
CONSIDERATION HAS BEEN GIVEN TO
THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE NOT CLEARLY
COVERED GAG MUSICIANS WHO ARE
NOT CLEARLY COVERED AS AN
EMPLOYEES TODAY. MISS GONZALEZ
YOU MAY ANSWER YEAH I WANNA
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION I
WOULD SAY THAT THOSE MUSICIANS
PROBABLY FALL INTO A FEW
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT PAGE NINE SUBDIVISION
SEE SUBSECTION TWO PARAGRAPHS
SIX YOU'LL NOTICE THAT THERE IS
AN EXEMPTION. IF A FINE ARTIST
AND I WOULD SUGGEST IN FACT I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
MUSICIANS ARE FINE ARTIST IF
THEY ACTUALLY QUALIFY UNDER A
DIFFERENT. SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES
THEY BASICALLY SET THEIR OWN
RATES RUN THEIR OWN BUSINESS
THAT THEY ARE IN FACT ALREADY
IN THIS BILL HOWEVER I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF CONCERN.
AND I KNOW THAT THE DISCUSSIONS
BETWEEN THE ROUTE RECORDING
ARTISTS AND THE ENTERTAINMENT
UNIONS BROKE DOWN AND- THEIR
SPECIFIC. EXEMPTION WAS TAKE
THE LANGUAGE WAS TAKEN OUT
BECAUSE THEY SAID THEY'D RATHER
HAVE NOTHING THEN THE LANGUAGE
THAT THEY HAD COME UP WITH. SO
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
REFINE THAT LANGUAGE AND MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY'S COVERED BUT
I'D SAY RIGHT NOW IF YOU'RE
WORKING AS AN INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS. BASICALLY SELLING
YOUR SERVICES AS A FINE ARTIST
THAT YOU'RE UNDER YOUR OWN
CONTROL YOU COULD BE PERFORMING
IN FACT AT THE- THE EMPLOYERS.
PLACE OR YOUR OWN I USE IT AS
LONG AS YOU'RE SETTING YOUR OWN
RATES IN YOUR UNDER YOUR OWN
CONTROL I THINK THAT YOU FALL
UNDER THAT FINE ARTISTS
EXEMPTION. THANK YOU ASKED
OFFICER BLOOM MY TIME MADAM
SPEAKER. I APPRECIATE THE
RESPONSE AND- A TAKE THAT IS
THE INTENT OF THE AUTHOR TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE'S AMBIGUITY
OR THAT THEY NEED TO BE MORE
WORK ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
I'LL COMMIT TO. PROVIDING MY
INPUT AND HELP ON RESOLVING THE
ISSUE AND THE- UPCOMING A
SECOND YEAR. OF OUR OF OUR TWO
YEAR SESSION AGAIN I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR ALL THE HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL AND I. URGE ALL
MEMBERS TO VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM MISTER PATTERSON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK MEDI
SPEAKER MEMBERS I BUY RICE OUT
IN OPPOSITION AB. THE VERY.
FACT OF THE DISCUSSION THAT
WE'RE HAVING ON THIS FLOOR
RIGHT NOW. IT ALMOST SOUNDS TO
ME. LIKE EXEMPTIONS OUR GUESTS
UP FOR NEGOTIATION AND THEY'RE
UP FOR AUCTION. THIS IS A VERY
TROUBLING PROCESS THAT YOU'RE
GOING THROUGH RIGHT NOW. WHICH
IS TO TREAT. I TENTATIVELY
PLACED INDIVIDUALS. IN
DIFFERENT. CIRCUMSTANCES AND
CALLING THEM ONE THING WHEN
THEY'RE NOT. LET ME JUST SAY
THIS. FUNDAMENTALLY WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION. TO PASSED JUST LAWS.
PART OF JUST LAWMAKING IS TO BE
VERY VERY CLEAR. THAT WE ARE
NOT STEPPING OVER A VERY
IMPORTANT LINE WHICH IS EQUAL
PROTECTION UNDER THE LAW. WE
HAVE MANY IDENTICALLY PLACED
PEOPLE. WHO ARE NOT EQUALLY
PROTECTED IN THIS LAW. WE ARE.
PLAYING A POLITICAL RUSSIAN
ROULETTE. WITH THEIR LIVES
THEIR LIVELIHOOD. AND THEIR
LABOR. BUT WE'RE ALSO DOING
HERE IS SETTING UP A CATEGORY.
THAT IS PROTECTED FROM THE
COURTS. LEAVING. MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS I'M PROTECTED FROM
THE COURT. AND WE'RE SUGGESTING
THAT SOMEHOW THIS IS A SOLUTION.
ALSO WE'RE WE'RE MAKING LAW
HERE. THAT WE KEEP SAYING WELL
WE'RE GOING TO VISIT THIS WILL
VISIT IT NEXT YEAR THE YEAR
AFTER THE YEAR AFTER. WE'RE
BASICALLY. ON THE FLY. TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHO WERE GOING TO
PENALIZE AND WHO WE ARE GOING
TO GIVE A SAFE HARBOR TO. THAT
IS NOT OBJECTIVE Là MAKING IT
IS NOT FAIR LAW MAKING. IT IS
VERY MUCH SUBJECTIVE LAWMAKING
WE'RE ON A SLIPPERY SLOPE HERE
AND THAT'S WHY YOU ARE SEEING
SO MUCH ANGST AND SO MUCH
CONCERN ABOUT WHY IS MY
BUSINESS MODEL IDENTICAL TO
THEIR BUSINESS MODEL AND THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL IS PROTECTED AND
MINE IS NOT. I FEAR THAT APART
FROM. PERHAPS MAKING SOME SAFE
HARBORS FOR COURT ACTIVITY THE.
APPROACH HERE CHOOSING WINNERS
AND LOSERS IN LIKE SITUATED
CIRCUMSTANCES IS GOING TO OPEN
IN MY JUDGMENT THE FLOODGATE.
OF LITIGATION. AND I THOUGHT
THAT'S WHAT WE WERE SUPPOSED TO
BE ABOUT TRYING TO REMEDY AND
SO I APPRECIATE. THE
CONVERSATION HERE. LET'S
REMEMBER WE ARE TREATING LIKE
PEOPLE. THEN ON LIKE WAYS YES
THIS IS A YEAH I THINK THIS IS
FUNDAMENTALLY OF LEGISLATING ON
VERY VERY TRICKY TERRITORY
HERE. AND LAST. YOU CONSIDER
THAT I'M EXAGGERATING THERE ARE
SEVERAL COURT CASES RIGHT NOW
THAT ARE WINNING CHALLENGES
AGAINST THIS BODY. FOR
LEGISLATING AND CROSSING THE
LINE OF EQUAL PROTECTION UNDER
THE LAW AND SO I'M GOING TO BE
OF NO VOTE AND I SUGGEST THAT
IN THE INTEREST OF FAIRNESS OUT
TO ALL OF THAT THIS BILL. NEEDS
TO BE DEFEATED AND IT NEEDS TO
BE REWORKED SO THAT WE ARE FAIR
TO EVERYBODY IN LIKE
CIRCUMSTANCES. OR WE SHOULDN'T
DO ANYTHING AT ALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON
MISTER LEVINE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. IF YOU'RE A MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE.
THIS CLASSIFICATION HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM FOR A LONG TIME AND AS
THE CHAIR OF LABOUR KNOWS IN AS
THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL KNOWS I
HAVE ALSO. BEEN WORKING TO
RAISE THE PLIGHT OF
SUBCONTRACTED LABOR SOME OF THE
WEALTHIEST CORPORATIONS IN OUR
STATE IN THE WEALTHIEST
CORPORATIONS ON EARTH HAVE
BEEN. SUBCONTRACTING LABOR TO
PAY THEM LESS OFTEN WOMEN OFTEN
IMMIGRANTS OFTEN IN JANITORIAL
OR FOOD SERVICE ROLES TO PUT
THEM OFF THEIR BOOKS. AND THEY
ARE NOT PAID WITH THE DIGNITY
ANDRESPECT OF OTHER EMPLOYEES
THAT BRING VALUE TO CALL THESE
COMPANIES BUT OF COURSE THESE
COMPANIES COULDN'T EXIST
WITHOUT THE HELP OF THE SUB
CONTRACTED LABOR AS WELL. SO I
LOOK FOR TO VOTING FOR THIS I
ALSO LOOK FORTY COMING BACK IN
JANUARY AND ADDRESSING THE
PLIGHT OF SOME CAUGHT
SUBCONTRACTED LABOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LANE MISTER
GRAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. I
WASN'T SURE IF I WAS GOING TO
RISE AND SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE
BUSINESS TO THE BAIT. I FIND
MYSELF PROBABLY THINKING WHAT A
LOT OF MEMBERS ON THIS FOR
THINKING WHICH IS A FALSE
CHOICE. THE FORCE. THERE'S A
LOT OF SPECIAL INTERESTS THAT
BEEN TAKEN CARE OF IN THIS BILL
AS WE LOOK AT THE THREE PART
TEST AND RECOGNIZE THAT THAT'S
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL FOR THE
ENTIRE ECONOMY THE COURT IN
ESSENCE AND THEY WOULD ARGUE
THEY INTERPRETED THE LAW THEY
REWROTE THE LAW THEY REWROTE
THE TEST THAT QUESTION SHOULD
NOW BE BACK BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE FOR US TO ESTABLISH
A TEST THAT WORKS. FOR THE
ENTIRE ECONOMY. END IF I
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY. I HELP
SOME. PROBABLY DAMAGE THE
INTEREST OF OTHERS GOING
FORWARD THEIR ABILITY TO SEEK
AMENDMENTS LATER AS AS- AS THE
AUTHOR HAS SUGGESTED A FURTHER
CLARIFICATION AS OTHER MEMBERS
HAVE SUGGESTED CLARIFICATION OF
WHAT HAPPENED IF IT DOES HAPPEN
WILL HAPPEN FOR THE POLITICALLY
POPULAR SPECIAL INTEREST MOSTLY
DOMINATED BY COASTAL AND LA AND
SAN FRANCISCO. CERTAINLY THOSE
OF US THAT REPRESENTS RURAL
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE WON'T
FIND YOURSELF IN A POSITION TO
GET THE RIGHT CAR ABOUT TO GET
THE EXEMPTION. AND IF IN FACT.
WE HAVE A THREE PART TEST THAT
WORKS FOR THE ECONOMY WHY ARE
WE DOING EXEMPTIONS AT ALL. WHY
ARE WE REQUIRE WRITING THE
THREE PART TEST. TO AN
APPROPRIATE DEFINITION NOW THAT
WORK MAY BE TOUGH AND I DON'T
BEGRUDGE THE. DIFFICULTY IN THE
LAYERS OF THIS ISSUE THAT I
KNOW THE AUTHOR OTHERS HAVE
STRUGGLED. TO NAVIGATE BUT I
DON'T THINK HERE IN THIS. THE
BILL BEFORE US WE'VE SOLVE THE
ISSUE DO WE WANT TO PROVIDE
SOME PROTECTION PERHAPS AGAINST
LITIGATION FOR AFFECTED
INDUSTRIES RIGHT AWAY I THINK
THAT PROBABLY MAKES SENSE. BUT
WE HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH WE
HAVEN'T GONE FAR ENOUGH WE
HAVEN'T COME UP WITH A SOLUTION
FOR ALL AND WHAT WE HAVE IS AND
I OWE YOU A PROMISE TO FIX
THINGS LATER. AND MEMBERS I'VE
SEEN TOO MANY I OR USE. IN THIS
INSTITUTION TO ME IS A BY HEARD
ALL WE'RE GOING TO TAKE CARE.
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY LATER
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE CARE OF
AGRICULTURE LATER. AND IT NEVER
HAPPENS. SO I FIND MYSELF IN A
POSITION TODAY. TO CAST NO
VOTE. I WOULD ENCOURAGE ALL. TO
CAP NOBLE ON THE BILL BEFORE
IT. THANK YOU MISTER GRAY AGAIN
MEMBERS OF YOUR SEEKING
RECOGNITION PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MIKE'S MISS COM LONGER W. ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY I
KNOW THAT THE TALK IN THE
CHAMBERS HAS BEEN MOSTLY AROUND
THE GIG ECONOMY AND I CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT THE GIG ECONOMY
DEBATE TO SUCK THE LIFE OUT OF
THE ROOM ON THIS VERY
COMPLICATED THIS VERY NEW ONES
THIS VERY MULTI LAYERED ISSUE
THAT IN ALL HONESTY AS WE'VE
HEARD DESERVES PROBABLY MORE
BILLS AND CERTAINLY MUCH MORE
TIME AND DEBATE. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE AS A STATE WE MUST
RESPOND THE SUPREME COURT
RULING. AND THIS BILL. IS A
FIRST STEP I WANT TO. THANK AND
CONGRATULATE THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL FOR STEPPING UP TO THE
PLATE AND INTO THE FIRE TO WORK
ON THIS ISSUE. I ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS THAT WE NEED TO
SUPPORT OUR WORKERS I ALSO ECHO
THE CONCERNS THAT WE NEED TO
NOT FORGET ABOUT THE BUSINESS
TO BUSINESS RELATIONSHIPS I
THINK I SPOKE ABOUT THIS WHEN
IT CAME BEFORE US IN THE
ASSEMBLY A COUPLE OF MONTHS
TAKE OUT OF A MONTHS AGO. YOU
KNOW I HEARING FROM A NUMBER OF
CONSTITUENTS IN DISTRICT FROM A
COUPLE OF IT TREES FROM OUR
HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY AND FROM
OUR ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY ON
THE OF CARE SIDE SMALL
BUSINESSES LIKE DENTISTS YOU
KNOW WHO A CONTRACT WITH HIGH
GENUS OR SPECIALISTS OR DENTAL
SURGEONS WANTING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE. BUSINESSES WHERE
FOLKS ACTUALLY LIKE BEING
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AREN'T.
HAVE UNRAVELED THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY'S
STYLISTS DESIGNERS EDITORS WHO
MAY BE CONSIDERED FINE ARTISTS
UNDER THE PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL ARE NOT ALSO COMPROMISED
SO I AM CERTAINLY PLEDGING TO
VOTE ON THIS BILL I'M AND I'M
ALSO PLEDGING TO COME UP TO
COMMIT MYSELF TO COMING TO THE
TABLE AS WE WORK ON MAKING THIS
FIRST STEP BETTER. BECAUSE WE
ARE A VERY DIVERSE. THE VERY
LARGE POPULATION IN A VERY VERY
COMPLICATED ECONOMY AND MANY OF
OUR REGIONAL ECONOMIES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE ACTUALLY DRIVEN
BY OUR SMALL BUSINESSES THAT I
AM SURE WE ALL WANT TO PROTECT
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE FOLKS
WHO ARE WORKERS WHO ARE
EMPLOYEES. ARE TREATED AS SUCH
AND GIVEN THE DIGNITY THAT THEY
SERVE TO PRESERVE SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS AND I. THINK
THAT YOU HEAR FROM FOLKS WHO
ARE YOUR ALLIES IN THIS FIGHT
THAT WE ARE COMMITTED TO MAKING
SURE THAT THIS BILL BECOMES A
BILL THAT'S ACTUALLY TRULY
REFLECTIVE OF THE DIVERSITY AND
THE STRENGTH OF THIS ECONOMY
AND STATE SOMETHING. AND I URGE
AN AYE VOTE ON AB FIVE THANK
YOU MISS COM LETTER TO HAVE
MISTER LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. RISE TO.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE AS WE HAVE A VEHICLE
IN FRONT OF US. ALSO DO WANT TO
SHARE A NUMBER OF OUTSTANDING
ISSUES THAT. NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED NOT JUST WITH RESPECT
TO SOME OF THE THINGS AND OTHER
COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED. BUT
TAXI CAB DRIVERS THAT OF TOM
INTEREST. AND YES THAT OF THE
GIG ECONOMY I'VE NOT HEARD THE
CONVERSATION WITH RESPECT TO
THE GIG ECONOMY. AND AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM SILICON
VALLEY. BACK OFFICE HOW DO WE
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE GIG
ECONOMY. I'M SURE MAJORITY OF
YOU HAVE ANY OF THESE APPS ON
YOUR PHONE AND YOU'VE UTILIZED
THEM I'M SURE YOU HAVE EQUALLY
DONE YOUR HOMEWORK TO ASK THE
CONVERSATION AND ASKED THE
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT IS IT LIKE
TO DRIVE. WHAT IS YOUR
EXPERIENCE LIKE AND LET ME TELL
YOU WHAT THAT CONVERSATION AS
LIGHT FROM A NUMBER OF THEM
SAYING THAT THEY ARE TEACHERS
OR THEIR SINGLE MOTHERS TRYING
TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH COST OF
LIVING PEOPLE JUST TRYING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET. PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION AS SEEN ON OUTSIDE
IS DEMONIZATION DEMONIZATION OF
INDUSTRY THAT IS CALIFORNIA
BORN WITH RESPECT INNOVATION IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND IN OUR STATE.
I LET ME JUST REMIND THIS
LEGISLATURE THAT THERE WAS A
BALLOT PROPOSITION IN A BALLOT
PROPONENT LAST YEAR. WHO WE HAD
A SENSE OF URGENCY IN THIS
LEGISLATURE TO SAY NO WE DO NOT
WANT TO SEE SOMETHING ON THE
BALLOT THEREFORE LET US FIX
THIS IN THE LEGISLATURE MEMBERS
AS A POINT OF FACT THERE IS
CLOSE AT NINE MILLION DOLLAR
BALLOT MEASURE. THE GATE CON TO
TRY AND FIX THIS ISSUE I THINK
IT'S UP TO A COMPROMISE AND YET
THERE'S NO SENSE OF URGENCY FOR
US TO TRY TO KEEP UP WITH A
COMPROMISE HERE BECAUSE IT
MIGHT BE TALK. AND SO I URGE
CAN WHEN THINKING ABOUT THE D.
IS EIGHT AND A- FIRST THEM. NOT
TO COMPLETE FOR THE- AND WHAT
IS FACT THE CONSUMER HAS SENT
TO LET US WORK WITH. SECTORS IN
SAYING THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU EXIST WE RECOGNIZE THAT YOU
HAVE SIGNIFICANT VALUE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO
HOLD YOU TO ACCOUNT AND PARTNER
TO MAKING SURE THAT THE
COMMUNITY AND SOCIETY IN THE
ECONOMY WORKS FOR EVERYONE. NOT
JUST FOR THE EXECUTIVES AND C.
SUITE BUT FOR ALL WORKERS ALIKE
BUT THIS CONVERSATION ON THE
OUTSIDE AND INSIDE HAS BEEN
SIMPLY WE DON'T WANT TO TOUCH
IT IT'S TOO MUCH OF A POLITICAL
POLITICAL NIGHTMARE WE DON'T
WANT TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
AND YET WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
AND SO LET US THINK ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL HIGH POP OR SEE THAT
IS THIS WHEN WE SAY THAT WE
WANT TO TAKE SOMETHING ABOUT.
FOR A PREVIOUS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND YET WE DON'T
WANT DO ANYTHING WE'RE JUST
GONNA COMPLETELY NOR THE SO
THIS IS OUR DUTY THIS IS OUR
JOB AS STATE LET WE'RE ELECTED
BY THE PEOPLE TO FIX THESE
PROBLEMS. AND SO WHILE I AM
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS LEGISLATION
BEFORE. AS IT IS A VIçT ONE
THIS IS. A GREAT AMOUNT OF WORK
BY LEADERS FROM THE MEMBER FROM
SAN DIEGO. I ALSO WANT TO SPEAK
UP FOR INNOVATION ECONOMY
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT. AND LOSS IN THIS
CONVERSATION THAT WE MUST HOLD
THEM TO ACCOUNT WE MUST. AND
THEY HAVE BEEN HERE. THEY HAVE
BEEN HERE IN SACRAMENTO WITH A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT. THIS
LEGISLATURE MY COLLEAGUES TO
THINK COLLABORATIVELY. ABOUT
WHAT WE DO IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE THEIR NUMBERS
OUTSTANDING ISSUES. THAT NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED. I'LL BUT LET
US MOVE THIS BOARD FOR THE
PROTECTION OF THE WORKER. AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE DO THIS IN
PARTNERSHIP. AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL OF THIS
MEASURE. URGE CAUTION MEN THINK
ABOUT WHAT WE ARE DOING TOWARDS
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU MISTER
LOWE. SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION MISTER
SPEAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS I RISE TO ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING AB FIVE.
EACH YEAR WE VOTE ON A HANDFUL
OF ISSUES THAT WILL HAVE A%
LASTING IMPACT. ON OUR STATE
AND THIS IS THIS IS ONE SUCH
DEL. TECHNOLOGY IS OUR FUTURE
WE ALL KNOW THAT AND THE TECH
COMPANIES ARE CERTAINLY LOOKING
IN THAT DIRECTION. SADLY WHAT
THEY- IS THE PLACE WHERE
WORKERS EITHER GIVE UP THEIR
JOBS TO MACHINES OR HAVE THEIR
WORK LIVES BROKEN INTO TINY
PIECES. THE GIG ECONOMY IS
BASED ON FUTURE RELATIONSHIPS
BUT WITH OUTDATED AND FEUDAL
WORK RELATIONSHIPS. THAT'S THE
ONLY AFFORD A USE OF THE SPEECH.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT THE SO
CALLED RIGHT SHARE APP
COMPANIES WANT TO PROVIDE RIDES
WITH DRIVERLESS CARS. BUT WE
CANNOT ALLOW THEM TO PAVE THE
WAY TO THAT FUTURE BY CRUSHING
THE DREAMS AND THE LIVES OF
WORKERS. I ENVISION A FUTURE
WHERE PEOPLE ARE ENTITLED TO
DECENT JOBS AND HAVE HEALTHCARE.
AND HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY
FOR HOUSING AND WITH A DECENT
ENVIRONMENT TO JOIN ON THEIR
TIME OFF. THE FLEXIBILITY TO
WORK THREE JOBS TO MAKE A
LIVING IS NOT FREEDOM. I ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB FIVE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER IS
CONSOLIDATING MY CLOSE THANK
YOU AND I DO WANT TO ADDRESS A
FEW COMMENTS MADE ON THIS FLOOR.
I THINK IT'S HIGHLY OFFENSIVE.
TO SUGGEST. THAT WE NEED TO
START OVER. CONTRA ARE ARE A
RULES ABOUT INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS WERE CREATED IN THE
COURTS TO TEST CALLED CARRILLO.
IN THE SUPREME COURT AFTER
YEARS OF SEEN MISS
CLASSIFICATION LAWSUITS THAT
CLEARLY HAD BAD EMPLOYERS
TRYING TO CIRCUMVENT THE LAW.
SEVEN SUPREME COURT JUSTICES
FROM DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS
UNANIMOUSLY UNANIMOUSLY
CONSIDERED THIS AND SAID WE
NEED A CLEAR TEST. AND THAT'S
HOW WE GOT DYNAMAX. I HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE. SINCE A
YEAR AGO APRIL WHEN DYNAMAX
CAME OUT. THINKING THROUGH
EVERY SINGLE TYPE OF WORK
THINKING THRILL OF HOW WE COULD
HAVE A FRAMEWORK. OF ONE SIZE
FITS ALL BUT WE ALL KNEW
DYNAMICS DIDN'T WORK BECAUSE IT
WAS ONE SIZE FITS ALL BUT THAT
WASN'T ENOUGH INTO THEN COME TO
THIS FLOOR AND SAY WE SHOULD
VOTE THIS DOWN BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT IT
ENOUGH WHEN YOU'VE NEVER EVEN
COME TO MY OFFICE AND SPOKEN TO
ME ABOUT THAT. KNOWING I'M
WORKING ON THIS BILL ALL YEAR
BEFORE. IS DISHONEST. IT'S
INTELLECTUALLY DISHONEST. YEAH
IT'S INTELLECTUALLY DISHONEST
FOR THE OPPOSITION PARTY. TO
SUGGEST THAT EVERY TIME THEY GO
OUT THERE THEY COMPLAIN ABOUT
THE POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA. YET
SUDDENLY WE WANT TECH COMPANIES
WHERE. THE CEOS OR MAKING FORTY
FIVE MILLION FORTY MILLION.
DOLLARS A YEAR. THEY'RE
BRINGING HOME BILLIONS BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN STOCK PROFITS. TO
SAY WE HAVE TO SOMEHOW ALLOW
THEM THE FLEXIBILITY. TO NOT
PAY WORKERS A MINIMUM WAGE AND
YOU WONDER WHY THERE'S TEN
CITIES IN SACRAMENTO. I'VE HAD
ENOUGH. I'VE HAD ENOUGH. NOBODY
WANTS TO OFFER SOLUTIONS THEY
JUST WANT TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
PROBLEMS IN THAT'S DISINGENUOUS
SO YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAVE A
SOLUTION HERE IS IT PERFECT NOW.
ARE THERE GUIDELINES YES
BECAUSE WE TOOK A LOOK AT THE
DYNAMICS DECISION WE READ IT WE
TRIED TO FIGURE OUT WHERE THE
COURT WAS COMING FROM. IT
PROVIDED EXEMPTIONS THAT WORK
IN THOSE FRAMEWORKS BUT SAID IT
MATTERS HOW MUCH SOMEBODY MAKES
AND THEIR JOB HOW MUCH LEVERAGE
THEY REALLY HAVE TO BARGAIN
THEIR OWN RATES. COMPETITIVE
DYNAMICS. YOU'RE NOT FLEXIBLE
WHEN YOU REALLY HAVE NO
FLEXIBILITY. WHEN YOU HAVE TO
TAKE A SIDE JOB OR THIRD GIG OR
FOURTH GIG THAT'S NOT
FLEXIBILITY. THAT'S FEUDALISM
AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GOING IF
WE DON'T PUT A STOP TO IT.
WANTED TO STRIKE A BALANCE A
BALANCE THAT PROTECTS WORKERS.
IN PROTECT SMALL BUSINESSES
LEGITIMATE SMALL BUSINESSES
BECAUSE IF YOU GO IN YOUR
COMMUNITY AND YOU ASK THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY ABIDING
BY THE LAW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THEY HAVE TO COMPETE AGAINST A
BUSINESS THAT DOESN'T PAY
PAYROLL TAXES IT DOESN'T PAY
SEVEN POINT 5% INTO SOCIAL
SECURITY MEDICARE FOR THE
WORKERS IT DOESN'T PROVIDE A
MINIMUM WAGE AND OVERTIME THEY
CAN NOT CONTINUE TO COMPETE.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE WORKERS
IT'S ABOUT LEGITIMATE SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO ARE DOING THE
RIGHT THING TODAY IN THE GYM AT
LARGE BUSINESSES. WHO ARE DOING
THE RIGHT TODAY. THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT ARE BY BY THE LAW.
AND THEY DO A GOOD JOB OF IT IN
LEADING A NEW INDUSTRY COME IN
AND SAY BECAUSE I HIRE YOU
THROUGH AN APP I DON'T HAVE ANY
RULES. PROVIDES IS EVERYTHING
IF YOU THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
HOMELESS PEOPLE ON THE STREET
TODAY WHAT EVERY JOB BE HIRED
TO RUN OUT. AND HAVE NO RULES.
THE PROPOSALS PUT FORWARD. HI
TECH COMPANIES ARE LAUGHABLE
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT WE TALK A
LOT ABOUT SOCIAL SECURITY YOU
KNOW IT WHAT HAPPENS IF WE
ALLOW EVERY COMPANY TO QUIT
PAID INTO SOCIAL SECURITY FOR
THE WORKERS. MEDICARE WE WONDER
WHY SOCIAL SECURITY IS
UNDERFUNDED THIRTY SECOND WEEK
GIVING UP ON SOCIAL SECURITY.
ARE WE GIVING UP ON WORKERS
COMP ARE WE GIVING UP ON HEALTH
CARE ARE WE GIVING UP ON
EVERYTHING WE HAVE BUILT OVER
THE LAST. FIVE SIX DECADES IN
STATE IT'S OKAY THE RICH WILL
BECOME RICHER AND THE POOR WILL
BECOME POOR AND WE'RE JUST
GOING TO SAY IT'S REALLY COOL
BECAUSE I. APP ON MY PHONE. I
DON'T HELLO THIS IS A PERFECT.
I THINK THIS GOES A LONG WAY TO
PROTECTING WORKERS LEGITIMATE
SMALL BUSINESSES LEGITIMATE
BUSINESS IS A PLAY BY THE RULES
AND WE AS TAXPAYERS THAT HAVE
TO CLEAN UP THE MESS WITH THESE
BUSINESSES DON'T PROVIDE ENOUGH
FOR THE WORKERS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NINE. WORK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
SIX KNOWS FIFTEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES WITH IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE GOVERNOR.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
ONE SIXTY SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY
SIX BY SOMETHING I'M A GAMER ON
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
MR GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB ONE SIX SIX WHICH IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE BILL
WOULD CREATE A FIVE YEAR PILOT
PROJECT THAT WOULD LEVERAGE
FEDERAL MEDICAID DOLLARS. TO
CREATE THE STATE OF FUNDING
STREAM PROVIDE. CAN PREP. THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
NARROWED THE SCOPE OF THE PILOT
STRENGTH IN THE EVALUATION
REPORT AND MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES. THIS BILL RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
CHAMBERS AND IS SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD COALITION OF MEDICAL AND
GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION
EXPERTS. INCLUDING THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS
AND THE DIFFERENCE LAW CENTER
TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE THANK
YOU AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
WORK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FORTY FOUR
KNOWS FOR OR THIS MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO RECYCLING WAS
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
O'NEILL'S 2% AB ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN A CONCURRENCE WHICH IS
SIMPLY. PUTTING INTO LAW SOME
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF A
STATE AUDIT ON THE MATCHES
RECYCLING COUNCIL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER CM
MISTER BIGELOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IN MEMBERS I TO AS A CO
AUTHOR VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
BILL AS YOU ALL KNOW YOU'VE
LIVED IN. YOUR COMMUNITIES
EVERY DAY FOR MANY YEARS NOW
AND YOU SEE THAT. THE THAT
DYNAMIC OF MATTRESSES BEING
THROWN AND ALONG THE ROADSIDES
WE'RE SEEING THE MASSES THAT
HAVE TO BE CLEANED UP WITH THIS
MAJOR I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
SENSIBLE RECOGNITION OF HOW TO
ADDRESSES IN A MORE EFFECTIVE
WAY. AND I'M PLEASED TO WORK
WITH THE ARE CHIEF AUTHOR OF
THIS IN AN EFFECTIVE WAY PLEASE
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER BIGELOW. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISS GARCIA YOU MAY
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
BI PARTISAN BILL THAT'S BOTH
GOOD FOR URBAN AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE I SIXTIES YOU KNOW ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES BY LIGHT
AND NINE AB ONE EIGHTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ AS A LEVEL ONE
EIGHTY NINE BY SEVEN MEMBER
CALVET OF AND OTHERS ACTUALLY
CHALABI'S OR NETFLIX NEGLECT
THIS CONGRESS HAVE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU THE
MORNING SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY ON ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
EIGHTY NINE WHICH IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCY
AMENDMENT SIMPLY IS ALSO. A
CHECK DURING OUT ISSUE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISS KAHN LONGER
DOES SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A-
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO GO. WHERE WILL LOSE
THE ROLAND TALLY VOTE AYE AYES
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TEN EIGHTY TO NINETY
FOUR THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY WILL TO NINETY FOUR BY
SOMETHING MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY A
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES IS
BUT I'M SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
RICE PRESENT AB TWO NINETY FOUR
WHICH IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
AB TWO NINETY FOUR CODIFIES
RECOMMENDATIONS PUT FORTH BY
THE STATE AUDITOR THAT WILL
PROVIDE CORRECTIONAL FACILITY
STAFF WITH ADEQUATE TRAINING TO
MITIGATE THE HARM OF GAS IN THE
TAX ALONG WITH THEM IMPORT
EMPLOYEE HEALTH INFORMATION
ENTITLEMENTS ARE STRICTLY I
TRAVEL. THANK YOU MISTER
RODRIGUEZ SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE. TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE
NINETY FOUR THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY DID BY
MENTAL QUALITY MR OBERNOLTE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. I REMEMBER LAST YEAR
THAT TERRIBLE FIRE IN PARADISE
WHEN A LARGE GROUP OF US WENT
OUT TO THE COMMUNITY AND TOOK A
TOUR OF THAT THE DEVASTATION
THAT RESULTED THAT'S SOMETHING
I WILL NEVER FORGET IN THE MOST
POIGNANT THING THAT WE SAW
THERE FROM MY POINT OF VIEW.
WAS THE AYE TESTIMONY FOR
PEOPLE THAT AT THE SHELTER IN
PLACE IN THEIR VEHICLES. IN THE
MIDDLE OF INTERSECTIONS. THERE
WAS FISHING EAGLE ALL. WALKED
VERY NARROWLY CRAFTED SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR THE CREATION OF
NEW GROWTH. UNIFIED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AS
HAVING INSUFFICIENTLY GRASS I
WE HAVE TAKEN MANY AMENDMENTS
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE TO NARROWLY CRAFT THIS
BILL AMENDMENTS TO THE SENATE
FURLEY FURTHER NARROW THE BILL
AND ENACT NEW ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS AND A LINE OF THE
IT PROTECTIONS IN THE BILL WITH
THOSE IN THE GOVERNOR'S ORDER.
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL IS ABOUT
SAVING LIVES AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR CONCURRENCE AND
SAID ABOUT MONTHS. THANK YOU
MISTER OBERNOLTE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO
KNOWS ONE SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM TWELVE
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO LAND USE
THIS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
PREPONDERANCE. AMENDMENTS IN
THE SENATE WERE TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE AB FIVE
SEVEN CREATES A NARROW
EXEMPTION FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY TO SELL
DEED RESTRICTED LAND TO
ELIGIBLE LOW INCOME HOMEOWNERS
AND PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
HOUSING TO THOSE IN NEED THIS
BILL ALLOWS HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY AND OTHERS LIKE THEM
TO SERVE TWICE AS MANY FAMILIES
ON SINGLE FAMILY LOTS. THIS
BILL IS RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISS FRIEDMAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE. ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL
YOU THAT I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY AND FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
AB SEVEN SIXTY TWO THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK AND ACTUALLY TO FOOD
HEALTH ADVISORIES. MR QUIRK YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
SPEAKER AB SEVEN SIX TWO
REQUIRES LOCAL HEALTH AGENCIES
TO POST ADVISORIES AT LAKES AND
RIVERS THAT RECOMMEND SAFE
AMOUNT OF LOCAL FISH THE PEOPLE
CAN EAT SENATE MEMBERS CLARIFY
THAT LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS
MUST EITHER POST THOSE
ADVISORIES OR REQUEST GRANT
FUNDING. FROM THE STATE OR
BOARD FIRST. WHEN A FISH
CONSUMPTION ADVISORIES ISSUED
MA'AM IT'S ALSO ADD PROVISIONS
TO ASSIST THE WATER BOARD WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE PERSON PROCESS
AND REQUIRE THE WATER BOARD TO
SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATOR. LEGISLATURE ON THE
POSTING PROGRAM THIS BILL
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES AND THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION I ASK FOR YOUR I'VE
FOR YOUR VOTE CONCURRENT. THANK
YOU MISTER QUIRK SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE THE-
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL YOU
THAT I SIXTY FOUR NEW ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB EIGHT
FORTY TO THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FORTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMóN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
TRANSPORTATION IS THE MAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FORTY TWO IS BACK ON CONCURRENT
SOMEONE SURE ALL ELIGIBLE LOW
INCOME PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS
INCLUDING OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS. ARE GUARANTEED ACCESS
TO NUTRITIOUS FREE OR LOW COST
MEAL DURING EACH PROGRAM DAY
WHILE ATTENDING PRESCHOOL OR
CHILD CARE AT A PUBLIC SCHOOL
OR CALIFORNIA STREET PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU ON SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK. IN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE THE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NEW
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
BY LAME SEVENTEEN AB EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE OCCUR FOR READ AS A
LEGAL EIGHT SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND
ACTUALLY TO FOSTER CARE THIS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
EIGHT SIX FIVE. IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT EXPANSE TRAINING
PROVIDED TO FOSTER YOUTH
FAMILIES TO INCLUDE INFORMATION
ON COMMERCIAL AND SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION OF YOUTH
AMENDMENTS FOR TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS REST
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON OUT OF THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB TEN
THIRTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY
SEVEN I SAW IN MY BURKE ABSENT
AND ACTUALLY TO CLINICS MISTER
GIBSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
THIRTY SEVEN IS BACK ON. FIRST
RESPECTFULLY ASK LIVE VOTE THIS
IS A DISTRICTS A SPECIFIC THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL. OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
NINETEEN AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN FIFTY SEVEN BY FAMILY
MEMBER LOW MOAN AND OTHERS AND
THAT CLING TO OIL AND GAS IS
THE MAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY SEVEN
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. AB TEN
FIFTY SEVEN WILL STRENGTHEN THE
STATE'S AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL SECURITY
FOR RISKY ON SHORE OIL AND GAS
PROSPER. OPERATORS IN ORDER TO
PROTECT TAXPAYERS. CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATES IF AN OPERATOR GOES
IN CRAP TO AND ABANDON THEIR
OPERATIONS THE COST TO
TAXPAYERS COULD BE AS HIGH AS
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
PER TEN THOUSAND OIL WELLS. WE
NEED TO MEET APPROPRIATE
MEASURES IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES AND
TAXPAYERS ARE NOT LEFT TO FOOT
THE BILL. THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
REFLECT TECHNICAL INPUT FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION AND A BETTER
ALIGNS WITH THE DIVISION WITH
THE CLIMATE GOALS FOR THE STATE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS LIMóN.
IT'S A CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. KERRY BY
MY COLLEAGUE TO THE SOUTH. IN
ONE COUNTY SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
WE HAD A WELL CLEAN UP ISSUE.
FOR AN OPERATOR THAT WAS UNDER
INSURED AND UNDER BONDED AND
THE COST OF THAT WAS IN THE
MULTIPLE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. THAT COST WAS PASSED
ON TO THE COUNTY AND THE
TAXPAYERS THIS BILL WOULD
PREVENT SOMETHING LIKE THAT
FROM HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE. I
URGE AND I ABOUT. THANK YOU
MISTER CUNNINGHAM SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS. OF THE-
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
THE. WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE EYES FORTY
SIX KNOWS NINE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM TWENTY AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN TWENTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
SIR COULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
ALWAYS IN PLEASE A PRESENT A.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE WHICH
CONCERNED CERTIFICATION OF
ANIMAL CONTROL OFFICERS. THIS
WILL ESTABLISH A FRAMEWORK
WITHIN WHICH THIS CAN BE DONE.
I WANT TO NOTE THAT ANY ANIMAL
CONTROL OFFICER WHO GETS A
CERTIFICATION. WILL SURELY BE
FELINE FINE. AND I URGE YOU ALL
TO NOT BOW OUT BUT VOTE ON.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLIES SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM TWENTY
ONE AB ELEVEN THIRTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN THIRTY THREE BY SO MANY
MEMBER LOW AND ACT ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES MR LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MINISTER REMEMBERS IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU MISTER LOS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS MODE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY THREE
KNOWS ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM TWENTY
TWO AB ELEVEN FIFTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN FIFTY THREE BY SOMETHING
MEMBER WICKS AND ACTUALLY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. MISS WICKS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
ELEVEN FIFTY THREE WILL EXTEND
THE CHILD ABUSE AND NEGLECT
REPORTING ACT TRAINING TO STAFF
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SENATE MOMENTS ARE CLARIFYING A
TECHNICAL NATURE AND I LANGUAGE
TO ADDRESS CHATTERING I. USE
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY. THANK
YOU MISS WICKS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE AB TWELVE OH NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE OH NINE PRICE ONLY
MEMBER TO DARIAN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE. MR TO
VERY AND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWELVE OH NINE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE IT'S ENJOYED.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS ARE THOSE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THAT I SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN BY LEN TWENTY FOUR
AB TWELVE FORTY THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FORTY
BY SOMETHING MEMBER WEBER AND
ACTUALLY TO SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY DOCTOR WEBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AT TWELVE FORTY
IS BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
UNCLE FOR CONCURRENCE. THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS SIMPLY
ADDRESS TAPPING OUT ISSUES THIS
BILL IS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENT THANK
YOU DOCTOR WEBER SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE THE-
ALL MEMBERS THAT HE DESIRED.
ALL MEMBERS MODE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NEWS
HERE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FILE AND TWENTY FIVE FILE
ITEM TWENTY SIX A. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE BY SONY MEMBER LACKEY AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC TRANSIT
THROUGH LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. OKAY THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB THIRTY FIFTY
WELL WHAT AUTHORIZED A
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY TO CONSULT PUBLIC
TRANSIT OPERATORS TO ASSESS DID
MINISTRY PROCEDURES OF RIDE
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
PHYSICAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. IT'S BACK FROM
THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE AND
THE MEMBERS PROVIDE A LARGER
WINDOW TO CONDUCT AND PUBLISH
THE ASSESSMENT CURRENTLY WHEN
CONSIDERING THE ENTIRETY OF THE
APPLICATION PROCESS YOU COULD
TAKE NEARLY A MONTH FOR A
PERSON WITH A DISABILITY. THE
CAN USE AN AGENCIES. PARA
TRANSIT SERVICE SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
LACKEY SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED
BOTH WORK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELEVOTE I SIXTY FIVE NEW
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN THE BACK UP TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY FIVE MAYBE TWELVE FORTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FORTY NINE
BUY SOMETHING MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND ACTUALLY THE
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS MR
MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWELVE FORTY NINE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE IN AUTHORIZES TWO
FIVE YEAR PILOT PROGRAMS THAT
EMPLOYER HEALTH BENEFIT PLANS
WITH ORGANIZED INTEGRATED
PROVIDERS IN A MORE ALIGNED
RELATIONSHIPS. TO PRODUCE
BETTER CARE AT A LOWER COST
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE PROVIDE
MORE DISCRETION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
TO. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESIRED BOTH THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM. TWENTY NINE AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE THE PURPLE
RAIN. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE BY SOME REMEMBER A
MAN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES MAKING
APPROPRIATION THERE FOR A
SECOND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND SPEAKER
MEMBERS A. B. FIFTEEN EIGHTY
THREE IS BACK WITH THE
CONCURRENCE FROM THE SENATE
HAVING TO DO WITH WASTE AND
RECYCLING ASTRI AB. THANK YOU
MISS EGGMAN SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHTY BE FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ. AS
A LEGAL FIFTEEN SIXTEEN BY
SELLING MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AND I PLAN TO FIRE
PREVENTION IS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN WILL ASSIST IN THE IN
PREVENTING DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES AND REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF HOMES DESTROYED BY WILDFIRE
SENATE AMENDMENTS INCLUDE
RENAMING THE NON COMBUSTIBLE SO
WITHIN FIVE PEOPLE OF A
STRUCTURE TO IN THE AMBER
RESISTANCE OWN. REQUIRE THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION TO DEVELOP REGGAE
TUNES FOR THE AMBER RESISTANCE
OWN TO CONSIDER THE ELIMINATION
OF MATERIALS IN THE AMBER
RESISTANCE OWN THAT WOULD
LIKELY BE IGNITED BY AMBER'S
CREATE A STATEWIDE PROGRAM TO
ALLOW QUALIFIED THIRD PARTY
ENTITIES TO SUPPORT HELLFIRE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTION
EFFORTS THROUGH DEFENSIBLE
SPACE ASSESSMENTS. AUTHORIZED
LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS TO
SUPPORT THESE NEW DEFENSIBLE
SPACE ASSESSMENT AB FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN IS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
CONCURRENCE OF THE SENATE
AMENDMENTSTHANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN. THING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT I FIFTY EIGHT NOTES
HERE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM THIRTY
AB SIXTEEN HUNDRED THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
HUNDRED BY SOMETHING MEMBER
KALRA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO DISCOVERY THIS CALL ARE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THINK ABOUT A
SPEAKER THIS MEASURES BACK
CONCURRENCE WAS ON AND
AMENDMENTS AB SIXTEEN HUNDRED
WILL HELP TO ENSURE GREATER
ACCESS TO DUE PROCESS ARGUMENT
JUST SYSTEM BY ALIGNING PITCHES
MOTION TIMELINES OF THE REGULAR
CRIMINAL DISCOVERY NOTICE
TIMELINES ME LAST SAW THIS
MEASURE THERE WAS SOME LATE
OPPOSITION BY LONG FORCES
MEASURE AND I'M A COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS THIS IN
THE SENATE. I DELETED A
PROVISION THAT CONCERNS WITH AS
WELL AS HELP TO NARROW SOME THE
LANGUAGE AND WITH THE WORK THAT
WE DID PLEASED TO SHARE THAT
WITH THE WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE THE PUBLIC
SAFETY IS IN SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY THAT POOR ACT AND THE
RECYCLING SURE SO CH REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION OR NO NEUTRAL
ON THE BILL. RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE I BO THANK YOU MISTER KALRA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK.
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THAT THIS
REQUIRES FORTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE IT THIS REQUIRES
FORTY ONE
. ALL MEMBERS GO TO
DESIRED OR BOTH THIS REQUIRES
FORTY ONE
. THIS COLUMN IS A
CALL. FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE AB
SIXTEEN OH THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH
THREE BY SOMETHING MEMBER WICKS
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE MISS WICKS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SIXTY NO
THREE WILL ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PROGRAM INTO
STATUTE THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE WITH NO
OPPOSITION IT IS SUPPORTED BY
GIFFORD LAWCENTER MOMS DEMAND
ACTION ELLA BAKER CENTER AND
MANY OTHERS I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISS WORK SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS MOODY'S ERA. ALL
MEMBERS VALUES ARE THE- THIRTY
WILL. LOW'S THE ROLAND TALLY
THOSE EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN BY LETTING THIRTY TWO AB
SEVENTY NO TO THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN OH
TO BUY SOMETHING MEMBER
THREE OF US AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO HOMELESSNESS THIS
REQUEST YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB SEVENTY NO TWO IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AB SEVENTY
SEVENTY NO TO WILL REQUIRE THE
COUNCIL THE HOMELESS CANADIAN
FINANCING COUNCIL TO PROVIDE
THE LEGISLATURE WITH A REPORT
ON STATUTORY CHANGES THAT COULD
BE MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
DELIVERY OF SERVICES. AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THE BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
NO UP POSITION AND HAS NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
VAST SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE. ALL
MEMBERS GO TO DISCARD VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE AB
SEVENTY NO FIVE A PURPLE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN OH FIVE
BUY SOMETHING MEMBER BONTA AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL THIS AMOUNT
TO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MA'AM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THE MOMENT IN THE
SENATE. WERE TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER BONTA SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
ARTIFICE. ALL MEMBER TO GO TO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE EYES
FIFTY SIX NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
THIRTY FIVE MAYBE FORTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND EXPLAINED FOR
PRODUCTS MISS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FORTY FOUR
WOULD MAKE IT UNLAWFUL TO
SELLING MANUFACTURED I KNEW FOR
PRODUCT IN THE STATE SENATE
AMENDMENTS MOVE THE EFFECTIVE
DATE OF THE BILL BACK TWO YEARS
FOR TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE FROM TO. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CLARIFY THAT A
PERSON IN VIOLATION OF THE
THESE PROVISIONS MAY BE CHARGED
WITH A CIVIL VIOLATION RATHER
THAN SHALL BE CHARGED ADDED TAP
DURING OUT AMENDMENTS WITH AB
TWO SEVENTY THREE THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
CONCURRENCE IN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERTED THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS AGES ARE THE.
ALL MEMBERS THEIR DESIRED ABOUT
THIS PART FORTY ONE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE
AYE AYES FORTY THREE KNOWS
TWELVE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WILL MOVE BACK
UP. TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
FIVE EIGHTY NINE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTY
NINE BUY SOMETHINGMEMBER
GONZALEZ AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT MISS GONZALES YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU AB
MA'AM SPEAKER AB FIVE EIGHTY
NINE PROHIBITS AN EMPLOYER FROM
IMPOSES PENALTIES FOR
WITHHOLDING AND EMPLOYEES LEGAL
DOCUMENTS THE AMENDMENTS PUSH
BACK THE EFFECTIVE DATE FROM
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IT ALSO PROVIDES A RIGHT
HERE FOR THE EMPLOYER OF THIRTY
DAYS IF THEY HAD DID NOT ABIDE
BY THE LAW AND SO THAT THEY CAN
FIX IT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE
IT THIS FAR AS FORTY ONE. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY NINE NO
SIX SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING BACK DOWN
TO FILE. ORDER FILE ITEM THIRTY
SIX AB SIXTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY
FIVE BY FAMILY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY COASTAL PROTECTION IS
PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB SIXTY FIVE IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
AT THE AMENDMENTS THE SENATE
OUR TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING IN
NATURE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I'VE IT. THANK YOU MISS
PETRIE-NORRIS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I'M
REFERRING ITEM NUMBER SIXTY AB
SIX OH TWO BERMAN TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. FILE ITEM
THIRTY SEVEN AB ONE THIRTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE THIRTY NINE BY SOME
THE MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
ACTUALLY THE HOUSING. QUIRK
SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB ONE THIRTY
NINE THE EMERGENCY AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING ACT IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE WITH
AMENDMENTS THIS BILL UPDATES
THE CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
ELEMENT IMPLEMENTING TARGETED
STRATEGIES TO LONG TERM.
PERMANENT HOUSING FOR
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS
POPULATION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
QUIRK SILVA SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS MOTIVES ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS KNOW TWO
THIRDS VOTE WHERE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY ONE NEWS ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHTY BE TO TWENTY THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME LEGAL TO
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY MEMBER
BONTA AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO
THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR TO RUN TO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MA'AM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A.
B. TWO TWENTY IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE CLARIFY AND REFINE THE
ALLOWABLE USES OF CAMPAIGN
FUNDS AND ADD TECHNICAL CHAP
DURING OUT LANGUAGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK. WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE THE. ALL
MEMBERS KNOW TO DESIRE TO THE.
ON THEM THIRTY DESERVE THE.
CLAIRE WELL THIS REQUIRES FIFTY
FOUR THANK YOU KATIE. ALL
MEMBERS THERE IS THERE ABOUT
THIS FIRST FIFTY FOUR. CLICK.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE IT
THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR. I'VE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN THE
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTEEN
BY SOME REMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
VICTIM COMPENSATION MAKING
PREPARATION THEREFORE MR
MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FOR
FIFTEEN AUTHORIZES THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD COMPENSATED VICTIM OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FOR THE COST
OF TEMPORARY HOUSING FOR A PAT
OR FOR ANY PET DEPOSIT MAY BE
REQUIRED FREE LOCATION. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS CHAPTER IN
ISSUES THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK. WILL OPEN
ROLL. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM FORTY AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY FIVE
BUY SOMETHING MEMBER
THREE OF US ACTUALLY THE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING IS THREE
BASS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE IS A CLEANUP BILL
THAT MAKES A NUMBER OF NON
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES THAT THAT
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING IDENTIFIED. AS
NECESSARY POLICY UPDATES THE
BILL SPONSORED BY THE
COMMISSION AND HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISS RIVAS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM FORTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE
NINETY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY WILL FIVE NINETY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE MR BLOOM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT IS HERE ON
CONCURRENCE I KNOW THAT YOU
AGREE WITH ME THAT A CHILD'S
ABILITY TO HEAR SHOULD NOT BE
DETERMINED BY THEIR FAMILY
INCOME. YET HERE IN CALIFORNIA
CONTRARY TO MANY OTHER STATES
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES HAVE TO
PAY FOR THEIR CHILDREN'S
HEARING AIDS OUT OF POCKET OR
SIMPLY HAVE TO FOREGO THEM ALL
TOGETHER IN SOME CASES THIS IS
YOU KNOW REALLY SAD FACT
PARENTS ARE QUITTING THEIR JOBS
TO QUALIFY FOR MEDI CAL BECAUSE
MEDI CAL APPROPRIATELY DOES
COVER HEARING AIDS WELL AB FIVE
NINETY DRESSES THIS GAP.
COVERAGE BY REQUIRING HEALTH
CARE SERVICE. AS POLICIES TO
INCLUDE COVERAGE FOR CHILDREN'S
HEARING AIDS. AMENDMENTS TAKEN
TO THE BILL IN THE SENATE
INCLUDE A COST SHARING DESIGN.
I RESPECTFULLY. ASK YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
FORTY VOTES LAST NIGHT ON THE
SENATE FLOOR. THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS NO DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLA VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FORTY
TWO AB SIX TWELVE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
TWELVE BY FAMILY MEMBER WEBER
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY CAL
FRESH DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YES MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS OUT AB SIX TWELVE
IS BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE. SENATE AMENDMENTS
AT A CO AUTHOR AND ADDRESS
TAPPING OUT. BILLS HAD NO NO
VOTES AND NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A- ALL
MEMBERS KNOW TO DO THAT VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM FORTY THREE EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY
ONE ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
ACTUALLY THE LAND USE THIS
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB SIX SEVENTY ONE IS BACK IN
THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE I
KNOW IT'S A CLICHE BUT
AMENDMENT TO THE SENATE REALLY
WERE TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING IN
NATURE. AB SIX SEVENTY ONE
REQUIRES THE GOVERNMENT TO
INCLUDE A PLAN IN THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT TO INCENTIVIZE THE
CREATION OF EIGHTY USE THAT CAN
BE OFERED AT IS AT AN
AFFORDABLE RENT FOR VERY LOW
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS THIS WILL CREATE A
WORKABLE RESOURCE FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
EIGHTY USE FOR THE HOMEOWNER
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT. IN
OPPOSITION I REQUEST REQUESTED
MY VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MYSTERY MEN SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE IN THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO THE-
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRED. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELEVOTE I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ORDER ITEM ONE OF TWO ACR ONE
TWENTY FIVE JONES SAWYER TO THE
FIRST DAY CONSENT CALENDAR
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER IN MEMBERS PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I'M RESCINDING MY
PREVIOUS RE REFER ALL OF ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR AB EIGHT
NINETY THREE GLORIA TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR
A. B. SEVEN FORTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. AS LEGAL SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE AND OTHERS AND ACT ON
THE LAND USE MISTER LEVINE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB SEVEN FORTY SEVEN REQUIRES
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN THE
GENERAL PLAN. TO PLAN FOR
EVACUATION ROUTES FROM THEIR
CITIES FROM THEIR COUNTIES FOR
NATURAL DISASTER. BUT DOES IT A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY THAN
JUST SEEN WHERE THOSE ROUTES
ARE. IT ASKS THEM TO DETAIL THE
CAPACITY OF THOSE ROUTES. UNDER
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT SCENARIOS
SO THAT WE REALLY CAN PLAN FOR
THE SAFE EVACUATION IN A TIME
OF DISASTER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. IF YOU
MISTER LEVINE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE IN
THE MATTER OF THE CLERK. THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DISCERN VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE AB
FIFTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY WILL A FIFTY NINE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
ACTUALLY DO IT ALSO THIS REMAIN
TRYING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN MINUS AFRICAN CURRENTS
THIS BILL REQUIRES YES ASKED TO
CONDUCT A STAKEHOLDER GROUP THE
PURPOSE OF CREATING EFFICIENCY
AND JUDICIAL DEPENDENCY PERCY.
PROCEEDINGS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. WHERE TWELVE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY SIX
NEW ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM FORTY
SIX A. B. NINE FORTY TO THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE CALIBRATION
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
WELL I STILL GOOD MORNING WAS
AFTERNOON OF MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB NINE FOUR TWO IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE ALL REVOLVED
AROUND CAPTURING OUT PROBLEMS
AND ISSUES. THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AS RECEIVE NO NO
QUOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I'VE PUT ON
CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THAT ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE AYE SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED. MOVING. IN A FILE
ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
VETERANS AFFAIRS AND ACTUALLY
DID DISABLED VETERANS IS OR
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE REQUIRES A CONTRACT
AWARDING STATE DEPARTMENT TO
MAINTAIN ALL RECORDS OF THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED BY A PRIME
CONTRACTOR UNDER THE DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
GRAHAM AND RETAIN THE RECORDS
FOR A MINIMUM OF SIX YEARS THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS REMOVED
CARMEN SYSTEM TO PROCREATE. A
REVIEW PROCEDURES FOR THESE
CARDS AND DIRECTLY INFORM EVA
WHEN IT APPLIED AS A
SUBCONTRACTOR. IN AN AWARD A
CONTRACT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS NO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN WILL PASS TEMPORARILY AND
FILE ITEM FORTY NINE FILE ITEM
FIFTY AB THIRTY THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY BY
FAMILY MEMBER HOLDEN AND OTHERS
AND EXPLAIN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SIR HOLDING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. SB THIRTY
YEARS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
REACHER RESEARCH HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT DUAL
ENROLLMENT. STUDENTS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO ENTER COLLEGE PERSIST
IN COLLEGE TO COMPLETION AND
GRADUATE. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
INCREASES ACCESS TO COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITIES STREAMLINES THE
PROCESS TO DEVELOP STRONG
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN K. TWELVE.
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
REMOVE BARRIERS FOR STUDENTS.
WE HAVE SEEN MANY STUDENT
SUCCESS SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SEA CAP
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND I
WANT TO CONTINUE TO ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITS DUAL
ENROLLMENT AS A PERMANENT AND
SUCCESSFUL STRATEGY. TO CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP. THANK
RATING STRIPS THE SAME WAS
PATHWAYS FOR HIGH SCHOOL TO
COLLEGE. THIS BILL ENJOYS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER HOLDEN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLY
THOUGH IT AYE SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN BY LETTING FIFTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO OH THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OH THREE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER SALAS AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
MR SALAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU BETTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OR
THREE IS BACK ON CONCURRENT TO
THE BILL THAT DEALS WITH.
VALLEY FEVER PROTECTING OUR
WORKERS AT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
SALAS SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
THOSE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. PASS
TEMPORARILY IN FILING A FIFTY
TWO FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE AB
TWO FIFTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOMETHING ALL TWO FIFTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
HELP MAKE IN PREPARATION
THEREFORE MISTER JONES SAWYER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY ARISE RESENT AB
TWO FIFTY EIGHT SENATE
AMENDMENTS ENSURE HIGH QUALITY
SERVICE PROVIDERS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND EFFICIENT
USE OF STATE FUNDS. THE BILL
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS BY STE
PARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE SENATE
LAST THREE AYE VOTE. THAT'S
MADAM SPEAKER BUT DESPITE THAT.
I SEE NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER AT THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS. ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL RIGHT
RESERVED VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TALLY VOTE AYE AYES
SIXTY TWO NEW ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE
WILL NOW BREAK FOR LUNCH THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS WILL HAVE
LUNCH IN THE RULES ROOM AND THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS WILL HAVE
LUNCH IN THE LOUNGE WE'LL BREAK
FOR AN HOUR UNDER CALL OF THIS
SPEAKER AND WE WILL BE BACK. TO
CONTINUE BUSINESS THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN SESSION
PLEASE REPORT. BACK TO THE
FLOOR SO WE MAY CONTINUE. THE
BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE
. THERE
ARE. MEMBERS PLEASE COME TO THE
FLOOR SO WE MAY RESUME. THE
BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE
. MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP SOME
CONCURRENCE ITEMS. FOR WHICH WE
PASS TEMPORARILY. MS BARRICADE
HAN WILL BE TAKING UP FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO THIS IS A AB EIGHT
OH SEVEN. THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT OH SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BAUER KING AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE CAL
WORKS TO CLEARING THE URGENCY
THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. HIS BROW CAM THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB EIGHT OH SEVEN IS
BACK BEFORE YOU ON CONCURRENCE
AND MEASUREMENTS TAKEN IN THE
SENATE WOULD EXEMPT ALL CENSUS
RELATED INCOME FROM EITHER
GOVERNMENTAL OR NON PROFIT
AGENCY TO ENCOURAGE CENSUS
PARTICIPATION IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THE CALYX PROGRAM
SERVES NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
BY PROVIDING FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FOR HOUSING FOOD AND
OTHER NECESSARY EXPENSES THIS
BILL EXPAND THE LIST OF ITEMS
EXEMPTED FROM CONSIDERATION AS
INCOME WHICH REMOTE SMART
SAVING HABITS WHILE HELPING TO
BREAK THE CYCLE OF POVERTY THE
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT EACH HOUSE AND IS NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
BACKHAND SAYING NO SURE BET ON
THE ADAM CORP LIBERAL. MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
. EVER SINCE
TAKES FIFTY FOUR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT
. WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN
. MEMBERS THIS
IS FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO AB TWO
THIRTY BY MISTER BRO. WE'LL GO
BRO AND THEN JONES SAWYER THIS
IS AB TWO THIRTY. CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRO AND
ACTUALLY TO VETERANS MR WROTE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWO
THIRTY RESPONSE TO CRITICISMS
IN A RECENTLY RELEASED DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
AUDIT BY REQUIRING THE DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE TO
PROVIDE PROOF OF PAYMENT FOR
WORK DONE UNDER THE CONTRACT
ONE REQUESTED BY THE WARNING
DEPARTMENT REQUIRES THE PRIME
CONTRACTOR DO USE DVB E.
SUBCONTRACTORS AND SUPPLIERS
PROPOSED IN THE BID TO THE
STATE UNLESS IS SUBSTITUTION IS
APPROVED BY THE DEPARTMENT
REQUIRES EVERY STATE CONTRACT
WITH THE DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
PARTICIPATION. TO CONTAIN A
PROVISION REQUIRING A
CONTRACTOR TO COMPLY WITH ALL
RULES REGULATIONS ORDINANCES
AND STATUES THE WHITE TO THE D.
E. B. E. PROGRAM. RESPECTFULLY
ASK GOD THE. HE WAS ROW SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
LIBERAL MEMBERS. THESE ARE VOTE
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. YEAH CLOSER
ROLE CHARLIE BUT I SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM FORTY SEVEN. AB TEN NINETY
TO THE CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
ACTUALLY NO CHILD SUPPORT.
MISTER JONES SAWYER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN AND SENATE WERE TECHNICAL
IN NATURE AT THE REQUESTED
DEPARTMENT RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING THIS POLICY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
NAME IS JONES SAWYER SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRED ABOUT
.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF YOUR OWN
PROPOSAL MISTER CHANCE WHERE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL KELLY
THAT EYES FORTY ONE NO
SEVENTEEN SEVEN MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRENT
. MEMBERS IN FOLLOWER
THIS IS FILE FILE ITEM FIFTY
FOUR. FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR AB
THREE OH EIGHT BY MR MURATSUCHI.
GREGORY ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OH
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND OTHERS AND
EXPLAIN IT TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MISTER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU I
AM HERE TO PRESENT AB THREE OH
EIGHT WHICH. PASSED UNANIMOUSLY
FORTY ZERO OUT OF THE SENATE
HELPING. HELD HER OWN SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH THE TAX BREAK
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE SAID
AMENDMENTS FOR MINOR TECHNICAL
NATURE OURS RESPECTFULLY ROPE
REQUEST DRIVER. NAME IS
MURATSUCHI SAY NO DISCUSSION OF
A CLERK WILL BE THERE ALL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIES BUT
I SIXTY TWO. NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND-
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE AB
FOR SEVENTY SIX CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SEVENTY SIX
BY SALLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
AND ACTUALLY PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS WHICH RUBIO THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT AB FOR SEVENTY SIX
WHICH IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
WITH SENATE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE. THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO CONVENE A
TASK FORCE TO ASSESS CURRENT
FOREIGN CREDENTIAL REVIEW
PROCESSES AND RECOMMEND
POTENTIAL STEPS TO ENSURE
FOREIGN TRAINED PROFESSIONALS
ARE ENCOURAGED TO PRACTICE IN
OUR GREAT STATE THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THERE WAS RUBIO SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE OR PULL UP IN
THE WRONG. NUMBER SERVICE OUT
OF ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A-
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WORK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE WHAT
EYES FIFTY ONE. KNOWS SEVEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX. AB
FOR NINETY THREE OR FOUR THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY THREE
BY SOME REMEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS IN ATLANTA TEACHERS
MISTER GLORIA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB FOR NINETY THREE IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE CON
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP AN AUNT OR UPDATE
EXISTING RESOURCES FOR TRAINING
ON SCHOOL SITE AND COMMUNITY
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT LGBT Q.
STUDENTS. OF MEMBERS I THINK
YOU ALL KNOW THAT DESPITE
PROGRESS UNDER THE LAW MANY OF
OUR STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS
CONTINUE TO REPORT HARASSMENT
BULLYING. WE CAN'T HAVE THIS IN
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT THIS BILL IS A FIRST STEP
IN DEVELOPING A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO MAKINGSURE OUR
LGBTQ YOUTH FEEL PROTECTED AND
SAFE AT SCHOOL A STUDENT HOME
AWAY FROM HOME. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS GLORIA. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. QUIRK
LIBERAL. THE SAD ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.%
CLARK WELL LOW'S ROLL TIDE OF A.
AS FORTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. WE
WANT TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT. AB FIVE
TWENTY FOUR BY MISTER BIGELOW
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE TWENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PEACE
OFFICERS. SHOULD BIGELOW THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
FIVE TWENTY FOUR WILL ADD THE
COUNTIES A DEL NORD MONO AND
SAN MATTEO TO PENAL CODE
SECTION. EIGHT THIRTY POINT ONE
AGAIN SECTION SEE OFFERING AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL TO HELP WITH
THEIR LIMITED RESOURCES I
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE. AIMS
BIGELOW SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
THE CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIGN OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF. IT
IS OUT OF OUT. WORK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
THERE WAS ONE PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE. WE
HAVE REFERRED FILE ITEM SIXTY
TO COMMITTEE THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE AB SIX FORTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX FORTY NINE BY FAMILY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE GAMBLING. THIS
GARCIA THANK YOU AB SIX FORTY
NINE IS BY FURQAN CURRENCY
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS VOICED BY
THE CALIFORNIA GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE. IT IS OUR
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AT
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS THIS
IS FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO AB SEVEN
OH NINE CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN OH NINE BY SELLING MEMBER
BONTA AND ACTUALLY TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THE SHOE BONTA THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. SEVEN OH NINE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THE
AMENDMENT TO THE SENATE WHERE
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE DRIVER.
AMOS BONTA SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. WELL CLOSER
ALL TYLER I SIXTY NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS. OUR
CONCURRENT. MEMBERS ONE OF BACK
TO FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE. AB
FIVE NINETY THREE I MISS
CARILLO THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETY THREE
BY SOME REMEMBER CREO AND
ACTUALLY THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. MYSTERY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THE
AMENDMENTS TAKE IN FOR A. B.
FIVE NINETY THREE IN THE SENATE
OUR TECHNICAL IN CLEAR FIND IN
NATURE AND REMOVE CHAPTER IN
CONFLICT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR ABOUT. THANK MISCREANT
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS AND THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS OUT OF A.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS THIS
IS FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE AB
EIGHT NINETY ONE BY MISS FOR
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT NINETY ONE BY CELL
NUMBER BURKE AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THIS BURKE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHT NINETY
ONE ESTABLISHES THE SAFE
PARKING PROGRAM IN SPECIFIED
CITIES AND COUNTIES SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADD A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET INTO THE PROGRAM AND
MAKE SOME OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK SO
WE CAN KERR IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MS BURKE
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
RIGHT. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT
OF A. WELL. THOSE ARE ALL TIED
OF ICE FORTY NINE KNOWS
THIRTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN
. MEMBERS I AM
PREPARED TO LIVE THE CALL ON
MISTER KALRA AS- MEASURE ON
CALL THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
AB SIXTEEN HUNDRED THE CLERK
WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRABLE. THE CLERK WILL. WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF THAT ICE
FORTY THREE KNOWS TWENTY ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES BACK IN
FILE ORDER. FILE ITEM SIXTY
FOUR AB EIGHT NINETY THREE THE
CORPORATION AS A LEGAL EIGHT
NINETY THREE BY SOMETHING
MEMBER GLORIA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE AGRICULTURAL
DISTRICTS MR LAURIA THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHT
NINETY THREE IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE WITH
SENATE AMENDMENTS THIS BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT GUNS AND
AMMUNITION SALES OF THE DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS STATE PROPERTY
OWNED BY THE TWENTY SECOND
AGRICULTURE DISTRICT. IN MY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THESE
AMENDMENTS FROM THE SENATE OUR
TECHNICAL AT FINDING THE
DECLARATIONS TO THE BILL
MEMBERS EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY
THREE IS IN DIRECT RESPONSE TO
CALLS FROM CITIZENS IN THE
SURROUNDING CITIES OF THE DEL
MAR FAIRGROUNDS TO END GUN
SHOWS. ON THIS PROPERTY I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK MISS
KOREA SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
GLOBAL ROLE. IS OUT OF OUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AT ABOUT THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE TELL
YOU ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS NINETEEN. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE.
AB NINE SIXTY THREE. PARKWAY
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SIXTY THREE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC%
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION MISS
PETRIE-NORRIS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER EIGHTY NINE SIXTY THREE
IS BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE WE'VE WORKED WITH
THE SECRETARY OF STATE AND WITH
CSU ON AMENDMENTS THAT CLARIFY
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE IT.
THANK YOU IS PETRIE-NORRIS SEEN
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF. IT IS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT ABOUT
THE CLERK WELL. CLOSER ALL TELL
YOU VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY FIVE NO
SIX SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN IN THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY SIX AB ELEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT BY FAMILY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY INTO THE ELDERLY.
TURNER SHE MAY GET OPEN. YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AT ELEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
ON CONCURRENCE WE WORKED WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESS
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
THANK YOU MISS MITCHELL NOR
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE. DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE AT A VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ALL. TELL YOU ABOUT
I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
WHERE IS THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY SEVEN A. B. ELEVEN NINETY
SEVEN. CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN BY SOME
REMEMBER SANTIAGO AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY DECLARING THE URGENCY
THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. MR SANTIAGO. I
THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ELEVEN
NINETY SEVEN RESPOND TO THE
HOMELESS CRISIS IN LOS ANGELES
BY REMOVING BARRIERS AND
EXPEDITING THE CONSTRUCTION.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ALSO
REQUIRE EMERGENCY SHELTERS ON
THIS BILL TO BE HIGH QUALITY
AND LOW BARRIER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY THE. THEY WERE
SANTIAGO. SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE NUMBER SO. ROSARIO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL LOW'S RURAL TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
ON THE URGENCY AYE SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT. AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE
GREGORY ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA AND ACTUALLY THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE DATA. MR BONTA THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE MEMONS TAKEN IN THE
SENATE IMPLEMENT AND DELAYED
OPERATIVE DATE FOR THE BILL AND
REQUIRE UNIFORMITY IN
COLLECTING AND REPORTING OF
DATA. BECAUSE OF THESE MEMBERS
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND JUDGES
HAVE GONE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY RESPOND TO SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THIS OUT ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A.
QUIRK WELL CLOSER ALL TELL YOU
THAT I AS FIFTY ONE NO SEVEN.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
NINE. AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY FAMILY
MEMBER MCCARTY AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
THIS MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS MEASURES IN
RESPONSE TO THE OPERATION
VARSITY BLUES THE COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS CHEATING SCANDAL AND
FORCING AT SOME OF OUR
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES WERE INDIVIDUALS A
FAKE TO BE STAR ATHLETES AND
WERE. HAD INDIVIDUALS PAID OFF
SO THIS WOULD ENSURE THAT GOING
FORWARD OUR UNIVERSITIES HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT HAS THAT CHECKS AND
BALANCES IN OUR ADMISSIONS
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE IT'S FAIR
AND DOESN'T. EXCLUDE OTHER
SUITS WERE TAKEN THAT SPOT AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
THE CSU SYSTEM BACK WITH
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TO
MAKING SURE OUR PROPOSAL IS IN
LINE WITH THE RECENT UC AUDIT.
PACKAGE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
REST REGARDING SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. OUR GLOBAL
ROLE. THESE ARE NOT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK
WELL. CLOSE ROLE TODD BUT I
SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE HEARD IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY AB. FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT FOUR FOUR RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT I
STILL REMEMBER CARILLO AND
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT. MISS
CARILLO. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS TAKE
IN THE SENATE ARE CLARIFYING
AND TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND
REMOVE ANY CHAPTER IN COMPLEX I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THERE WAS CARRILLO.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CARPOOL OVERALL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
. SIX FORTY
ONE. MISS KOREA MOVES A CALL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE.
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO COVERAGE
AT SOME LEVEL SIXTEEN TWENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO
AND ACTUALLY THE FAMILY
PHYSICIANS THIS CARILLO THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
A. B. SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE SENATE ARE
CLARIFYING IN NATURE AND REMOVE
CHAPTER IN COMPLEX THIS BILL
ENJOYS BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. NAME IS CARRILLO SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM OR CALL THE ROLL. VOTERS
ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
ARE ABOUT. QUIRK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY FOUR. NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT. THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY TWO. AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY
ONE CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE BY SOMETHING
MEMBER GONZALEZ AND ACTUALLY
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT MS
CONSULTANTS THANK YOU
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATOR
CLAIRE FIND IN NATURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE OF.
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL. IT IS OUT OF
THAT ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRABLE. KIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF THE- AYE AYES SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN
. WHAT A PASS
TEMPORARILY ON SEVENTY THREE WE
REFERRED FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FIVE. FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE IS
A. B. SIX. SIX EIGHT BY MISS
GONZALES THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE COURT
HOUSES IT'S GONZALEZ THANK YOU
THE MEMBERS TAKE IN THE SENATE
A NARROW THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL
AND I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ABOUT. THERE'S GONZALEZ
SENIOR CATCHER DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT
OF THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
THE SIX FORTY ONE. CLICK WELL
CLOSER ALL TELEVOTE EYES FORTY
FOUR NOS THIRTEEN. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK.
TWO ITEMS TO SEVENTY THREE FILE
ITEM SEVENTY THREE. AB THIRTY
TWO BY MR BONTA CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA AND
ACTUALLY INTO DETENTION
FACILITIES MR BONTA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
A. B. THIRTY TWO IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE PHASE OUT THE USE OF ALL
FOR PROFIT PRIVATE DETENTION IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING CIVIL
DETENTION. THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IS
SUPPORTED BY THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AS WELL
AS NUMEROUS CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS MONTANA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. OUR GLOBAL
ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A-
WORK WELL. CLOSER ALL TIE VOTE
I FIFTY FIVE KNOWS NINE. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BLOOM NEXT
LINDA PARENTAGE MR BLOOM. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE IS BACK HERE ON
CONCURRENCE FOR LATE AMENDMENTS
THAT FURTHER CLEAN UP THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE THAT
REGULATE DONOR GAMETE AND THE
DECORATION OF PARENTAGE. THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE. THE BILL
PASSED OUT OF THE SENATE WITH
FORTY VOTES LAST NIGHT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOW. SINGER
DISCUSSION DEBATE THE CLUB
LAUREL ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE.
TELL A VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL. ON MISS CORREOS
MEASURE FILE ITEM SEVENTY THIS
IS AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
CORE COMPOSED. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE STATUS OF. CLICK WELL CLOSE.
OPEN THE ROLE. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ALL. HI IS FORTY TWO
KNOWS FIFTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES CENTER MEMBERS ARE
CONVERTED. BACK IN FILE ORDER
THIS IS A. B. ELEVEN SEVENTEEN
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN AB
ELEVEN SEVENTEEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BALL LEVIN SEVENTEEN
BY SOME REMEMBER GRAYSON AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO PEACE
OFFICERS. MR GRAYSON THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
ELEVEN SEVENTEEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL WILL
ESTABLISH STATEWIDE STANDARDS
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT YOUR
SUPPORT PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE
FOR CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN TRAIN PEER SUPPORT TEAM
MEMBERS AND THEIR FELLOW PEACE
OFFICERS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THERE WAS
GRAYSON. SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. QUIRK LIBERAL ALL
MEMBERS OF. IT IS OUT OF IT ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRED ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE THE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO. SENATE
AMENDMENTS OUR CURRENT. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT AB
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR. GREGORY
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN FORTY FOUR
BY SOMETHING MEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND OTHERS AND I TELLING TO
ELECTRICITY THIS FRIEDMAN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR REQUIRES
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO USE 10% OF THE
SELF GENERATION INCENTIVE
PROGRAM FUNDS FROM TWENTY
TWENTY TO BE ALLOCATED TOWARDS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
FACILITIES IN HIGH FIRE
DISTRICTS. SENATE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFIED THAT THESE FEW FUNDS
CANNOT BE USED FOR FOSSIL FUEL
BACKUP GENERATORS ADDED A CO
AUTHOR AND MADE OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND IT'S RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THREE MEN
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COUPLE OF THE ROLE MEMBERS. THE
CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS SO DESIRED
OF A. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
TYLER AS SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS. OUR
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM SEVENTY
NINE IS AB THIRTEEN FORTY CAR
FOR FREE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
FORTY FIVE FAMILY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
MR CHIU YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB THIRTEEN
FORTY IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS
FROM INEFFECTIVE CREW TRAINING
PROGRAMS BY PROVIDING ESSENTIAL
DATA TO STUDENTS AND THE PUBLIC
ON EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES AT FOR
PROFIT SCHOOLS THIS BILL CLOSES
A GAP IN OUR STATES OUTCOME
DATA BY COMPARING STUDENTS
MEDIAN ANNUAL EARNINGS. TO
MEDIAN DEBT TO GIVE STUDENTS
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
MAKE AN INFORMED CHOICE OF THAT
THEY'RE NOT SADDLED WITH DEBT
AND FEW CAREER PROSPECTS
SIGNIFICANT MOMENTS IN THE
SENATE LED TO A BI PARTISAN
UNANIMOUS VOTE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR AND. I HOPE WE CAN DO
THAT HERE WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THINGS CHIU SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THESE ARE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. RESERVE
VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE.
TIE VOTE AS FIFTY NINE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN
. A RESTORED TO PASS
TEMPORARILY. I'M FILE ITEM
EIGHTY. FILE I'M AT ONE HAS
BEEN REFERRED TO COMMITTEE. WE
ARE AT FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO. AB.
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE CORPORATION
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
AND ACTUALLY THE ELEMENTARY AND
SECONDARY EDUCATION MISTER
O'DONNELL. MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN NINETY FIVES
THE ANNUAL K. TWELVE EDUCATION
ON OF US BILL WHICH MAKES
TECHNICAL AND NON CONTROVERSIAL
REVISIONS TO THE EDUCATION CODE
SENATE MOMENTS AT A CHATTERING
OUT LANGUAGE ANOTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES I ASK FOR AND I HAVE A.
THEY MEASURED ALL. SAMEER
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLE TELEVOTE HIGH. SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN. AND THIS IS FILE
ITEM EIGHTY THREE AB SIXTEEN
NINETY FIVE BY MISS CARILLO.
THE CLERK WILL READ AS A LEGAL
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER CARILLO AND ACTUALLY
TO HEALTH FACILITIES MISS KOREA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENT THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE.
REMOVE PROVISIONS DEALING WITH
THE CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP PROCESS
AND MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING
CHANGES I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GRILL SAYING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS OTHERS ARE VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. BIZARRE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CULTURAL TELEVISE
FORTY FOUR KNOWS FIFTEEN. SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT. AND
THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY FOUR
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT BY SOME
REMEMBER CARILLO AND ACTUALLY
THE PREVAILING WAGE. RIO YOU
MAKE IT OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENT THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN THE SENATE REMOVE CHAPTER
IN COMPLEX I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THIS
CREEL SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
QUIRK WELL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THESE ARE THE ALL
MEMBERS OF THIS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSE ROLE TELL THE VOTE
ICE FORTY NINE KNOWS TEN.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN
. I WAS WE HAVE A FEW MORE
CONCURRENCE ITEMS TO DISPENSE
WITH. IN FILE ORDER THIS IS.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE OPERATE
AS A LEGAL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS AND OTHERS AND EXPLAINED
AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYEE HOUSING
MYSTERY THIS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SO I'M VERY PROUD TO
ONCE AGAIN BE HERE PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. A PRIORITY BILL THE
LATINO CAUCUS AND CERTAINLY A
PRIORITY FOR THE MORE THAN
NINETY THOUSAND FARM WORKERS IN
THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT. IN
THE MIDST OF CALIFORNIA'S
UNPRECEDENTED HOUSING CRISIS.
THISBILL IS A CRITICAL STEP
FORWARD IN A DRESS SEEN OUR
FARM WORKER HOUSING SHORTAGE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY NAY THREE CREATES
AN OPT IN STREAMLINED PROCESS
TO BUILD FORMER HOUSING ON
SURPLUS AGRICULTURAL LAND. SETS
QUALITY STANDARDS TO ENSURE
THAT NEW HOUSING IS DIGNIFIED
FAMILY FRIENDLY AND PUT
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO PROTECT
PEOPLE AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
SENATE AMENDMENTS HAVE MADE
THIS BILL STRONGER AND REFLECT
THE FEEDBACK AND SUGGESTIONS WE
RECEIVE FROM EIGHT CD. TO
IMPROVE EFFICIENCY OVERSIGHT
AND PROCEDURAL THE DUTIES AS
PRESCRIBED BY THIS BILL. ONE
NOTABLE AMENDMENT PROVIDING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS A CHECK. A
CHECK TO ENSURE THAT PROJECTS
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF RESIDENTS AND THE
COMMUNITIES AND CAPS ALL
POTENTIAL PROJECTS AT THIRTY
SIX UNITS. COLLEAGUES LET ME
REMIND YOU CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
HOUSING CRISIS ISN'T JUST AN
URBAN PROBLEM. THIS IS A
PROBLEM IN RURAL CALIFORNIA.
THIS HOUSING CRISIS IS PUSH
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND THEIR FAMILIES IT TO
DESPERATE DANGEROUS LIVING
SITUATIONS. IT ISNOT OKAY FOR
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR CHILDREN.
TO LIVE IN GARAGES INTENSE IN
CARS ABANDONED BUILDINGS IN
RURAL MONTEREY COUNTY THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT ONE IN TEN
STUDENTS SHOULD NOT BE HOMELESS.
IT IS NOT OKAY AND WE MUST
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS TO HELP
THOSE WHO PUT FOOD ON OUR
TABLES. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE IS A FIRST BUT A
SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD TO
HELP BUILD HOUSING FOR OUR
FARMWORKERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS
CONCURRENT BOAT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISS
RIVAS. SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CLARK LIBERAL. DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSER ROLE TELEVOTE
FORTY FIVE KNOWS TWELVE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
AND MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SIX. AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY
THREE. THE CLERK WILL READ AS
LEGAL EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND ACTUALLY THE FIRE
PROTECTION. THIS FRIEDMAN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE IS AN
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE BILL WHICH PROVIDES
IMPORTANT CLEAN UP TO
LEGISLATION PASSED LAST YEAR.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CLEAN UP
TO AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN
INCLUDING DEFINING A CLARIFYING
THE DUTIES OF THE FOREST
MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE. THE BILL
DID HAVE A PROVISION DEALING
WITH MANAGEMENT OF FOREST
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS WHICH
HAD OPPOSITION THOSE PROVISIONS
REMOVED FROM THE BILL AND NOW
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
IS RECEIVE NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
CONCURRENCE AND SENTIMENTS.
THANK YOU. I AM IS FRIEDMAN SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. THE CLUB
IN THE ROLE. THESE ARE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS A DESIRABLE. WORK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLL TIDE LOVE EYES
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
NUMBERS ON FILE ITEMS NINETY
THREE NINETY FOUR NINETY FIVE
WILL BE CONTINUE. MOVING TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON ITEMS
FILE ITEMS NINETY SIX TO ONE
HUNDRED. MEMBERS WILL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM ONE OH ONE HR SIXTY
ONE THE CLERK WILL READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION SIXTY ONE BY FAMILY
MEMBER BELINDA'S RELATIVE TO A
DAY OF SOLEMN COMMEMORATION OF
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
AND ONE. NEVER GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION I'M A NUMBER MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN EIGHTEEN
YEARS AGO AS A SERIES OF FOUR
COORDINATED TERRORIST ATTACKS
ARE CARRIED OUT AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES ON THE MORNING OF
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH. BY NINETEEN
ISLAMIC EXTREMISTS. THESE
NINETEEN TERRACE CARRIED
SMUGGLED BOX CUTTERS AND KNIVES
THREE SECURITY AT THREE EAST
COAST AIRPORTS AS THEY BOARDED
FOR EARLY MORNING FLIGHTS WHICH
WERE BOUND FOR CALIFORNIA.
BOUND FOR CALIFORNIA THEY CHOSE
THOSE FLIGHTS BECAUSE THEY WERE
LOADED DOWN WITH THE MOST FEEL
THAT THEY CAN GET ON THE PLANE
FOR SUCH A LONG FLIGHT. EIGHT
FORTY FIVE AM AMERICAN AMERICAN
AIRLINES FLIGHT LOADED WITH
TWENTY THOUSAND GALLONS OF FUEL
FLEW INTO THE NORTH TOWER OF
THE WORLD TRADE CENTER. JUST
AFTER NINE AM AND UNITED
AIRLINES FLIGHT FLEW INTO THE
SOUTH TOWER. THEN AN AMERICAN
WEST SIDE OF THE PENTAGON NINE
FORTY FIVE. IN A FOURTH
CALIFORNIA BOUND PLANE. IT WAS
ABOUT FORTY MINUTES AFTER
TAKING OFF FROM NEWARK NEW
JERSEY. THE PASSENGERS FOUGHT
THE HIJACKERS BY ATTACKING THEM
IN THE COCKPIT ACTUALLY WITH A
FIRE EXTINGUISHER THE PLANE
FLIPPED OVER SPED TOWARD THE
EARTH AND CRASHED IN A FIELD
NEAR SHANKSVILLE IN
PENNSYLVANIA AT TEN TEN AM.
PEOPLE FROM SEVENTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES DIED THAT
DAY IN NEW YORK AND WASHINGTON
DC AND PENNSYLVANIA AND ALMOST
THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE
KILLED AND THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF OTHERS WERE
INJURED AND MANY MORE HAVE LOST
THEIR LIVES SINCE. DUE TO
INJURIES RELATED TO THOSE
ATTACKS SAID WHETHER IT'S
CANCER OR OTHER HEALTH RELATED
ILLNESSES. THESE ATTACKS HAD
BEEN PLANNED FOR YEARS AND THEY
WERE CARRIED OUT BECAUSE OF A
DEEP HATRED FOR AMERICA FOR
VALUES. AND FOR THEIR FRIENDS
IN THE WORLD WE CHOOSE TO
PROTECT. THE TAX DESTROYED A
LOT OF LIVES IT BROKE A LOT OF
HEARTS. BUT IT ALSO BROUGHT
THIS COUNTRY TOGETHER IN A WAY
THAT I'D NEVER SEEN IN MY
LIFETIME WHERE WE ALL LOCKED
ARMS AND STOOD TOGETHER. TO
FIGHT FOR OUR COUNTRY FOR
VALUES FOR OUR FELLOW CITIZENS
IT DIDN'T MATTER WHAT POLITICAL
PARTY YOU WERE. WHAT COLOR YOU
WERE WHERE YOU CAME FROM WE
WERE ALL SOLIDLY UNITED IN
EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO SEEMS LIKE A
LONG TIME AGO I WAS THINKING
ABOUT IT SOME OF YOU IN HERE
WE'RE JUST KIDS WHEN IT
HAPPENED. BUT NO MATTER HOW
MANY YEARS PASS BY OR HOW OLD
YOU WERE WHEN IT HAPPENS I HOPE
THAT NO ONE EVER FORGETS THE
MANY INNOCENT LIVES THAT WERE
LOST NOT BECAUSE OF SOME
DISPUTE OVER LAND BUT SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE STAND FOR.
AND REMEMBER HOW UNITED WE WERE
THEN AND THAT IN IN THE END
WHAT REALLY MATTERS IS TO WHERE
ALL AMERICANS DESPITE OUR
DIFFERENCES WE CARE ABOUT ONE
ANOTHER WE PROTECT ONE ANOTHER
WE STAND UP FOR ONE ANOTHER.
AND. I GUESS I WOULD ASK THAT
WHY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION OUR ALSO
ASK WHEN THE MOMENT COMES IF WE
COULD. OPEN THE FIRST ROLL
UPPER CO AUTHORS THANK YOU.
TAKING HIS MELENDEZ MISS
WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS LET US TAKE TIME TODAY
TO REMEMBER THE TRAGIC EVENTS
OF SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND ONE. AND TO EXTEND OUR
DEEPEST SYMPATHIES TO THE
VICTIMS AND FAMILIES ATTACKED.
THAT DAY ON THE MORNING OF
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH TERRORIST
ATTACK THE UNITED STATES NEARLY
THREE THOUSAND INNOCENT
AMERICANS WERE KILLED. ON THE
ATTACKS AT THE WORLD TRADE
CENTER THE PENTAGON AND ON
FLIGHT NINETY TWO WHICH CRASHED
IN THE FIELD IN PENNSYLVANIA
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED PUBLIC
SAFETY PERSONNEL PERISHED IN
THE IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF THE
ATTACKS. IN MANY FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE STILL LOOP
LOSING THEIR LIVES TODAY FROM
BEING EXPOSED TO THE TOXIC
DEBRIS IN THE AIR. ON THIS
MORNING EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO. IT
DAWNED AS A BEAUTIFUL NEW YORK
MORNING LIKE SO MANY FALL
MORNINGS ACTUALLY THE BEST TIME
OF THE YEAR TO BE IN NEW YORK
THE WEATHER IS ABSOLUTELY
BEAUTIFUL WHEN I SAW THE
PICTURES IT WAS IT WAS JUST
DEVASTATING THE SEE THAT BLUE
SKY AND THEN THE SMOKE WITH IT.
KNOW THAT THIS MORNING WOULD BE
DIFFERENT. ONE THAT WOULD
CHANGE THE WORLD FOREVER THE
NIGHT BEFORE HUNDREDS PREPARE
FOR THEIR TRIPS PACKING BAGS
THEY WOULD NEVER RE OPEN. IF
YOU HAVE EVER BEEN TO THE WORLD
TRADE CENTER IN NEW YORK YOU
WOULD KNOW THE ENORMITY OF
THOSE STRUCTURES. EVERYONE WHO
LIVE THERE KNEW SOMEONE WHO
WORKED THERE. THE BUILDINGS
WERE LIKE MANY CITIES THERE ARE
LIKE THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
EACH BUILDING. TODAY I STAND
THE REMEMBRANCE OF THE HUNDREDS
OF CLASSMATES AND FAMILY
MEMBERS FROM MY HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE WHO DIED THAT MORNING.
INCLUDING SPECIFICALLY THAT THE
ONE OF THE FIRST PERSONS TO DIE
IN THE WORLD TRADE CENTER
CHAPLAIN MYCHAL JUDGE WHO WAS A
FIRE CHAPLAIN BUT HE WAS ALSO
THE CHAPLAIN AT MY HIGH SCHOOL.
CAPTAIN TIMOTHY STACKPOLE WAS A
CLASSMATE FROM FDNY. AND
CAPTAIN VINNY G. A MONA WHO WAS
JUST GETTING READY TO SERVE TO
CELEBRATE HIS FORTIETH BIRTHDAY
AND WAS MADE CAPTAIN THAT WEEK
AT FDNY. I RAN TRACK WITH HIM
HE WAS A CLASSMATE. EVERYONE
CAN REMEMBER WHERE THEY WERE
THAT MORNING MY SON WAS SITTING
IN THE HIGH CHAIR FACING ME AS
I WAS FEEDING HIM AND SOMEONE
SAID OH MY GOD YOU'RE GOING TO
TURN ON THE TV AND RIGHT BEHIND
HIM WAS THE TV. AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN AS A NEW MOM MY WHOLE
PERSPECTIVE ON LIFE IN THE
FUTURE WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO LIVE
IN THIS WORLD. CHANGED. THAT
ALSO MEANS THAT EVERYONE ELSE
WHO'S NOW WITH THIS UP TO A
SENIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL. WAS NOT
ALIVE DURING THE TIME OF THESE
ATTACKS. DON'T REMEMBER AND
DON'T KNOW. AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT. THAT WE KEEP THAT
REMEMBER TO LIVE AND TEACH THEM.
SO WE EXTENDED AGAIN OUR
DEEPEST SYMPATHIES TO THE
THOUSANDS OF INNOCENT VICTIMS
OF THIS ATTACK. AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AND OUR FIRST
RESPONDER HEROES. WE NEED TO
LIVE EACH DAY AND NEVER MISS A
CHANCE TO TELL ARE THE ONES
DEAR TO US THAT WE LOVE THEM.
AND THE BEST WAY WE CAN HONOR
THOSE ON NINE ELEVEN. IS TO
LIVE LIKE IT'S NINE TWELVE WE
REMEMBER HOW THAT THEY WAS WE
WERE SO UNIFOR UNIFIED TOGETHER
SO. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND MAY
WE NEVER FORGET. THANK YOU MISS
WALDRON IS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND LIKE TO IT I
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LIKE
HOUSE NOR FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD. YOU'RE
EIGHTEEN YEARS ON THE MEMORY OF
THAT MORNING IS STILL. AS RAW
AS EVER AND. AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO SAID I THINK WE
WILL ALWAYS REMEMBER WHERE WE
WERE WHEN WE HEARD THAT
HORRIBLE NEWS. WE ARE LIVING
RIGHT NOW IN. DIVIDED TIMES AND
I THINK THAT EVEN IN TIMES LIKE
THAT SOME PERHAPS ESPECIALLY IN
TIMES LIKE THIS IT IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR US TO REMEMBER
THAT WE HAVE MUCH MORE IN
COMMON THAN WE DO AT ODDS AND
THAT THE TIES THAT BIND US
TOGETHER MUCH STRONGER THAN ANY
OF THE FORCES THAT ARE SEEKING
TO TEAR US APART. SEC THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD LET'S NEVER FORGET. THE
MORNING OF SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH
AND LET'S NEVER FORGET THAT
EACH AND EVERY PERSON. EACH AND
EVERY EFFECT WAS AN AMERICAN
FIRST AND FOREMOST THANK YOU.
TAKEN IS BETWEEN NORTHWEST
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS UP.
WE THROW. THE WORD HERO AROUND
A LOT. AND SOMETIMES IT'S%
DESERVED AND SOMETIMES IT'S A
BIT OF A AT AN EXPRESSION OF
APPRECIATION BUT IT EXAGGERATES
THE NOTION. OF HEROISM. AND
NINE ELEVEN REALLY DOES BRING
HOME WHAT HEROES DO AND WHO
THEY ARE. WE SAW OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS WHILE PEOPLE WERE
RUNNING AWAY FOR THEIR LIVES
THEY WERE RUNNING TOWARD THE
HORROR. KNOWING FULL WELL THAT
THEY MAY VERY WELL RISK THEIR
OWN LIVES FOR SOMEONE ELSE.
THAT'S REALLY HER ROLE WAKE. WE
WITNESSED ANOTHER. ACT OF
HEROISM WHEN THOSE. INDIVIDUALS
IN FLIGHT NINETY THREE.
TOGETHER SAID LET'S ROLL. AND
THEY DID SOMETHING VERY HEROIC
AND THEY KNEW. AT THE TIME THEY
DID IT. THAT THEY WERE RISKING
THEIR LIVES. AND SO I THINK IT
REMINDS US ALSO OF. THOSE
AMONGST US DO THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT WE IMAGINE. WE
MIGHT HOPEFULLY TO. IF CALLED
UPON AND YET WHO REALLY KNOWS.
I THINK THIS IS A TIME TO ASK
OURSELVES THE QUESTION HOW
SHOULD WE THEN LIVE BEING GIVEN
SUCH A WITNESS. AND IT IS A
TIME TO REMEMBER I THINK IT'S
ALSO A TIME TO THINK VERY
SERIOUSLY. WHAT WOULD WE DO AT
A MOMENT THAT TESTED OUR SOULS
TO BECOME THE PEOPLE WE HOPE.
WE CAN BE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER PATTERSON IS OUR QUE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I TWO ONE I THINK
OUR COLLEAGUE MIKE ELSINORE FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD. AND I WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF OUR COLLEAGUES WHO
SAID THEY REMEMBER WHERE THEY
WERE THAT DAY. I WAS THE LAW
STUDENT I WAS MY FIRST BOOK OF
LAW SCHOOL. CAPITOL HILL IN
WASHINGTON DC. WATCH IT ON THE
TELEVISION IDN'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND WAS GOING ON SO I
WENT TO CLASS. WELL AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW HOW THEY EVACUATED.
CAPITOL HILL AND IT WAS A SCENE
LIKE NONE I'VE EVER SEEN
BEFORE. WE WATCHED THE SMOKE
COMING OFF THE PENTAGON. PEOPLE
WERE RUNNING FROM THEIR CARS
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T GET OUT
FAST ENOUGH BECAUSE THE PLANE
THAT WENT DOWN IN PENNSYLVANIA
WAS RUMORED TO BE HEADED OUR
WAY. THE FEAR THAT EACH OF US
FELT THAT DAY. AND THE HEROES
WHO CAME TO OUR AID. TO PROTECT
EACH AND EVERYONE OF US AND TO
FIGHT FOR ALL THE LIVES THAT
THEY COULD. IN THE TWIN TOWERS
IN NEW YORK AND ELSEWHERE. WAS
AMAZING. ANDIN THE DAYS THAT
FOLLOWED BEING IN WASHINGTON
AND BEING ON CAPITOL HILL
WATCHING AS OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE
SPOKEN. THAT WE KNEW THAT THE
VALUES THAT EACH OF US COMES
HERE EVERY DAY TO PROTECT WERE
UNDER ATTACK. AND THAT WE WOULD
STAND STRONG. IN THOSE VALUES
WAS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
REMEMBER ALWAYS TO HOLD ON TO.
AND AS WE HAVE VIGOROUS DEBATES
TODAY AND THROUGH THE REST OF
THE WEEK AND AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. WE KNOW THAT EACH OF
US. HOLDS DEAR THE VALUES OF
THIS COUNTRY. AND THE NO MATTER
WHAT HAPPENS THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
FIGHTING FOR AND TO PROTECT.
AND SO I WANTED TO RISE TODAY
TO REMEMBER THAT FEELING
BECAUSE I KNOW THE VIGOROUS
DEBATES WILL CONTINUE. BUT WE
ARE UNITED AND IN THE MEMORY OF
THOSE THAT WERE LOST WITH
CONTINUED TO HOLD THOSE VALUES
DEAR. ME EACH OF THEIR MEMORIES
BE A BLESSING. FIGURES
BARRICADE HAND DOCTOR CHOI YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
SPEAKER. AND THE NORTH SAW SOME
OF THE MEMBER MELENDEZ OF FOR
BRINGING UP BUT THIS AT AGE OF
SIXTY ONE LET ME ASK A FEW OF
MY THOUGHTS. EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO
TODAY AMERICA WAS SHOT. FOR
THAT MATTER THE WORLD WAS
SHOCKED. TO WATCH THE CRUMBLING
TWIN TOWERS. THE PROUD THE
SYMBOL OF AMERICAN WELL'S TO
HAND THE PERHAPS OF THE SYMBOL
BOOK CAPTORS. IT WAS SO A
WAKEUP CALL TO AMERICA. WE WERE
NOT. SAVEFILE AS WE THOUGHT.
AND THE FROM THEIR OWN. OUR
LIFESTYLES HAVE PERMANENTLY
CHANGED. WE CAN EVEN ARE TAKEN
ON OPEN THE BOTTLE OF. WATER
BEYOND THE SECURITY POINT. BUT
THE NO ONE COMPLAINS BECAUSE A
WE UNDERSTAND THAT. THE TIMES I
HAVE CHANGED AND ON OUR SAFETY
IS A MORE IMPORTANT. ALL OF THE
INCONVENIENCES. ON THE OTHER
HAND HOW SOON ARE WE FORGET.
HAD HAPPENED ON SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH OF TWO THOUSAND ONE.
SOME INCLUDING US SOME
GOVERNMENT LEADERS THINK A WE
ARE SAFE WITH THE EVEN WITH YOU
OPEN BORDERS. WHICH SHOT ANYONE
CAN CROSS. WE WILL NOT KNOW
WHO'S CROSSING OUR BORDERS. WE
WOULD NOT KNOW IF A FEW OF THEM
ARE OUR ENEMIES ONE. LIKE THOSE
SO WHO ATTACKED THE TWIN TOWERS.
ONCE THEY ACROSS THE BORDER SO
CALLED THE SANCTUARY CITIES
SANCTUARY US STATES ARE LIKE
CALIFORNIA WOULD WELCOME THEM
WITH OPEN ARMS AND THE- FOOD
AND SHELTER. HOW SOON DO WE FOR
GAS. THAT THOUGHT ONE ONE HALF
OF THE WAR THE POPULATION HATES
AMERICA. NINE ELEVEN REMINDS US
THAT THAT. NINE ELEVEN
REMINDERS THAT THE IT IS SO OUR
LAST TO WAKEUP CALL AND WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO AND ON THE ONE.
YES SIR IT IS TIME TO REMEMBER
AT THE INNOCENT VICTIM SO AND
THE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
WERE THE FIRST RESPONDENTS. WHO
ALSO VANISHED THE TOGETHER. BUT
WE CAN JUST A TO L. UPON THE IS
CHARLES AND A TRAGIC MOMENT
AMERICA MUST OUR LOOK AT THE
BIGGER PICTURE OUR OF THE
TRAGIC NINE ELEVEN. WE SHOULD
ASK AT THESE TYPES OF QUESTIONS.
HOW CAN WE BE SURE OF ON THE
WHOLE REPEAT OFF ON NINE ELEVEN.
WHO ARE OUR ENEMIES. HOW CAN WE
SURVIVE AS A NATION. WHAT
SHOULD YOU DO AS A NATION. GOD
BLESS AMERICA. THIS MESSAGE SHE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LIKE
ELSINORE FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION TO OUR
FLOOR AND I ALSO JOIN ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN HONORING AND
REMEMBERING ALL THE VICTIMS ALL
THE OR OUR FIRST RESPONDERS AND
ALL THOSE. WHO DEMONSTRATED OUR.
WHICH IS AN ODD TO OUR COUNTRY
IN RESPONSE TO NINE ELEVEN. YOU
KNOW WHEN NINE ELEVEN HAPPENED.
THERE WERE SOME PEOPLE THAT
COMPARED THIS FIRST TERRORIST
ATTACK ON AMERICAN SOIL. A
PEARL HARBOUR. AND. PEARL
HARBOR. RESONATES IN A VERY
SPECIAL WAY WITH THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY BECAUSE. ON
THE ONE HAND WE KNOW THAT. AN
ENEMY IS ATTACKING AMERICANS ON
AMERICAN SOIL. BUT IT'S ALSO
ANOTHER IMPORTANT LESSON OF
NINE ELEVEN IS THAT WE REMEMBER.
TO DISTINGUISH THE ENEMIES THAT
ATTACK US. FROM. LOYAL
AMERICANS WHETHER OF JAPANESE
ANCESTRY. FOLLOWING WORLD WAR
TWO OR LOYAL MUSLIM AMERICANS.
THAT. WE MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T ENGAGED AND RACIAL
PROFILING OR RACIAL
STEREOTYPING. AS A RESPONSE TO
DID THESE DRAMATIC EVENTS. AND
I ASK THAT WE. ALSO REMEMBER
THAT AS AN IMPORTANT LESSON OF
NINE ELEVEN. MEMBERS OF YOUR
SPEAK ON THE RESOLUTION PLEASE
PUT YOUR MIKE SEVEN UNSCHOOLING
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I
A AND MOVED JUST BECAUSE THIS
IS JUST I LISTED MY CALLERS
TODAY MY COLLEAGUE FROM LAKE
ELSINORE BRING THIS BEFORE US.
ON MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO
REFLECTED UPON THE ROLE OF
HEROISM ON THAT DAY. AND I SIT
HERE UNDERNEATH THE PICTURE OF
ABRAHAM LINCOLN. AND THE THINGS
I SORT OF PUT TOGETHER OF
COURSE IS DAYS LIKE THIS OUR
DAYS REMEMBER THOSE WHO PASSED
AWAY THIS REALLY FOR THE
PRESENT WE LIVE AS MY COLLEAGUE
IS EMPHASIZED OUR RELATIONS ONE
WITH ANOTHER. AND. SO MUCH OF
AMERICAN CIVIC LIFE IS ACTUALLY
BOUND UP IN LOOKING AT HEROISM
FROM AFAR. THE STOPPER FORTY
POINT THAT'S ACTUALLY THE STAR
SPANGLED BANNER. IS A SONG
ABOUT LOOKING AT HEROISM FROM
AFAR IS FRANCIS SCOTT KEY WAS
IN THE HARBOR LOOKING THROUGH
THE NIGHT AT THE AMERICAN FLAG
AS WOULD. FLASH IN THE LIGHT
MOMENTARILY. SAYING SOMETHING
ABOUT THE HAIR WAS AND IT WAS
THERE. AND ON THIS DAY WE
REMEMBER THE HEROES OF NINE
ELEVEN. AND IT I CONNECTED TO
ABRAHAM LINCOLN AS HE. WENT TO
HIS FIRST INAUGURAL. WITH
AMERICA IN GREAT CONFLICT. AND
WHAT A CONUNDRUM TO SEE AN
AMERICA THAT WAS STILL YOUNG.
THIS CONCEPT OF A UNION. AND
COMING APART AT THE SEAMS. THE
BUNDLE OF STICKS WHICH IS SO
UBIQUITOUS ON MY LABEL IS ON
THE FRONT OF HIS CHAIR IN THE
LINCOLN MEMORIAL. ON BOTH SIDES
PRETTY TO CHANCE BECAUSE HE
KEPT AMERICA FROM FLYING APART.
WHICH IS SORT OF OUR CHALLENGE
IN OUR AREA. BUT ABRAHAM
LINCOLN FACED WITH THIS
CONUNDRUM. OF HOW DO WE BRING
BACK. FIND THE CENTER OF
AMERICA AS HE WENT TO HIS
INAUGURAL. AS WE ARE DOING HERE
HE REFLECTED UPON HEROISM
VIEWED FROM AFAR. AND
CHALLENGES LISTENERS TO THINK
ABOUT OUR CONNECTION TO OTHER
HEROES. AND A RECENT OURSELVES
AND SO ON THE STAIRS WE HONOR
THIS PERMISSION TO READ THESE
THE CONCLUDING REMARKS OF
ABRAHAM LINCOLN THAT I SORT OF
RELATE TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FRESNO POINT OUT THAT. WE HAVE
A SPECIAL REGARD FOR THESE
HEROES. MY PHONE SET UP SO I
APOLOGIZE AS I PROCEED. I AM
LOATH TO CLOSE. WE ARE NOT
ENEMIES BUT FRIENDS. WE MUST
NOT BE ENEMIES. THOUGH PASSION
MAY HAVE STRAINED. IT MUST NOT
BREAK OUR BONDS OF AFFECTION OF
COURSE BECAUSE OF THE AMERICAN
UNION. THE MYSTIC CHORDS OF
MEMORY. STRETCHING FROM EVERY
BATTLE FIELD AND PATRIOT GRAVE.
TO EVERY LIVING HARDENED HEARTS
STONE. ALL OVER THIS BROAD LAND
WILL YET SWELL THE COURSE OF
THE UNION WHEN AGAIN TOUCHED AS
SURELY THEY WILL BE BY THE
BETTER ANGELS OF OUR NATURE. I
THINK THIS MEMORIAL THIS
OBSERVANCE REMINDS US OF WHAT
IS THE CENTER OF AMERICAN LIFE.
THE VALUES THAT UNDER GIRD OUR
NATION FOR WHICH PEOPLE HAVE.
SACRIFICED THEMSELVES. AND I DO
THINK WE ALL OF THIS FOR LABOR
AND HOPE THAT IN TIME SOME OF
THE- TENSION IN AMERICAN CIVIC
LIFE. WILL BE HEALED AS PEOPLE
REFLECT UPON WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRING THIS FOR TODAY. THANK YOU
MISTER COOLEY. TO MAKE THIS
YEAR RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I WAS
GOING TO SPEAK ON THIS BOY. YOU
KNOW THINKING ABOUT THE HOW. WE
PUT OUT ALL THESE SENTIMENTS
ABOUT HOW OUR FIRST RESPONDERS.
OUR HEROES HOW WE LOOK BACK TO
NINE ELEVEN HOW WE TALK ABOUT
HOW IMPORTANT THIS DAY IS IN
OUR HISTORY. AND HOW MUCH
RESPECT WE HAVE IN I MEAN I
KNOW WHERE I WAS WE ALL KNOW
WHERE WHERE YOU WERE. THIS IS
REALLY THE SPARK OF MY MILITARY
CAREER AND GOING INTO COMBAT.
BOY. I I'M JUST HONESTLY TAKEN
ABACK. FOR THIS WHOLE WEEK FOR
LAWS THAT WE'VE JUST PASSED
ABOUT NOT HELPING OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHEN THEIR NEED BUT
YET WE HAVE THE AUDACITY ON THE
STATE TO THANK THEM. AND JUST
IT IT BLOWS MY MIND WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE. THIS WEEK ON THE
FLOOR. AND AS WE REALLY THINK
ON THIS DAY THINK ABOUT THESE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE PASSED. AND
WHAT THAT MEANS TO THEM.
BECAUSE ON ONE HAND. WE SAY WE
RESPECT YOU YOU'RE OUR HEROES
AND ON THE OTHER HAND WE SAID I
DON'T HAVE YOUR BACK. SO I JUST
WANNA LET YOU TO THINK ABOUT
THAT TODAY THANK YOU. MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I DO
ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM LAKE ELSINORE
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
FOR EVERYONE WHO SPOKE IN.
ABOUT THE MESSAGE OF UNITY AND
TOGETHERNESS THAT I THINK THE
STATE OUGHT TO REPRESENT I DID
WANT TO RESPOND. BRIEFLY TO THE
COMMENTS OF OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
IRVINE AS HE WAS TALKING IT
REMINDED ME. OF SOMETHING. BUT
I'D FORGOTTEN ABOUT. AND THAT I
THINK IS IMPORTANT THING THAT
WE REMEMBER. AND I WANTED TO
COMPLEMENT THE ARE PRESENT AT
THAT TIME GEORGE HW BUSH'S NOT
SOMEONE WHOSE POLITICAL VIEWS
AYE. AYE SHARE SOMEONE WHO I
OFTEN COMPLIMENT BUT I'M
REMINDED THAT IN. JUST SEVERAL
DAYS AFTER THE NINE ELEVEN
ATTACKS YOU TRAVEL TO THE
ISLAMIC CENTER OF WASHINGTON.
AND HE TALKED ABOUT THE NEED TO
EMBRACE OUR COMMUNITY OUR
MUSLIM AMERICAN COMMUNITY HERE.
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
THE VALUABLE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
MUSLIM AMERICANS. SO I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE WITH WITH YOUR
PERMISSION MISTER SPEAKER SOME
OF WHAT PRESIDENT GEORGE W.
BUSH SAID. THE OBJECTION AND HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT THOSE WHO
WERE WERE SEEKING TO INTIMIDATE
MUSLIM AMERICANS AND HE SAID.
THOSE WHO FEEL LIKE THEY CAN
INTIMIDATE OUR FELLOW CITIZENS
TO TAKE OUT THEIR ANGER DON'T
REPRESENT THE BEST OF AMERICA
THEY REPRESENT THE WORST OF
HUMAN KIND. AND THEY SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF THAT KIND OF
BEHAVIOR. THIS IS A GREAT
COUNTRY IT'S A GREAT COUNTRY
BECAUSE WE SHARE THE SAME
VALUES OF RESPECT AND DIGNITY
AND HUMAN WORTH. IT IS MY HONOR
TO BE MEETING WITH LEADERS WHO
FEEL JUST THE SAME WAY I DO.
THEY'RE OUTRAGED THEY'RE SAD
THEY LOVE AMERICA JUST AS MUCH
AS I DO. AND I THINK IN THAT
MOMENT TO SEAT PRESIDENT GEORGE
W. BUSH COMMON EMBRACE ARE
MUSLIM AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO
STAND SHOULDER TO SHOULDER WITH
THEM. THAT WAS A REFLECTION OF
THE UNITY THAT MAKES THIS
COUNTRY GREAT OF THE SENSE OF
PARTNERSHIP AND COLLABORATION
THAT MAKES THIS COUNTRY GREAT I
JUST WANTED TO REMIND ALL OF US
IN THIS CHAMBER OF THAT BECAUSE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I FORGOTTEN
AND I THINK IS A REALLY
POWERFUL MESSAGE. AND IMAGE
THAT WE SHOULD ALL REMEMBER ON
THIS TERRIBLE ANNIVERSARY.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL. THIS ONE
IS NOT TO CLOSE. WELL I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES WHO ROSE TO
SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS AND
EXPERIENCES SOME OF YOU
REGARDING THIS RESOLUTION AND I
THE INTENT OF BRINGING THE
RESOLUTION FORWARD YOU KNOW
THIS TIME OF YEAR WE'RE VERY
BUSY WORK WE'RE WE'RE KNEE DEEP
IN A LOT OF VERY COMPLICATED
ISSUES AND SOMETIMES IT AND
MOTIONS FLARE. THIS WAS NOT
ONLY TO HONOR THOSE WE LOST BUT
ALSO PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
PART WAY THROUGH THE WEEK TO
KIND OF TAMPA DOWN WHEN
EVERYONE THINK ABOUT PRIORITIES
AND WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THIS WAS THIS IS NOT MEANT TO
BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
POLITICIZE. A VERY HISTORIC
EVENT IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY
THIS IS NOT ABOUT ONE'S RACE
RELIGION OR WHERE YOU CAME FROM
NONE OF THAT THIS IS ABOUT.
AMERICANS. AN AND FRANKLY THE
PEOPLE FROM THE SEVENTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES WHO ALSO
LOST THEIR LIVES THAT DAY THIS
IS ABOUT AN ATTACK ON GOOD.
FROM EVIL THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT AND IT'S NOT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SALLY. THE
MEMORY OF THOSE WE LOST IN THE
GREAT SACRIFICE THAT THEY MADE
FOR ALL OF US IT'S TO REMIND US
WHAT IS AT STAKE WHY IT IS
IMPORTANT WE STICK TOGETHER WHY
WE STAY UNITED AND UNIFIED
REGARDLESS. OF OUR POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES ARE DIFFERENCES ON
POLICY THAT IT REALLY DOESN'T
MATTER WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THIS ON LIMITS I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR THOUGHTS
AND WISHING THAT. THANK THE
MAJORITY FLOOR LEADER FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BRING UP TODAY
NO IT'S A LITTLE BIT UNUSUAL
BUT I THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT
DATA RECOGNIZE SO WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK FOR THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHOR. AUTHORS AND
I WOULD ALSO ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
TAKING HIS MELENDEZ. MEMBERS MS
MELENDEZ ASKING FOR AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. THERE WAS THIS IS
RESOLUTION. IN A MOVE TO A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE HI
THE OPPOSED SAY NAY. GUYS HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WILL MOVE TO SENATE
THIRD READING. THIS BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE OF
THREE SENATE BILL SEVEN A SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
SEVEN OH SEVEN BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE HE AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO ARBITRATION. MR
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES
SB SEVEN OF SEVEN. IS A NARROW
BILL THAT PROVIDES A REMEDY FOR
CONSUMERS AND WORKERS WHEN
THEY'VE BEEN FORCED TO SIGN AN
ARBITRATION CLAUSE AND THEN THE
BUSINESS REFUSES TO PAY ONE
ARBITRATION BEGINS OR STOPS
PAYING HALF WAY THROUGH. THIS
INTENTIONAL NON PAYMENT OF
ARBITRATION FEES HAS THE EFFECT
OF BARRING WORKERS AND
CONSUMERS FROM BOTH COURT. AN
ARBITRATION LEAVING THEM
WITHOUT ANYWAY TO SEEK REDRESS
FOR WRONGFUL TERMINATION WAGE
THEFT OR FRAUD SB SEVEN OH
SEVEN LAYS OUT THE PROCESS AND
PENALTIES FOR THIS TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR. THE BILL ALSO ADDS
THE SAME DIVERSITY REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR ARBITRATORS
DEMOGRAPHICS AS IS ALREADY
REPORTED FOR OUR JUDICIAL BENCH.
I URGE AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU MISTER
MARTIN NEVER SEEN ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON ITEM THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
SIX FORTY ONE MEMBERS. CLOSE
THE WRONG TALLY THE VOTE AYE
AYES FORTY THREE KNOWS SIXTEEN
MEASURE PASSES. THERE'S A PATH
TO RETAIN AN ITEM FILE ITEM
WHAT FOR PASS TEMPORARILY AN
ITEM OF ONE OH FIVE. PASS
RETAIN ITEMS ONE OF SIX TO ONE
TEN. PASS TEMPORARILY ON ITEM
FILE ITEM ONE ELEVEN. PASS
RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS ONE
TWELVE AND ONE THIRTEEN.
NUMBERS THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM OF ONE FOURTEEN SENATE
BILL THREE SEVEN SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND ACTUALLY THE
JUVENILES MR STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. WE HAVE
CENTER MCGUIRE I'D LIKE TO
PRESENT SB THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS FOR
OUR FOSTER YOUTH ARE A MAJOR
MAJOR PROBLEM INSTEAD OF
DEALING WITH THE ISSUES FOR
FOSTER KIDS AND FORTUNE THE
SYSTEM HAS OFTEN TAKEN TO
MEDICAL CONSTRAINTS LIKE
PSYCHOTROPIC DRUGS. WHAT SB
SEVENTY SEVEN DOES IS FOLLOW A
STRING OF POLICIES THAT ARE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
AND IT SETS UP A TASK FORCE TO
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN WE CAN BEST
REACH OUT AND TALK TO KIDS WHO
HAD BEEN OVER MEDICATED. IT
REQUIRES THE MEDICAL BOARD
GIVES THE MEDICAL BOARD THE
ABILITY TO DO CONFIDENTIAL
INVESTIGATIONS OF OVER
PRESCRIPTION OF PSYCHOTROPIC
DRUGS AND ASK THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. TO WORK WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD AND OTHERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S BEING
DONE IN AN APPROPRIATE WAY SO
THAT WE ARE BEST PROTECTING THE
YOUTH WHO HAVE BEEN HARMED AND
PROTECTING THEIR PRIVACY IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE SERVING
YOUTH. BETTER ON BEHALF OF
CENTER MCGUIRE I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
STONE. NEVER SEEN NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION THE CLERK WILL WHEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL IT
WAS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLICK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE PALATABLE
AYE AYES SIXTY FIVE KNOWS IT
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. THERE'S A
MOVED UP FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
FIFTEEN SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE
BILL FOR EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR
PELL AND OTHERS IN ACTUALLY
DRIVING PRIVILEGE. MISTER JONES
SAWYER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. SB FORTY
FIVE PROHIBITS TO SUSPENSION OF
A DRIVER'S LICENSE FOR NON.
VEHICLE RELATED CRIMES THERE'S
NO DATA SHOWING SUSPENSIONS
INCREASED PUBLIC SAFETY HOWEVER
THERE IS DATA SHOWING THIS
LEADS TO INCARCERATION. FINES
AND FEES AND IMPOUNDING
VEHICLES WITH ALL
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTING
LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. SB FORTY
FIVE ELIMINATES AN INEFFICIENT
AND UNNECESSARY WORK LOVE TO
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES MAINTAINING
POINT AND PAY RESTITUTION. THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER JONES
SAWYER. SCENE NO DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS FORTY
SEVEN KNOWS THIRTEEN MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA GO
BACK IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE ELEVEN. SENATE BILL
FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR ALLEN AND OTHERS AND
EXPLAIN TO ELECTIONS. MR MULLIN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS SB FORTY
SEVEN REQUIRES SIGNATURE
GATHERS TO PROVIDE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS WITH THE NAMES OF THE
TOP THREE FUNDERS OF AN
INITIATIVE CAMPAIGN. AT A
MOMENT WHEN THE DISCLOSURE IS
CRUCIAL WHEN A PETITION IS
BEING SHARED WITH VOTERS AND
THEY'RE DECIDING WHETHER OR NOT
TO SIGN IT. UNDER CURRENT LAW
COMMITTEES PAIN TO QUALIFY
INITIATIVE REFERENDUM A RECALL
MUST FILE PERIODIC CAMPAIGN
FINANCE REPORTS HOWEVER VOTERS
WHO SIGNED PETITIONS TO NOT
HAVE CONVENIENT ACCESS TO THE
SUPPORT DISCLOSURE WHAT
APPROACHED BY A SIGNATURE
GATHERER. SB FORTY SEVEN
COMMITTEE OPTION. THIS CALL
SEEING FUNDING FOR ME CAN
EITHER ON A PETITION ITSELF OR
PRESENTING VOTERS WITH THE
SEPARATE OFFICIAL TOP FUNDER
SHEET THAT CAN ALSO INCLUDE THE
NAME OF THE- OF THREE OF THE
PETITIONS ENDORSERS. BY
PROVIDING THE PUBLIC WITH
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT WHO IS
FINANCING INITIATIVE AT THE
MOMENT WHEN THEY'RE WHEN
THEY'RE CONTEMPLATING WHAT NOT
TO SUPPORT IT SB FORTY SEVEN
MAKE A NOTE ON PART COMMON
SIMPLE AND- TO THE PETITION
PROCESS FOR INITIATIVE.
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN REPORTER
BY COMMON ALSO. FIRST THE
LEGISLATION THE SENATE WITH
BIPARTISAN. SUPPORT THANKFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES AYE AYES FORTY TWO
KNOWS FIVE MEASURE PASSES.
NEVER WILL MEMBERS WILL MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE OH FIVE. THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY FOUR BY SENATOR SKINNER
AND OTHERS IN ATLANTA CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE. SOME OF THE ROLEX
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
2% SB THREE NINETY FOUR ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR SKINNER. SB
THREE NINETY FOUR WOULD GIVE
COURTS THE OPTION TO CREATE A
PRE TRIAL. DIVERSION PROGRAM
FOR PRIMARY CARE GIVERS OF
DEPENDENT CHILDREN.
UNFORTUNATELY LONG TERM
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN WHO END
UP IN OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
ARE NOT IT WITH AN INCREASED
CHANCE OF DROPPING OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL. I NEVER GOING TO
COLLEGE MANY OF THE CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM ARE THE
RESULT OF PARENTS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED. THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO ALLOW THOSE MONIES
THAT WANT TO PER TO PRE TRIAL
DIVERSION SO THAT CHILDREN CAN
STAY WITH THEIR PARENTS OR
PRIMARY CAREGIVER WHILE HOLDING
THE PARENTS ACCOUNTABLE. FOR
THE ALLEGED CRIME. IN ORDER TO
SET THE PROGRAM OUTLINED BY SB
THREE NINETY FOUR THE JUDGE
PROSECUTING ATTORNEY. AND THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER ALL HAVE TO
AGREE IF THE DISK TURKEY DOES
NOT AGREE PROGRAM IT DOES NOT
GO FORWARD. SB THREE FOUR
COURTS TO CHOOSE YOU. THAT THAT
TO TURN BUT A PATH THAT WILL
KEEP. US TOGETHER HOLDING BOTH
COUNTABLE WHILE THEY GET THEIR
LIVESBACK ON. TRACK THIS HAS
WHAT MADE. OF SIX. YOU ARE
BEING TO THE- ELEVATORS PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AS WELL AS THE
AMERICAN CONSERVATIVE UNION.
AND IT ALSO TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE PROGRAM. PARENTS MUST BE
THE LEGAL GUARDIAN OF A MINOR
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN LIVE
IN THE SAME HOUSEHOLD PROVIDE
CARE. FOR THAT MINOR AND NOT BE
CONVICTED OF SERIOUS FELONIES
VIOLENT CRIMES OR CRIMES
AGAINST CHILDREN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. TAKING HIS WICKS. SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM I'M SORRY I APOLOGIZE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YES I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINETY
FOUR. AND THIS IS ANOTHER
DIFFICULT VOTE FOR ME. IT WOULD
EASY LEE A LAYOFF VOTE FOR ME
BUT I WANT TO TELL YOU THAT I
AM A VETERAN I WORK WITH MANY
VETERAN ORGANIZATIONS AND
VETERANS COURTS ARE MUCH THE
SAME AS WHAT THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES. IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE. A DEFENSE
THAT MAYBE YOUR FIRST OFFENSE.
THAT YOU GET SPECIAL
CONSIDERATION ESPECIALLY IF
YOUR PRIMARY CARE GIVER AND
IT'S A FAMILY OF THAT. THIS
PROTECTS CHILDREN BECAUSE AS
THE AUTHOR SAID IT'S GOTTA GO
THROUGH MANY FILTERS. AND IF
THE CHILD THEMSELVES AS
INVOLVED THEN ITS HANDS OFF
VETERANS COURTS SAVE MANY MANY
VETERANS WHO GET THE HELP THEY
NEED AT THAT TIME. AND IT'S
LIKE A ONE STRIKE PROGRAM IF
YOU MESS IT UP AGAIN YOU'RE
DONE YOU GO BACK TO COURT SO. I
BELIEVE THIS SHOULD BE AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER VOEPEL. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SEEN NONE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS FORTY
THREE KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WILL RETURN TO
FILE ORDER PICKING UP AT FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE SIXTEEN SENATE
BILL FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
HUESO AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT SB FIVE
SEVEN SEVEN ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR HUESO IN A SENSE SB
FIVE SEVEN SEVERAL CARS FOR
LEGALIZATION STAFF. TO PROVIDE
CD TIA A WITH INFORMATION AND
MATERIALS THAT ARE NECESSARY
FOR THE CD TO HAVE A TO PROVIDE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND PERSONAL
SERVICES. TO THE BOARD AT AS
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES. SB FIVE
SEVEN SEVEN HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AYE
ASPIRIN AYE. HE WAS VERY. NEEDS
WITHOUT SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION
WILL HAVE A COOK OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE ITALIAN VOTES I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES. MOVED DOWN MEMBERS TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SEVENTEEN
SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
FIVE TWENTY THREE BY CENTER
MCGUIRE AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO ELECTIONS. MS GONZALEZ LET'S
LET IT A YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT FIVE TWENTY SB FIVE
TWENTY THREE ON BEHALF OF
CENTER MCGUIRE IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE OVER HALF OF VOTERS VOTE
BY MAIL OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND
BALLOTS WERE REJECTED IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY SIXTEEN BECAUSE
OF A MISSING SIGNATURE MANY OF
THESE VOTERS HAD NO IDEA THERE
BUT WAS NOT COUNTED BECAUSE
ONLY SOME COUNTIES SENT NOTICES
WHEN ABOUT IT'S MISSING A
SIGNATURE. THIS BILL WHAT'S THE
PROBLEM BY RIPARIAN OPTIONS
OFFICIALS TO NOTICE VOTERS OF A
MISSING SIGNATURE AT LEAST
EIGHT PRIOR TO CERTIFICATION OF
ELECTION IN PROVIDE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VERIFY THEIR
SIGNATURE UP UNTIL TWO DAYS
PRIOR TO SERVICE VACATION OF
THE ELECTION THIS PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL TIME FOR VOTERS TO
CORRECT THEIR MISSING
SIGNATURES AND PROVIDES MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO COUNTIES TO
NOTIFY VOTERS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MS GONZALEZ. SCENE DIGITAL
DISCUSSION THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLY THE
VOTES HIGHS FIFTY FIVE KNOWS
FIFTEEN MEASURE PASSES. THE
BILL WILL PASS RETAINER FILE
ITEMS ONE EIGHTEEN AND ONE
NINETEEN THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE TWENTY SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY SIX BY SENATOR ALLEN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID. MR MEDINA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB TWO
NINETY SIX ENABLE STUDENTS
RESIDING IN CALIFORNIA WITH
APPLIED FOR ASYLUM TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR STATE FUNDED
FINANCIAL AID THROUGH THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM WHETHER ASYLUM
CASE IS PENDING. AMENDMENTS
TAKEN ARE NON SUBSTANTIVE
ADDING CHAPTER IN OUR LANGUAGE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA
SEEN NO DISH ON DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
LOCAL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES I FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
FIVE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ONE TWENTY ONE AND ONE
TWENTY TWO. THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE TWENTY
THREE SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY FIVE BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE WILD GAME
MAMMALS. GO FOR THIS
AGUIAR-CURRY. KNIVES AND FORKS
EVERYONE I RISE TO IT TO
PRESENT SB THREE NINETY FIVE
THE WHILE LIFE TRAFFIC SAFETY
ACT BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION THIS
BILL ALLOWS THE FISHING GAME
COMMISSION TO CREATE AN ONLINE
PORTAL THAT WOULD ALLOW USERS
TO LOG INFORMATION IN REGARDS
TO LARGE GAME ANIMAL COLLISIONS
AND AT THE SAME TIME DELIVER
PERMIT FOR THE TAKE OF THESE
LARGE GAME ANIMALS. ACCORDING
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT THOUSAND
LARGE GAME ANIMAL COLLISIONS I
RESULTED IN OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED INJURIES AT LEAST
TWENTY FOUR FATALITIES BY
MIRRORING LEGISLATION IN MANY
OTHER STATES SB THREE NINETY
FIVE WILL COLLECT THE DATA
NEEDED TO CREATE SAFER QUARTERS
FOR BOTH MOTORISTS AND WILDLIFE
ALIKE THIS BILL I KNOW IT'S
SURPRISING HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
OUT CURRY MR GALLAGHER IF YOU
MUST. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE NINETY FIVE I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF JOKES
MADE ABOUT THIS BILL. BUT
REALLY WHAT THIS BILL DEALS
WITH IS NO LAUGHING MATTER ALL
THE MEMBERS IN THIS ROOM HAVE
CONSTITUENTS WHO MAY HAVE
SUFFERED FROM DISASTROUS
CONSEQUENCES FROM LARGE ANIMAL
COLLISIONS THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILLS TO HARDEN OUR ROADWAYS
FOR SAFETY AND IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ANIMAL OVER
PASSES OR OR CROSS SCENES. SB
THREE NINETY FIVE INCENTIVIZE
THE REPORTING OF THESE ACCIDENT
LOCATIONS. OTHER REPORTING
ASPECT IS THE MISSING LINK IN
MAKING OUR ROADS SAFER FOR BOTH
HUMANS AND WILDLIFE ALIKE AND
ALSO WHEN WE HAVE ANIMALS THAT
ARE KILLED ALONG. OUR ROADWAYS
IS MUCH BETTER TO HAVE THAT
UTILIZE THAN TO BE THAN TO BE
COMPLETELY WASTED AND SO THIS
IS. I THINK A MUCH MORE
SUSTAINABLE WAY OF DEALING WITH
WHAT WE ALL KNOW IS A REALITY
ALONG AYE ROADWAYS AND FOR
THESE. REASONS I RESPECTFULLY.
EVEN THOUGH YOU MAY LAUGH. IS
VOTE I AND PRESS THE GREEN
BUTTON THANK YOU. MISTER MISTER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
AS A CO AUTHOR OF SB THREE
NINETY FIVE AS SEVERAL OTHER
REASONS ALREADY STATED ABOVE
THIS BILL IS TO HELP OUT WITH
THE ROADWAYS AND REALLY LOOKING
AT THE NUMBER OF HUMAN AND
ANIMAL MORTALITY RATES AND JUST
FOR THE RECORD BOOKS IT GETS
THE DESIGNATION THREE NINETY
FIVE FROM HIGHWAY THREE NINETY
FIVE THAT GOES THROUGH MY
DISTRICT. SO MEMBERS ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THAN. THANK YOU
SIR. OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RESIDENT I RECOGNITION WILL
MOVE TO VOTE CRITICAL FOR THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLIED THE VOTES AYE AYES
FIFTY FOUR IT KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL PASS
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE
TWENTY FOUR. TWO ONE. THIRTY
TWO. WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEMS ONE THIRTY THREE AND
ONE THIRTY FOUR. MEMBERS THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE THIRTY FIVE SENATE BILL ONE
SEVENTY TWO THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE FIREARMS. MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. MR
WHAT YOU HOLD ON FOR JUST ONE
MOMENT MISTER GABRIEL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
THERE WE GO I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB ONE SEVEN TWO ON
BEHALF OF CENTER PORTANTINO
THIS BILL ENSURES THE FIREARMS
ARE SAFELY STORED IN ITS
COURAGE'S SAFE GUN OWNERSHIP.
FOR STORAGE OF FIREARMS IS A
THREAT TO LIFE AND SAFETY. THE
VAST MAJORITY OF AXONAL FIREARM
DEATHS SUICIDES AND SENSELESS
ACTS OF GUN VIOLENCE AMONG
CHILDREN ARE RELATED TO EASY
ACCESS TO FIREARMS. SB ONE
SEVEN TWO RESPONSE TO THESE
TRENDS BY MAKING THE CURRENT
CRIME OF CRIMINAL STORAGE APPLE
TO THE STORAGE OF AN UNLOADED
AS WELL AS LOADED FIREARM. THIS
BILL WOULD PLACE ON THE TEN
YEAR PER PROHIBITED PERSONS
LAST THOSE WHO VIOLATE THESE
PROVISIONS. THIS BILL ALSO
INSURES RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY HAVE
STANDARDS FOR SAFE STORAGE. BY
APPLYING THESE CRIMES AND OTHER
SIMILAR VIOLATIONS TO THE TEN
YEAR GOT. POSSESSION PROBATION
LIST WE CAN INSURE THE GUNS ARE
RESPONSIBLY STORED BY FIREARM
OWNERS THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY
THE BRADY CAMPAIGN THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND OTHER GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION GROUPS.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. MR GABRIEL SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION
WILL MOVE TO A VOTE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
YEAH. YEAH. YEAH BERMAN. ALL
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS FORTY
FIVE KNOWS TWENTY MEASURE
PASSES. PASS A RETAINER FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE THIRTY SIX THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE THIRTY SEVEN SENATE BILL
TWO SIXTY TWO THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY TWO
BY SENATOR MIKE WEIR AND
ACTUALLY THE MARINE RESOURCES
MR STONE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS THE
ANNUAL FISHERIES OMNIBUS BILL
DEALING WITH SOME ISSUES AROUND
PERMITTING GEAR RETRIEVAL NONE
OF THESE PROVISIONS ARE
CONTROVERSIAL I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE THAT. THANK YOU MISTER
STONE FOR THE PRESENTATION AND
THE BREVITY. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION
WILL MOVE TO VOTE QUICKLY OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY THREE
KNOWS ZERO MEASURE PASSES. WHAT
NOW I FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
THIRTY EIGHT SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY SIX BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBER SENATE BILL TWO
SIX SIX PROTECTS THE PROMISE
AND PAID FOR. PAID FOR RETIREE
BENEFITS OF CALPERS MEMBERS BY
MAKING SURE THAT A RETIREES NOT
HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY
COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED
PENSIONABLE CUT ON COMPENSATION
THAT WAS REPORTED TO THE SYSTEM
THIS MEASURE RESPONSE TO CASES
IN WHICH PENSIONABLE
COMPENSATIONS OF RETIRED
EMPLOYEES IS RETROACTIVELY DEAN
DISALLOWED CALPERS. THIS BILL
COMPELS CALPERS AND EMPLOYERS
WHO WORKED OTHER TO PROTECT
TYREE BENEFITS AND PREVENT IT
INSTANCE FROM EVER HAPPENING
AGAIN IN THE FIRST PLACE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. DO YOU. WANT
TO. SEE NO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM
WILL MOVE TO A VOTE CLICK TO
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY
THE VOTES I'D IS SIXTY KNOWS IT
ONE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
WILL PASS RETAIN FILE ITEMS.
ONE THIRTY NINE TO ONE FORTY
ONE. MEMBERS THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE FORTY TWO
SENATE BILL SEVENTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR LEYVA
AND EXPLAIN TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR MR BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES SB
SEVENTY ONE WOULD PROHIBIT THE
EXPENDITURE OF CAMPAIGN AND
LEGAL DEFENSE FUNDS TO PAY OR
REIMBURSE. FOR POUNDS EACH MAN
OR SETTLEMENT RELATED TO SEXUAL
ASSAULT SEXUAL ABUSE OR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIM FILED AGAINST
A CANDIDATE OR ELECTED OFFICER
THE BILL ALLOWS CANDIDATES AND
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO USE
CAMPAIGN AND LEGAL DEFENSE
FUNDS TO DEFEND AGAINST CLAIMS
UNTIL THEY ARE FOUND LIABLE.
HOWEVER ONCE FOUND LIABLE FOR
SUCH VIOLATIONS THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
pFUNDS USED TO PAY FOR LEGAL
EXPENSES AND FEES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE CLIENT. SB SEVENTY ONE.
GRITTY BUT HOPE A LOOPHOLE THAT
ALL CORRECT IS TO DEPEND ON
DONATED. THE DEFENDER UNLAWFUL
ACTIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
BERMAN. SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM
WILL MOVE TO A VOTE. CLICK OPEN
AT ALL. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE MEMBER
THIS IS A TWO THIRDS VOTE
REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR VOTES. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLIED THE VOTES HI SIXTY ONE
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM ONE
OF FORTY THREE SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY SIX BY
SENATOR ALSO AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT. WELCOME
IS CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
GOT IT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE 2% SB TWO
EIGHTY SIX WHICH ADDRESSES AN
ISSUE THAT HAS ARISEN REGARDING
THE INTERPRETATION OF LABOR
CODE SECTION TWO OH ONE THAT
THIS CHARGE STATUTE AND IS IN
WHAT CIRCUMCISED WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES SHOULD A POT PIE
IN THE CONTEXT OF WORKERS AND
BASEBALL PARKS IN THE STATE THE
AUTHOR AND I HAVE DILIGENTLY
WITH CALIFORNIA YOUR FEDERATION
AND AT THE I. YOU. THIRTEEN
HERE. HELLO EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION CONSUMER ATTORNEY
SOME CALIFORNIA. AND OTHERS TO
ENSURE THAT THIS NEW PROVISION
OF THE LABOR CODE MAINTAINS THE
STATUS QUO WHICH MEANS THAT
WORKERS WILL CONTINUE TO BE
PAID ON THE REGULAR PAY DAY
THIS MEASURE ROSE HEARD IN THE
ASSEMBLY LABOR AN EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE WHERE IT
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY I'D ALSO
LIKE TO TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONGRATULATE MY CHIEF OF STAFF.
MOTHER WHO WAS AND BE P. WE
JUST THAT NOMINATED AS AN BE P.
EMPLOYEE OF THE YEAR AT DODGER
STADIUM AND AT THE END OF THE
DAY THIS BILL IS ABOUT ALL THE
WORKERS AT THE STADIUM'S ACROSS
A CALIFORNIA. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST I VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER. SEVEN I'M SHOCKED IS
NOT MORE MEMBERS WERE SPEAKER
SPORTS ITEM I REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH ALL THE RIGHT
N. CLICK TO OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES AYE AYES SIXTY KNOWS
IS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS. MISTER CALDERON. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO SB
SIXTY A GALGIANI TO THE IMAC TO
FOLLOW. CARPOOL NOW SYNONYMS
CONSENT TO WITHDRAW AB TWO
SEVENTY ONE COOPER FROM
ENGROSSING AND ROLLING AND
RETURN THE BILL TO THE SENATE
FOR FURTHER ACTION. WITHOUT
QUESTION I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND GENERAL
SIXTY TWO A THE FALL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO MEET
TOMORROW THURSDAY SEPTEMBER
TWELFTH. BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS TO MEETING HERE AB
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT LOW AN A. B.
FIFTEEN TWENTY TWO LOW AT NINE
THIRTY AM IN ROOM FORTY TWO A
TWO. ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING TO MEET AND HERE
AB SIX EIGHTY ONE GONZALEZ AT
TWELVE THIRTY PM IN ROOM FOUR
FORTY FOUR JUDICIARY TO ME IN
HERE AB SIX OH TWO BERMAN. AT
TWELVE NOON IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO ME IN
HERE AB FOR SEVENTEEN FIFTY
TWO. PETRIE-NORRIS AND BRO AT
ELEVEN AM IN ROOM FOUR FORTY
SEVEN AND WHAT SAFETY COMMITTEE
MEETING HERE AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
THREE CENT THIAGO. AT TEN AM IN
ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE REQUESTED GREAT.
MEMBERS WE ARE. MOVING BACK TO
THE CURRENT FILE. TO TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM FORTY NINE. THIS IS
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO. THE
CLERK WILL RAISE ASSEMBLY WILL
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHIU AND I
PLAN TO TENNESSEE. MISTER DAVID
CHIU YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE TENANT
PROTECTION. CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE ONE RENT INCREASE AWAY FROM
ADDICTIONS AND FROM
HOMELESSNESS. ON BEHALF OF OUR
JOINT AUTHORS I WANT TO THANK
THE ORIGINAL COALITION OF
TENANT PROGRESSIVE INEQUITY
ADVOCATES AND LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS WHO RECENTLY
JOINED AFTER SENATE AMENDMENTS
BY STAKEHOLDERS FROM OUR
BUSINESS VETERANS AND RENTAL
HOUSING COMMUNITY. I ALSO WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK AND
ACKNOWLEDGE LEADERSHIP OF HONOR.
ARE SENATE PRO TOWN AND OF
COURSE OUR SPEAKER. THIS BILL
WILL PREVENT EGREGIOUS RENT
GOUGING AND PREDATORY EVICTIONS
WHILE STRIKING A BALANCE TO
ALLOW LANDLORDS TO MAKE A FAIR
RATE OF RETURN. THERE TO
CRITICAL PROTECTIONS FOR
TENANTS THAT ARE STYLISH UNDER
THIS BILL FIRST A RENT CAP FOR
ANNUAL RENT INCREASES. AT THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX PLUS FIVE
PERCENT. AND SECONDLY JUST
BECAUSE PRODUCTIONS THAT
REQUIRE LANDLORDS DECIDE A
REASON BEFORE VICTIMS SOMEONE.
I'M GONNA TAKE A MOMENT TO
BRIEFLY ANSWER A FEW QUESTIONS
THAT ARE TYPICALLY ASKED ABOUT
THIS BILL FIRST WILL IT IMPACT
HOUSING PRODUCTION. ARBIL
EXPLICITLY EXEMPTS NEW
CONSTRUCTION FOR FIFTEEN YEARS.
WE APPRECIATE THAT CIA BELIEVES
THAT THIS WILL NOT IMPEDE
CONSTRUCTION. IS CP I WAS FIVE
THE APPROPRIATE CAP. THE RENTAL
HOUSING INDUSTRY IS REPRESENTED
BY CAA DOES NOT OPPOSE THIS
BILL KNOWING THAT LANDLORDS CAN
MAKE A FAIR RATE OF RETURN ON A
CAP THAT'S MORE THAN DOUBLE OR
STATES YEARLY MEDIAN RENT
INCREASE. WILL IT IMPACT THE
REALTOR INDUSTRY. OUR BILL NO
LONGER APPLIES TO THE VAST
MAJORITY OF SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
AND OWNER OCCUPIED DUPLEXES THE
BREAD AND BUTTER OF THE REAL
ESTATE INDUSTRY. AND SHOULD WE
BE IN PRODUCING HOUSING. WHAT
ALL OF US WHO MAKE UP THE
SEVERAL DOZEN AUTHORS ON THIS
BILL ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT WE
NEED TO PRODUCE MORE HOUSING
BUT UNTIL WE BUILD THE THREE
AND A HALF MILLION UNITS THAT
WILL STABILIZE OUR STATE'S
HOUSING PRICES WE NEED TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS STAY IN THERE LONG
TIME HOMES. IN A BEST CASE
SCENARIO IT WILL TAKE WELL OVER
A DECADE TO BUILD THAT HOUSING
WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE A TEN YEAR
SUNSET DATE. AS MILLIONS OF.
STRUGGLING IN THE WORST HOUSING
CRISIS IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
WE NEED TO STAND UP AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MISTER
BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SO
I'M JUST TOOK. AN HOUR OR SO
AGO ON THIS FLOOR. WE VOTED AND
I THINK IT TOUGH PULLED DOES
SOMEWHERE NORTH OF FIFTY VOTES.
TO ALLOW FOR SAFE PARKING ZONES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S WHERE WE ARE
IN CALIFORNIA ON HOUSING WE ARE
FINDING WAYS TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
LIVE IN THEIR CARS. IF THAT
DOESN'T UNDERSCORE WHERE WE ARE
WITH THIS HOUSING CRISIS AND
THE NEED TO PROTECT TENANTS AND
BUILD MORE HOUSING. SO THAT THE
CAPACITY IS THERE THAT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT DOES. FOLKS YOU'RE
BEING ASKED TO PAY. 506070% OF
THEIR NET SPENDABLE INCOME ON
RENT. BECAUSE LANDLORDS ARE
RAISING THE RANTS AND THAT'S
WHAT TENANTS ARE FACED WITH
WHAT'S SOMEONE TO DO IN THAT
SITUATION. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL IT'S A BILL THAT'S BEEN
NEGOTIATED. WE HAVE NOT PASSED
SIGNIFICANT TENANT PROTECTION
MEASURES UNTIL THIS SESSION AND
THE TIME IS NOW FOR US TO DO
SOMETHING FOR TENANTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH SOME MODICUM OF
PROTECTION. BECAUSE THE HOUSING
THAT WE ALL KNOW WE NEED TO
PROVIDE FOR THEM IS GOING TO
TAKE TIME TO BUILD DOWN IN IN
THAT THIS GAG REGION AND SO THE
CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS THEY'VE JUST BEEN
TOLD BY EIGHT CD THAT THEY NEED
TO BUILD ONE POINT THREE
MILLION. HOUSING UNITS. OVER AN
EIGHT YEAR PERIOD OF TIME
THAT'S A TALL ORDER CALIFORNIA
FORWARD SAYS THAT TO BUILD THAT
KIND OF HOUSING IT'S
UNREALISTIC TO EXPECT THAT WE
CAN DO IT WITHIN THE NEXT TEN
YEARS OR SO AND WE OUGHT TO BE
THINKING EVEN LONGER TERM. SO
THE- IF WE DON'T DO SOMETHING
TO MODERATE THE INCREASES AND
RENT WE'RE GOING TO BE
CONTINUALLY FACED WITH MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE ON OUR STREETS IT'S
THAT SIMPLE AND IT'S NOT JUST
HOMELESS THAT WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT. IT'S OUR
FAMILIES IT'S ARE FOR AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS. DOES
NOT NO MAN IS NOT JUST. BUT
MANY PEOPLE PROBABLY MOST OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WE KNOW WHO ARE
AFFECTED BY THE RISING COST OF
HOUSING WHETHER IT'S YOUR
CHILDREN OR YOUR PARENTS OR
YOUR FRIENDS YOU KNOW WHO THESE
PEOPLE ARE AND WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING TO I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE UGH THE MEMBER
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND FOR THE
CORD WHO HAVE LABORED MANY MANY
HOURS TO CRAFT A COMPROMISE ON
THIS BILL. OF THE TIME IS COME
TO DO SOMETHING TO TECH TENANTS
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. MR YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
NUMBERS I RISE TODAY AS A JOINT
AUTHOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO. THE
HOUSING CRISIS IS NOT SIMPLY AN
ACADEMIC ISSUE THEY CAN BE
REDUCED TO FACTS FIGURES AND
SPREADSHEETS. IT IS A HUMAN
ISSUE. IT IS PRESENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WHEN WE PASSED BY
PARKING LOTS WERE FAMILY SLEEP
WITH THEIR CHILDREN IN CARS. IT
CONFRONTS US WHEN WE LEAVE THE
CAPITAL IN THE EVENING AND SEE
PEOPLE SETTING UP CAMP IN THE
PARK NOT ONE HUNDRED YARDS FROM
WHERE WE NOW STAND. ADDRESSING
THE ISSUES THAT TENANTS FACE
ACROSS OUR STATE TO ME AT LEAST
IS A MORAL IMPERATIVE. AB
FOURTEEN TWO IS AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF A COMPREHENSIVE
RESPONSE TO OUR STATES. CRISIS
OF HOUSING PORTABILITY AND
HOMELESSNESS PROTECTING
VULNERABLE TENANTS FROM
DISPLACEMENT BY OUTRAGEOUS RATE
HIKES AND AN EPIC EVICTIONS.
EVERY LANDLORD AND PROPERTY
OWNER SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY
TO MANAGE RENTAL PROPERTIES WAY
THAT THEY'D NESS. THIS MEANS
THAT RENTERS TO BREAK THE ALL
WERE SEIZE PAYING RENT CAN BE
OF. OWNERS OF THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS OR OWNERS OR THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS CAN MOVE INTO
THEIR PROPERTIES AND UNITS CAN
BE TAKEN OFF THE MARKET IF IT
MAKES ECONOMIC SENSE. ALL OF
THESE THINGS REMAIN UNTOUCHED
AND UNAFFECTED BY EIGHT AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO DEVELOPERS
THEY NEED LONG TERM CERTAINTY
AND THE ABILITY TO ATTRACT
CAPITAL IF THEY'RE GOING TO
BUILD A MASSIVE AMOUNT OF
HOUSE. WE NEED TO MEET OUR
PRODUCT GOALS. FOURTEEN TO NOW
FIFTEEN YOUR NEW CONSTRUCTION
EXEMPTS. SURE THAT WE DON'T
HINDER NEW DEVELOPMENT. BUT
JUST AS LANDLORDS AND
DEVELOPERS NEED CERTAINTY AND
STABILITY IN ORDER TO DO
BUSINESS. FAMILIES NEED AND
DESERVE THE SAME CERTAINTY IN
ORDER TO THRIVE. THEY DESERVE
THE TO HAVE THE STABILITY IN
THE PLACE THAT THEY CALL HOME
THE PLACE THAT THEY PUT THEIR
KIDS TO BETTER. IT IS SIR HOW
MUCH RENT CAN IT WITHIN A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF A- OF TIME.
THEY DESERVE TO KNOW THAT THEY
WILL BE THAT THEY WILL NOT BE A
VERY BECAUSE OF WHO THEY ARE
WHO THEY LOVE OR THE GOD THAT
THEY PRAY TO. WE HAVE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH MEMBERS OF THE
RENTAL HOUSING INDUSTRY.
PRESENTED IS FROM TEN TO
ADVOCACY GROUPS TO STRIKE A
BALANCE BETWEEN THEIR
LEGITIMATE INTEREST. YOU ALL
KNOW THAT WE ARE IN THE MIDST
OF A HOUSING CRISIS DECADES IN
THE MAKING. THIS BODY IS POISED
TO AVOID MANY FOR THIS THIS
BODY IS POISED TO ADVANCE ITS
MEANING FOR MEANINGFUL
SOLUTIONS JUST HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. ENTERING COULD
INCREASE PRODUCTION TO THE HIGH
LEVELS THAT WE NEED TO REACH IN
ORDER TO MAKE PROGRESS ON OUR
BACKLOG. BUT PRODUCTION ALONE
IS NOT ENOUGH TO WRITE OUR
CONSTITUENTS WITH RELIEF FROM
THE UNCERTAINTY AND- **** BY
OUR LACK OF A MORE HOUSING. OF
CALIFORNIA. THE THEM IN THEIR
HOMES AND THEY NEED THEM NOW
THERE IS A WAY FOR LANDLORDS TO
DO BUSINESS FOR TENNIS TO HAVE
MEANINGFUL PROTECTIONS AT THE
SAME TIME BOTH SIDES OF THIS
ISSUE CAN COME TOGETHER TO FIND
A MIDDLE GROUND AND I BELIEVE
WE HAVE ACHIEVED THAT
COMPROMISE WITH THE BILL
COLLEAGUES I KNOW YOU CARE
ABOUT PROVIDING RELIEF TO THE
DEVELOP INTO STRUGGLE HOUSING
COSTS. I KNOW YOU HEAR ABOUT
PEOPLE POVERTY ALL STREET THEN
THE I ASK YOU TODAY THIS BILL
ON THE FLOOR TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL PROTECTION FOR ME OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES WHILE WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS TO ADDRESS OUR
PRODUCTION AND AFFORDABLE.
CRISIS. THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON.
MISS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I A STROKE STRONGLY
URGE A NO VOTE ON AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. WE ALL KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS AN UNACCEPTABLE
HOUSING AND AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL
WILL JUST POUR FUEL ON THE
FIRE. WE'RE ALREADY SEEING THE
IMPACTS OF THIS RENT CONTROL
SCHEME PREEMPTIVE RENT
INCREASES IMPOSSIBLE
RESTRICTIONS ON LEASES AND THE
SLOWDOWN IN THE CONSTRUCTION OF
BADLY NEEDED NEW HOMES. FOR
DECADES NOW CALIFORNIA'S IMPOSE
MORE MORE RESTRICTIONS AND
MANDATES ON BUILDERS AND
PROPERTY OWNERS WHY WOULD
ANYONE LOOK TO INVEST IN MULTI
FAMILY RENTAL HOUSING NOW IN
FACT A LOT OF THE RENTAL
HOUSING IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND MY DISTRICT IS. WAS BUILT
BACK THIRTY YEARS AGO OR FORTY
YEARS AGO THEY'VE BEEN
RENOVATED BUT THEY'RE STILL
RENTAL HOUSING AND ALL OF THOSE
WOULD BE AFFECTED BY THIS BILL.
AND FOR DECADES NOW THE PROBLEM
HAS GOTTEN WORSE. WHY ON EARTH
WOULD WE EXPECT THINGS TO BE
DIFFERENT THIS TIME AROUND.
EVERY TIME A BILL LIKE THIS
COMES UP YOU'RE WARNED OF THE
IMPACT IT WILL HAVE ON A RENTAL
MARKETS. AND EVERY TIME THOSE
WARNINGS FALL ON DEAF EARS AND
THIS WILL PROBABLY HAPPEN AGAIN
TODAY. SOME CALIFORNIA CITIES
ALREADY HAVE RENT CONTROL AND
MANY OF THOSE CITIES HAVE THE
ABSOLUTE WORST HOUSING
CONDITIONS IN THE STATE. THAT'S
NOT A COINCIDENCE DON'T CREATE
A SCENARIO WHERE RENTERS WILL
BE PAYING THE PRICE FOR IT FROM
THE BACKLASH AGAINST RENT
CONTROL. IF WE WANT TO SOLVE
THE HOUSING CRISIS WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THE ARE WE JUST NUMBER
OF REGULATIONS IMPOSE SOME
BUILDERS AND PROPERTY OWNERS.
ICE CONTROLS AND GOVERNMENT
CONTROLLED ECONOMY HAVE FAILED
TO DELIVER RESULTS TIME AND
TIME AGAIN. THIS BILL WILL TOO
I STRONGLY URGE IN THE VOTE.
THEY MISS WALDRON MEMBERS
PLEASE RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES
WE'D LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
DEBATE MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AS I UNDERSTAND
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL TO
PREVENT EXCESSIVE RENT
INCREASES THIS IS A HUGE
COMPLEX ISSUE. NOT EFFORT AND I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE NEED TO
WORK ON HOUSING SUPPLY WHICH IS
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS IN OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. AS I
STRUGGLE WITH THIS BILL I WOULD
LIKE TO ENCOURAGE THIS BODY TO
HAVE A SERIOUS CONVERSATION
NEXT YEAR REGARDING INCREASE IN
OUR HOUSING SUPPLY ACROSS THE
STATE THANK YOU. THEY MUST
RODRIGUEZ IS BOERNER HORVATH
YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
TODAY I RISE TO ENCOURAGE
SUPPORT FOR FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
AND YOU MIGHT BE SURPRISED
BECAUSE WHEN THIS BILL CAME TO
THE FLOOR LAST TIME I WAS A
STRONG EARLY NO VOTE. BUT THIS
IS NOT THE SAME BILL THAT BILL
WAS TOO EXTREME FOR ME WENT TOO
FAR AND SMACKED OF RENT CONTROL.
AND NOW WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS
BILL THIS BILL IS A SOLID
SOLUTION THAT WE NEED TIME ARE
THAT. A SOLID SOLUTION TO OUR
PROBLEMS NOW WE HAVE RUN OUT OF
TIME. WE'RE DONE. IN MY
DISTRICT I HAD A REPORT LAST
WEEK. OF THE FAMILY WERE BOTH
PARENTS WERE WORKING TWO JOBS.
AND THEY WERE IN THE HOMELESS
SHELTER. THIS IS A MY DISTRICT
GUYS. EVER THE MY DISTRICT IT'S
IN EVERYBODY'S DISTRICT. SO WE
DON'T HAVE TIME TO SOMEONE
INCREASE SUPPLY AND WHEN WE DO
INCREASE SUPPLY WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE IN PRESET THOUGHTFULLY.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND NOT BE
DOING STATE MANDATES SO THAT'S
EVEN HARDER. SO WHAT ARE WE
GONNA DO TO PROTECT OUR
NEIGHBORS ARE FAMILIES NOW. AND
THERE ARE THINGS I DON'T LIKE
IN THIS BILL BUT I'M VERY
THANKFUL TO THE AUTHORS AND
EVERYBODY IS WORK ON THIS BILL
BE FOR TAKING SO MANY OF MY
AMENDMENTS THAT I'VE ASKED FOR.
WHICH IS WHY I'M SUPPORTING
THIS TODAY. SO VERY HOPEFUL
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
AS MY COLLEAGUE JUST MENTIONED.
ON HOW TO INCREASE THAT HOUSING
SUPPLY THAT'S COMPATIBLE WITH
NEIGHBORHOODS. AS WELL SO THAT
WHEN THIS BILL DOES SUNSET.
IT'S DONE AND WE DON'T HAVE A
NEED FOR IT. I'D URGE YOUR AYE
THAT TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
IS BOERNER HORVATH. THIS BILL
AND AS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. A
LOT OF ORDER BUT OKAY. THANK
YOU MISTER. SPEAKER THIS BILL
IS AN END RUN BY THE AUTHOR
BECAUSE THE PROPOSITION FOR
RENT CONTROL FAILED. THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS THIS IS RENT
CONTROL YOU CAN CHANGE THE
WORDING ALL YOU WANT BUT THIS
IS RENT CONTROL AND IT IS
FASCINATING TO ME TO LISTEN TO
MEMBERS ON THIS WAR TALK ABOUT
HOW EXPENSIVE IT IS TO LIVING
CALIFORNIAN HOW THERE ARE
PEOPLE LIVING IN THEIR CARS AND
BUT YET THEY'RE WORKING TWO
JOBS AND WE HAVE BILLS TO A LOT
OF PEOPLE LIVE IN THEIR ARS IN
PARKING LOTS AND- AND ALLOW
CALTRANS TO MAKE UNDER PASSES
IN UPPER PASSES. HOMELESS
SHELTERS AND THEN YOU ACCESS IT
IN THE POLICY DID YOU PUT IN
PLACE ARE THE REASON WHY IT'S
SO EXPENSIVE YET YOU'RE ALL
ACTING SURPRISE LIKE GOSH I
DON'T KNOW WHY AND HOW THIS
HAPPENED HOW DO WE GET SOME
LIKE SO MANY HOMELESS PEOPLE
WHY CAN'T PEOPLE AFFORD TO LIVE
HERE. BECAUSE YOU'VE INCREASE
THE COST OF WATER THE COST OF
WHAT YOU'RE CITY BECAUSE THE
BASS. BECAUSE OF HOUSING COSTS
OF RENT. EVERYTHING. AND THEN
YOU HAVE THE AUDACITY TO ACTUAL
PRICE. THE PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD
TO LIVE HERE. AND NOW YOU'RE
GONNA CAM AND YOU'RE GOING TO
ACT LIKE THE SAVIORS THE VERY
PEOPLE WHO CREATED THE PROBLEM.
YOU'RE NOW GOING TO WALTZ IN
AND TRY TO CONVINCE EVERYBODY
THAT YOU ARE THE SAVIORS. OF
ALL THAT AILS MAN THAT'S RICH.
REALLY. THIS IS RENT CONTROL.
AND LET ME JUST REMIND YOU IF
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD OF THE BASIC
CONCEPT OF SUPPLY AND DEMAND
PLEASE GOOGLE IT. OKAY IT'LL
TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN IF YOU DECREASE THE
SUPPLY THE DEMAND IS GREATER
YOU HAVE LESS OF WHAT PEOPLE
WANT. AND IT'S A HIGHER COST.
THE NOTION THAT WE CAN'T
BECAUSE I HEARD A COUPLE PEOPLE
SAY THIS THAT WE CAN'T BUILD
OUR WAY OUT OF THIS YES WE CAN.
ONE THAT. WE CAN BUILD OUR WAY
OUT OF IT IF WE ALLOW POLICIES
TO GO IN PLACE. TO ALLOW THAT
TO HAPPEN. IT'S NOT A MATTER OF
CAN'T IT IS A MATTER OF WON'T.
WE NEED MORE HOUSING WE NEED
MORE SINGLE FAMILY HOMES WHO
NEED MORE APARTMENTS WE NEED
MORE EVERYTHING. SET THERE'S
ENOUGH TO ACCOMMODATE EVERYBODY
IN THIS STATE THAT NEED
SHELTER. AND I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT SHELTER IN THEIR CAR IN A
PARKING LOT IN LA. WHICH IS
SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS THAT
YOU'VE COME UP WITH. WE CAN
BUILD OUR WAY OUT OF THIS IF
YOU ALLOW IT. BUT WE HAVE
CERTAIN SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS
WHO DON'T WANT ALLOW IT AND YOU
ALL GO ALONG WITH IT SO NOW YOU
CAN GO AHEAD AND PRETEND. THAT
YOU ARE THAT THE KNIGHT IN
SHINING ARMOR WRITING IN ON
YOUR WORST TO SAVE EVERYONE
FROM THE HIGH RENTAL COST. BUT
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY GOING TO
HAPPEN I WOULD ORIGINAL ABOUT.
THIS MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER YOU
KNOW THIS IS A- BOIL IT ALL
DOWN IT'S A FAIR MEASURE AND
WHAT WE DO EVERY DAY WE MAKE
THAT ON THIS FLOOR. IS GONNA DO
MORE HARM. OR MORE NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE CONSTITUENTS
THAT'S WHAT EVERY VOTE THAT WE
PRESS HERE. REALLY IT IS IT'S A
FORMULA WE'RE THINKING. THE
RISK IN THE REWARD. AND THIS
REALLY IS AS A FAIR DEAL AND
IT'S ALREADY OUTLINED BY OUR
AUTHORED OTHERS SPEAKERS AT
ALL. I'LL I'LL GET INTO THAT IT
REALLY PER TAXED TENANTS WE'LL
TALK ABOUT GATHERING IN A
SECOND. IT STABILIZES THE
RENTAL HOUSING MARKET. AND IT'S
VERY REASONABLE FOR PROPERTY
OWNERS. IT'S NOT RENT CONTROL
IT'S NOT LOOK IN NEW YORK IN IN
DISTRICTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
WHERE THEY HAVE THE SMALL
INCREASES. THAT REALLY COULD
UPSET THE APPLE CART AS FAR AS
SUPPLY I'VE I'VE PROBABLY WILL
NOT SUPPORT THOSE MEASURES. BUT
HAVING A MEASURE WERE YOU CAN
GO UP 28% AN INCREASE. IS
TOTALLY REASONABLE AND THE
EXEMPTIONS FOR EXEMPTING NEW
HOUSING. FOR THE FIRST FIFTEEN
YEARS EXEMPTING DUPLEXES SINGLE
FAMILY HOUSING FRANKLY MOST OF
THAT. THE MAIN STREET TYPE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THE RENTAL
HOUSING INDUSTRY THE BIG
CORPORATIONS WHO WOULD HAVE THE
MIST AT STAKE. THEY'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. THERE ARE
OPPOSED SO THE MEASURES THAT WE
HAVE IN HERE AS FAR AS
IMPACTING. SMALL OWNERS ARE
FRANKLY VERY FAIR AND I WOULD
KNOW FIRST HAND. BECAUSE MY
FUND TO PAY FOR MY LITTLE GIRLS
COLLEGE FUND. IS ON THREE UNITS
I HAVE RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND IF YOU CAN'T MAKE A GOOD
RETURN ON YOUR INVESTMENT
HAVING IT UP TO AN 8% INCREASE
IN YOUR RENT. YOU ARE A POOR
PROPERTY OWNERS YOU CAN DO THE
REPAIRS BE FAIR TO YOUR
TENANTS. AND HAVE A GOOD
BUSINESS MODEL. EARLIER I
TALKED ABOUT. THE HARM IN THE
GOOD EVERY TIME WE PRESS THESE
BUTTONS. WE KNOW THAT RAN
GALGIANI. HAS ITS IMPACT WE'VE
HEARD STORY AFTER STORY OF
INDIVIDUALS HAVING A TWENTY
THIRTY FORTY SOMETIMES A 50%
INCREASE IN THE RENT. IT'S JUST
NOT FAIR AND IT'S MORE LIKELY
THEY'RE GONNA END UP HERE. ON
K. STREET MALL OR MAYBE THEY
WILL BE HOMELESS BUT THEY'LL
PUT THEY'LL GO DOWN TO THE
LOWER INCOME HOUSING THAT
PERSON WILL GET SQUEEZED DOWN
TO THE SINGLE ROOM OCCUPANCY
HOUSING AND THAT PERSONAL BE
LEFT OUT HERE SLEEPING ON K.
STREET MALL SO THERE IS A REAL
CORRELATION. AS WE KNOW
RESEARCH SHOWS EVERY 10%
INCREASE IN RENT IN A
METROPOLITAN AREA CORRELATES TO
A 9% INCREASE IN HOMELESSNESS
THE FAX JUST A SPEAK FOR OUR
SELF. HERE IN SACRAMENTO MY
HOME TOWN HERE RIGHT GREW UP
WHERE I WAS A YOUNG STAFF
MEMBER AND I CAN'T BELIEVE. I
THE SALARY VERY COMPARABLE TO
WHAT OUR LEGENDS ALLEGE
DIRECTORS HERE TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO WHEN I FIRST CAME OF
THIS PLACE AND MY LITTLE
APARTMENT HERE MY SHARE THE
RENTS. UNDER DOLLARS A MONTH.
THAT WAS MY SHARE OF THAT
LITTLE HOW. TWO DOLLARS A MONTH
NO WAY. WE ARE SQUEEZING YOUNG
PEOPLE OUT AND YOU CAN'T HAVE A
FAIR RENTAL HOUSING MARKET AND
MAKE SURE YOU DON'T UPSET THE
APPLE CART TOO MUCH IN
SACRAMENTO LAST SEVEN YEARS THE
AVERAGE RENT HERE IN THE
CENTRAL CITY. HAS INCREASED BY
45% 45% WE KNOW THAT SALARIES
HAVE NOT INCREASED BY THAT MUCH
ANNUAL WAGES FOR PEOPLE AND
STATE GOVERNMENT HAVE IT NOT
INCREASE THAT MUCH. AND THIS IS
A FAIR MEASURE THAT WILL
PROTECT THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
PROTECT. RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS
AND HELP TENANTS ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. AMOS
REGARDING MS QUIRK SILVA. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ON THIS FLOOR EVERY DAY
BUT TYPICALLY AT THIS TIME OF
OUR SESSION WE GRAPPLE WITH
DECISIONS THAT ACTUALLY CAN BE
VERY STRESSFUL WE CAN BE
CONFLICTED MEANING WE SEE BOTH
SIDES OF AN ARGUMENT WE CA AND
LISTEN TO THE OPPOSITION AND WE
LISTENED TO THOSE THAT SUPPORT
AND SOMETIMES IN MY CASE LIKE
AN ORANGE COUNTY THESE CHOICES
ARE EXTREMELY DIFFICULT. WE
HAVE NO LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES
THAT HAVE RENT CONTROL IN
ORANGE COUNTY SO THIS CERTAINLY
WOULD BE A CHANGE. FOR
LEGISLATOR TO SUPPORT SOMETHING
LIKE THIS BUT THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR I'VE NOT ONLY BEEN
LISTENING I'VE BEEN WATCHING
AND SEEN AND AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED NOT ONLY ON THIS
FLOOR IN THIS CITY BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE NOW SEEN
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
STRUGGLING WITH NOT ONLY
HOMELESSNESS BUT BEING VERY
CLOSE TO BEING HOMELESS. BY
BEING ON ABLE TO AFFORD THE
RENT IN FULLER TWO AND WE HAD
TO CITIES FULLER TEN AND
ANAHEIM WHERE THE COUNCILS
WERE. HAD MANY MANY
CONSTITUENTS COME BECAUSE A
LANDLORD RAISE THE RENT ABOUT
20% WITH THE NOTIFICATION IN
MOBILE HOMES NOW MOBILE HOMES
ARE EXEMPTED FROM THIS BUT THEY
CAME INTO THE COUNCIL WEEK
AFTER WEEK TO TRY TO GET RELIEF
MANY OF THESE CONSTITUENTS WERE
VETERANS SENIORS IN HAD MOVED
IN FEELING LIKE THEY WOULD HAVE
A SAFE PLACE TO LIVE. NOW THEIR
PLAN IS WHAT DO WE DO NOW. THEY
HAVE A LITTLE REPRIEVE BECAUSE
THE COUNCIL WORKED WITH THEM
BUT MANY DO NOT HAVE THIS SO WE
ARE NOT ONLY IN A HOMELESS
CRISIS WHAT WERE IN A HOUSING
CRISIS AND WE HAVE THE MORAL.
AUTHORITY TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT
AND DO IT DOING WHAT'S RIGHT IS
NOT EASY. I WON'T GO AS FAR AS
SAYING THERE'S THREATS BUT
THERE ARE THREATS. DOING WHAT
IS SAFE IS WHAT IS EASY. AND
DOING WHAT IS TOUGH. TAKES
COURAGE IN SOMETIMES COURAGE IS
HARD TO FIND. I KNOW I LIKE
BEING A LEGISLATOR. BUT I WANT
TO SEE PEOPLE HOUSE MORE THAN I
CARE ABOUT BEING A LEGISLATOR
WHEN I WALK OUTSIDE AND I KNOW.
BECAUSE I'VE COUNTED THERE ARE
PEOPLE LIVING ON THIS. THIS
GREAT PARK THAT ARE HOMELESS WE
KNOW THAT I SEE NO THE
SERGEANTS KNOW THAT I KNOW THE
POLICE KNOW THAT I SEE THEM IN
THE MORNING IN THE SAME PLACE.
FOLDING UP THEIR BLANKETS.
HEARING THERE TWO BACKPACKS
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
HOMELESS AND WE HAVE ACTED THIS
YEAR WE'VE ACTED ON ON
EVERYTHING FROM SAFE PARKING TO
AID YOU YOU EIGHTY USE THOSE
ARE TOOLS BUT IT WON'T BE ONE
ASPECT IT WON'T BE ONE BILL IT
WILL TAKE MULTIPLE. TYPES OF
LEGISLATION AND IT WILL TAKE
YOUR WILL. I TALKED TO MY GREAT
MENTOR WHO DOESN'T KNOW SHE'S
MY MENTOR BUT DOCTOR SHIRLEY
WEBER AS WE WALKED BY SOME
HOMELESS AS WE WERE COMING BACK
FROM THE CAPITAL AND I SAID.
WHAT CAN WE DO AND SHE SAID IT
ON THE FLOOR YESTERDAY SHE SAID
I TRAVELED TO AUSTRALIA AND I
ASKED THEM WHAT WHY DID THEY
NOT HAVE THE SAME SITUATION WE
HAVE AND THEY SAID BECAUSE THEY
MADE A DECISION. TO ACT AND
THEY HAVE THE WILL SO I ASK YOU
TO SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO FOR A SOLUTION IT MAY NOT
BE PERFECT AND I KNOW THE
AUTHOR HAS WORKED TIRELESSLY
BUT IT IS ONE OF THE SOLUTIONS
AND WE DON'T ACT WE STAY IN THE
SAME PLACE. AND WE NEED TO ACT
BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE'LL BE
HERE. A YEAR FROM NOW TALKING
ABOUT THE SAME ISSUES BUT WITH
MORE PEOPLE ON OUR STREETS SO I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS QUIRK SILVA MEMBERS TO BE
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
DEBATE PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES AT THIS TIME. MR
MURATSUCHI. THAT'S A TOUGH VOTE
FOR ME. IT SEEMS LIKE ALL OF MY
CONSTITUENTS. HAVE BECOME
REALTORS IN THE LAST COUPLE
DAYS. BUT I'M GONNA SUPPORT
THIS BILL. BECAUSE I FEEL THAT
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO. IN
ALL THE REALTORS. THAT HAVE
BEEN CALLING ME AND TWEETING ME
AND EMAILING ME THAT ALL BEEN
SAYING THE SAME THING THAT THE
SAME TALKING POINT. THAT. THE
SOLUTION IS TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING. BUT I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT BUILDING MORE HOUSING
IS GOING TO TAKE A LOT OF TIME.
AND IN THE MEANTIME. IN MY
COMMUNITY AND MY. EVEN IN MY
AFFLUENT PARTS OF MY DISTRICT
I'M HEARING. FOR MORE STORIES
OF PEOPLE THAT CAN'T KEEP UP
WITH THEIR RENTS. THAT THAT
THAT YOU KNOW EXPERIENCING RAN
GALLON XING. AND THEY'RE BEING
EVICTED. SO THAT THE LANDLORDS
CAN JACK UP THE RENTS. AND SO.
YOU KNOW I FEEL THAT TO. THAT
WE NEED TO SIDE WITH THE
RENTERS ON THIS ONE. BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO. THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI
MISTER MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I. RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS LEGISLATION AND WHICH I
DON'T OFTEN RISE TO OPPOSE
ESPECIALLY SINCE I HAVE A GREAT
AFFECTION FOR THE AUTHOR AND I
KNOW HOW MUCH WORK THAT HE HAS
DONE ON THIS BILL THE ISSUE FOR
ME. IS THE ISSUE OF BANKING.
AND I FEAR THAT WITH THIS BILL
BEFORE US TODAY THAT FOR SOME
PARTS OF THE STATE WILL PROVIDE
SOME RELIEF. FOR UPWARD
PRESSURE WITHIN THE RENTAL
MARKET BUT ALSO WILL DISTORT
THE MARKET. IN INLAND
CALIFORNIA IN IN MY DISTRICT
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
THERE IS NO PROVISION IN THIS A
BILL THAT SAYS THAT EVERY YEAR
THAT'S CALLED SEVEN AND A HALF
A PERCENT PER YEAR LANDLORDS
ARE GOING TO RAISE THEIR RIGHT
THERE THEIR RENT. EVERY SINGLE
YEAR SEVEN AND A HALF 8% WHEN
IN SOME PARTS OF MY DISTRICT
THEY'RE NOT RAISING THEIR RENT
AND THEY CAN'T BANK THAT. SO
EVERY SINGLE YEAR THEY'RE GONNA
RAISE SEVEN A HALF A PERCENT
MAYBE IF THEY HAD DONE IT FOR
THREE YEARS NOW THEY'RE GOING
TO DO THAT I WAS. AT AN EVENT
THIS WEEKEND AND I HAD SEVERAL
PEOPLE TELL ME THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO BE DOING THAT IN FACT
THE ONE LANDLORDS SAID. SENT.
SO UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL I
THINK HAS SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR SOME PARTS OF
THE STATE IT WILL PROVIDE
RELIEF BUT FOR OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE IT WILL ACTUALLY
DISTORT THE MARKET AND THEY
WILL END UP BEING UPWARD
PRESSURE AND ACTUALLY INCREASE
THE COST OF HOUSING. SO
REGRETFULLY MEL B. OPPOSING
TODAY. FAMOUS REYES MEASURE
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I AM OF PLEASED TO
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MAJOR. AND I FIND IT
INTERESTING BILL A CHANNEL SO
MUCH OF MY LIFE IT SEEMS THIS
TOPIC. DRAWS TOGETHER A GREAT
DEAL FOR ME. I WAS ADMITTED THE
PRACTICE OF LAW IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. MY FIRST CLIENT
WAS IN WHAT'S REFERRED TO AS
THE SHELTER INDUSTRY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I WORKED IN
THAT INDUSTRY. UNTIL THIS HOUSE
RECRUITED ME TO COME BACK IN A
RUN THE BANKING FINANCE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE IN THE LATE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES. SO I LOOK AT
IT SORT OF THROUGH THE LENS OF
MY LAW CAREER WORK IN THE
SHELTER INDUSTRY. ON THE SUPPLY
SIDE ON THE FINANCE SIDE FOR
THIS HOUSE. I REMEMBER ONE OF
THE FIRST THINGS I LOOKED AT
WAS THE NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
WAS THE SIGNING OF THE DAVIS
STIRLING COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT ACT. WHICH IS
IMPLICATED IN THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT'S COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS CONDOS SO CALLED
ARE REMOVED FROM THE SCOPE OF
THIS BILL. I DO THINK THAT
THERE IS ISSUES IN HERE FOR US
ON A GOAL FOR BASED SYSTEMS
LAWMAKERS WE ARE GOING TO WANT
TO PAY ATTENTION TO. BUT I
DON'T THINK THERE FATAL TO THE
APPROVAL THIS BILL TODAY. I
THINK AS A GENERAL MATTER WE'RE
GOING TO WANT TO WATCH. IT
PEOPLE BRING FORWARD THE
ARGUMENT. THAT WE MIGHT IT JUST
THE RULES TO PROMOTE AND
SUPPORT MAINTENANCE. OF LONG
ESTABLISHED FACILITIES WHETHER
CONDOS ARE SINGLE FAMILY OR
DUPLEXES OR CRY TAXES OR- FOUR
PLEXUS. I DON'T DOUBT BE A
RIGHTEOUS THING TO LOOK AT THIS
DOES HAVE A TEN YEAR SUNSET. I
THINK THEY'LL BE OPPORTUNITY TO
KIND OF SUPPORT. THE
PRESERVATION OF OUR HOUSING
STOCK GOING FORWARD. BUT I
DON'T I SEE THAT AS A VERY
SUBORDINATE ISSUE. TO THIS I
THINK THE USE OF A- CPI. TO
HELP ESCALATE. THE CAP. OR TO
ENLARGE THE CAP IS ACTUALLY
GOOD I TEND NOT TO LIKE CPI'S.
OFTEN VOTE AGAINST A BUT IN
THIS CONTEXT I SEE IT ALL TO
THE GOOD. AND. SO I LOOK AT IT
IS IT IT. THE WAY IT ADDRESSES
THE HOUSING MARKET THE WAY IT
PROVIDES A. LARGE CEILING ON
RATE INCREASES THE FACT THAT
THERE IS THAT SUNSET. I THINK
THESE ARE PROVISIONS WHICH GIVE
A LOT OF ROOM FOR DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS TO LET. FOLKS WHO
HAVE PROPERTIES OPERATE WITHIN
THIS FRAMEWORK AND. SO THAT IT
COMES DOWN TO JUST THE DECISION
AS WE AS MEMBERS ON THE FOR TO
DECIDE WHERE WE ARE. AND. I
CAN'T HELP MYSELF I GOT A QUOTE
OF THE FAMOUS OLD TESTAMENT
PROPHET ISAIAH. BUT I'LL TELL
YOU TWO THINGS ABOUT THAT. THE
VERSE I'M GONNA SHARE ACTUALLY
INCLUDES THE WORD SHELTER. AS
IT HAD SOMETHING TO SAY ABOUT
SHELTER AND WE'RE DIVERSE IN
QUESTION IS TO ME. THE BEST
IMAGE. OF LEADERSHIP FOR OTHERS
DELIVER FINE. AND I WILL TELL
YOU IS KIND OF UNUSUAL BECAUSE
IT'S A PICTURE FRANKLY OF A
ROCK. ON A LANDSCAPE. AND
APPARENTLY INANIMATE OBJECTS.
IS THE IMAGE THAT ISAIAH PULLS
UP. HE SAYS A KING SHALL RULE
WITH RIGHTEOUSNESS OKAY AS A IS
TALKING ABOUT A GOVERNMENT
WE'RE GOOD WORK IS BEING DONE.
IT'S PROSTHETIC WHEN HE USES IT
BUT WE GET A FIRM HE'S TALK
ABOUT A- PLACE WHERE THERE'S A
GOOD GOVERNMENT. AND HE SAYS
EACH ONE EACH PERSON. WE'LL BE
LIKE A SHELTER FROM THE STORM.
SO WE'RE GOVERNOR'S TO HIS WORK
THERE IS A RESULT PEOPLE ARE
FINDING SHELTER FROM THE STORM
A WHAT IS A CHARACTER THE
SHELTER HE TALKS ABOUT. LIKE
STREAMS OF WATER IN THE DESERT
AND THE SHADOW. OF A GREAT ROCK.
IN A WEARY LAND A THIRSTY LAND.
THIS IMAGES ONE. THAT WHEN
PEOPLE AROUND IN THE JUDEAN
DESERT AND IT'S THE SUMMER.
IT'S A SCORCHING PLACE.
SCORCHING PLACE AND HOSPITABLE
TO LIFE. AND AS A SAYS.
LEADERSHIP IS LIKE A ROCK IN
THE DESERT IT OPPOSES ITSELF.
BETWEEN THE FORCES OF ESCORTS
SOMEBODY. SO I TO CREATE
SHELTER THIRTY SECONDS COOLEY
AND INCIDENTALLY IT MEANS THE
PERSON WHO FUNCTIONS LIKE THAT
ROCK MAY TAKE SOME OF THAT HEAT
THEMSELVES. TRY TO GET A BILL
LIKE THIS IS INDISPUTABLY A
BILL RELEASE TO SHELTER.
PROVIDING SHELTER PROVIDED
SHELTER FROM WHAT WE ALL KNOW
IS A SCORCHING HEAT IN OUR DAY.
AND A CALLS US ALL TO SAY ARE
WE WILLING TO TAKE SOME OF THAT
HE TO GIVE OTHERS SHELTER.
URGENT ABLE THING WAS COOLEY
MEMBERS OF YOUR SEEKING
RECOGNITION PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES NOW. MISTER MATHIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR. WITHOUT OBJECTION YES
WHAT WAS THE POINT OF RAISING
THE MINIMUM WAGE. THE POINT OF
RAISE THE MINIMUM WAGE IS TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE IN OUR
STATE AND OUR COUNTRY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SURVIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. ALL RIGHT THERE
THANK YOU. SO MEMBERS WE'VE
INCREASED MINIMUM WAGE BUT YET
PEOPLE STILL CAN'T AFFORD TO
LIVE WE'VE DONE THINGS TO MESS
WITH OUR LECTURE CITY OUR WATER
IS STATED EARLIER. BUT YET WE
KEEP TOYNE WITH. PEOPLE'S
BUDGETS. PUTTING A CAP ON THE
RAIN. IS IT GOING TO FIX IT. WE
KNOW THIS THERE SO MANY
ECONOMICAL FACTORS AT STAKE
HERE. BUT YET WE OVER REGULATE
EVERY OPPORTUNITY. ACTUALLY XIN
SAY WE SOME OF YOU DECIDE OVER
REGULATE AT EVERY OPPORTUNITY.
BUT WE'VE DONE THIS WE HAVE 24%
OF OUR POPULATION LIVING IN
POVERTY IN ANOTHER 25% THAT ARE
ONE PAYCHECK AWAY. THAT HAVE TO
SIT DOWN EVERY MONTH AND MAKE
THOSE HARD DECISIONS. BETWEEN.
PAYING THE RENT OR THEIR
MORTGAGE. IN THEIR LECTURE BILL
THEIR WATER BILL. IN FOOD ON
THE TABLE FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
OR. OR GOT SOCCER SEASON COMING
UP SO CAN THEIR KIDS EVEN PLAY.
CAN THEY BUY THAT NEW SET OF
CLEATS BECAUSE THEY'VE OUTGROWN
THE ONES FROM LAST YEAR. OUR
FAMILIES. EVERY MONTH FOR
MAKING THESE CHOICES. IN THE
FACT THAT WE SEE HERE AND WE
THINK LET'S JUST PUT A CAP ON
IT LET'S JUST PUT MORE
GOVERNMENT CONTROL OVER WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN THIS IS GONNA
SOLVE THE PROBLEM THE TRUE
PROBLEM WE'VE WE'VE ALREADY
SAID IT IT'S THE HOUSING CRISIS.
YOU KNOW A FEW YEARS AGO I TOOK
THIS AMAZING TRIP. WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE AND WE
WERE IN CHINA. IN THE BILL TWO
HUNDRED CITIES IS SIZE A
CHICAGO IN A MENTALLY YEARS.
BECAUSE THE DON'T OVER REGULATE
LIKE WE DO. GRANTED THEY DON'T
HAVE THE SAME ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS WE DO. BUT. WE ARE
ABLE TO GET THINGS DONE. WE
HAVE OTHER MEASURES THAT WE CAN
DO. BUT YET WE'VE CHOSEN NOT TO
DO THOSE BECAUSE WE THINK THERE
YOU ALL THINK FOR SOME REASON
HAVING GOVERNMENT JUST GRAB A
HOLD OF EVERYTHING THEY CAN. IS
GOING TO BE THE ANSWER. MEMBERS
THIS ISN'T THE ANSWER THIS
ISN'T THE WAY TO GO LET'S
REALLY STOP AND THINK ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO THESE FANS
LEAST MY COLLEAGUE FROM YUCCA
VALLEY IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THIS IS GOING TO HAVE THE
ADVERSE AFFECT WE'RE GONNA SEE
RENTS SKYROCKET AND YOU'RE ALL
GONNA BE SCRATCHING THEIR HEADS
RUNNER WHAT THE HELL WENT
WRONG. VOTE NO. MISTER GIBSON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I HAVE CERTAINLY
ENJOYED THIS DEBATE THUS FAR IT
WAS NOT PLANNING ON SPEAKING
BUT I FEEL IS NECESSARY FOR ME
TO RISE AND SPEAK CERTAINLY
I'VE ENJOYED MOST OF WHAT HAS
BEEN SAID ON THIS FLOOR A LOT
OF IT IS VERY HYPOCRITICAL OF
MY COLLEAGUES DOCTOR MARTIN
KING SAID THIS. THE TIME IS
ALWAYS RIGHT TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT.
THE TIME IS NOW. BE CLEAR THE
TIME IS RIGHT NOW. PEOPLE HAVE
KICK THIS CAN DOWN THE STREET
AND DONE NOTHING WITH THE
POSITION. IN THIS HOUSE AND THE
OTHER HOUSE. THE MEMBER FROM
SAN FRANCISCO. A VISIONARY
BECAUSE HE'S TIRED OF SEEING
WHAT I SEE. HOMELESS PEOPLE.
WHO DON'T WANT TO BE HOMELESS.
I'M POSSIBLY THE ONLY MEMBER
OUT OF EIGHTY MEMBERS ON THIS
FLOOR WHOSLEEP WITH HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS EACH AND EVERY YEAR.
IT'S ALWAYS THE FIRST THURSDAY
IN THE MONTH OF MARCH WHICH IS
THE COLDEST MONTH IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHY DO I DO
THAT. WHAT DO I LEAVE MY HOME
AND SLEEP WITH HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. WANT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION SO WHEN I GET ON
IS DOWN FLOOR I CAN SPEAK WITH
THEM INTELLIGENCE. AND ALSO
WITH INPUT AND WHICH THEY GIVE
ME. THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
HOMELESS. AND FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. IS OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE
THE SUBJECT THREE IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S NO PLACE LIKE HOME.
MANY OF US HAVE A BEAUTIFUL
HOME HAVE REFRIGERATOR CLOSE.
SHELTER MY BROTHERS AND SISTERS
WHO DON'T HAVE THOSE AMENITIES
WHO WOULD LOVE TO BE IN A WARM
BED. WHO WANTS TO BE HERE A
PLACE THAT THEY CAN CALL HOME.
THEY'RE STRUGGLING EACH AND
EVERY DAY ALL RIGHT I'M SICK
AND TIRED. I'LL BE WATCHING MY
HOMELESS BROTHERS AND SISTERS
ON THE STREETS AND TO HAVE THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY. WHO'S IN
POWER TO CHANGE THE SUBJECT OR
IN CALIFORNIA. TO HELP THE
RHETORIC GOING ON THIS FLOOR
TALK ABOUT DOING NOTHING TALK
ABOUT RENT CONTROL WHAT IS NOT
RECONSTRUCTING FRANCE. THIS IS
ABOUT HAVING A FOURTH FOURTH
AFORETHOUGHT. VISIONARY
CHANGING TRAJECTORY THE SUBJECT
IN CALIFORNIA AS WE KNOW IT
TODAY. SO HOW DARE WE GET SO
SELF RIGHTEOUS. TO TALK ABOUT
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS
DON'T EVEN EXIST YOU WALK PAST
THE BECAUSE YOU HAVE WHAT YOU
HAVE. BUT THEY WILL LOVE DON'T
THINK THAT WE HAVE TODAY. AND
TO TALK ABOUT WORDS SOLUTION
WHERE IS YOUR SOLUTION TO TALK
ABOUT CHANGING THE SUBJECT
THREE IN CALIFORNIA RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE WHICH SELF RIGHTEOUS
HOLIER THAN THOU WHERE'S MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ALIKE ELSINORE.
I WISH SHE WAS HERE TO HEAR
THIS. BECAUSE WE'RE DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND I WANT
TO THANK HIM AND THOSE WHO HAVE
CALLED FOR THIS BILL. BECAUSE
IT IS THE RIGHT WAY TO GO. WE
HAVE BUSINESSES WHO ALSO
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. AND TO DO
NOTHING IT'S CRIMINAL TO DO
NOTHING IT'S MALPRACTICE I
THOUGHT THIS BODY PUSHED PAST
YOURSELF AND DO THE RIGHT THING
BECAUSE GUESS WHAT YOU MAY KNOW
SOMEONE WHO WILL BE HOMELESS
ONE DAY. AND YOU WILL WANT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS TO BE THERE
FOR THEM. BUT THE NEXT
GENERATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GIPSON. MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS YEAH I HAD TO
RISE JUST BECAUSE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT THAT I'VE HEARD ON
THIS FLOOR. YOU KNOW GUYS. WHEN
I WATCH YOU OVER THE OVER MY
NOW GOING ON MY FIFTH YEAR IN
THIS LEGISLATURE BUT WATCHING
OUR GOVERNMENT OVER THE PAST
TEN YEARS. VOTE ON BILL AFTER
BILL. THAT RAISES THE COST OF
LIVING IN THE STATE. WHEN YOU
YOUR PS UP TO A 100% NOW WE'RE
GONNA READ A HUNDRED PERCENT.
AND ARE GONNA JACK UP
EVERYBODY'S UTILITY BILLS 2100%
BY THE TIME THIS IS ALL OVER
SAID ALREADY BEEN RAISED 80% WE
PAY. WE PAY 80% MORE FOR
ELECTRICITY IN CALIFORNIA THAN
ANY OTHER PLACE IN THE STATE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT. ALL THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS THAT
YOU CONTINUE TO PILE ON. ANY
SEQUEL REFORM THIS YEAR. FOR
HOUSING TO ACTUALLY BUILD MORE
HOUSING IN THIS STATE STATEWIDE.
NOPE WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT. BUT
AS YOU CONTINUE TO PILE ON ALL
THE REGULATIONS AND MAKE RENTS
HIGHER THAT MAKE THE COST OF
HOUSING. HIGHER. WHEN THE
THINGS THAT YOU PASS THAT MAKE
THE COST OF BUYING FOOD HIGHER.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE AUDACITY
ON THIS FLOOR TO BLAME THE GIG
ECONOMY. FOR POVERTY IN THIS
STATE. THE AUDACITY TO BLAME
LANDLORDS FOR HOMELESSNESS. I
MEAN FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS YOU
GUYS HAVE BEEN TALKING HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO HELP THE
HOMELESS AND ABOUT HOW YOU'RE
GOING TO HELP PEOPLE GET OUT OF
POVERTY HEY GUYS LAST I CHECKED
IS. 18% NOW IN CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT AND THE COST KEEP GETTING
HIGHER. AND NOW YOU HAVE
ANOTHER PROPOSAL YOU SAY IS
GOING TO HELP THEM. HELP PEOPLE
ON THE MARGINS AND MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THEY'RE NOT HOMELESS
AND YET WE HAVE MORE HOMELESS
NOW YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN IN
POWER. YEP ALL THE CONTROL WE
DON'T GET TO PASS THE LAWS THAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE PASSED.
YOU GUYS OF HAPPY CONTROL. AND
WE HAVE MORE HOMELESS IN THIS
STATE THAN EVER BEFORE SO
PLEASE ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
CALIFORNIANS ALLTO SAY PLEASE
STOP HELPING US. BECAUSE YOU'RE
NOT HELPING PEOPLE ON THE
MARGINS YOU'VE INCREASED
HOMELESSNESS WITH YOUR POLICIES
YOU HAVE INCREASED POVERTY.
WITH YOUR POLICIES. AND I WANT
TO SPEAK TO YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE FOLKS WHO I KNOW THEY'RE
HARD TO THE RIGHT PLACE THEY
SEE THE RENTS GOING HIGHER THE
FRUSTRATED. A LOT OF RENTAL
ADVOCATES. SOME IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE ASK YOURSELF HOW THIS
BILL HELPS YOU. OKAY. AND GIVE
YOU A LITTLE VIEW OF WHAT GOES
ON IN THIS BUILDING THIS BILL
SAYS THAT THEY CAN RAISE YOUR
RATE YOUR RENT EVERY YEAR BY 7%
AND 8% ARE YOUR WAGES
INCREASING. BY 8% EVERY YEAR.
NO BUT THAT'S THE DEAL THAT GOT
CUT THE GENTLEMAN FROM
SACRAMENTO SAID IT REALLY
CLEARLY WHY ARE THE BIG
CORPORATE LANDLORDS. NOT
OPPOSING THIS BILL. WHY BECAUSE
THEY'RE GETTING A HELL OF A
DEAL. THEY'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
RAISE RENTS 8% A YEAR. FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE. AND THE MOM
AND POP LANDLORDS WHO USUALLY
ARE ACTUALLY ARE THE ONES WHO
KEEP RENTS LOW AND PROBABLY
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO BUT
DEALT BUT THEY'LL HAVE THAT.
CAP AS WELL. BUT THE CORPORATE
LAND BIRDS THEY'RE GONNA JUST
KEEP RAISING THAT TO THAT CAP.
EVERY YEAR AND BY THE WAY IF
THEY BUILD NEW HOUSING. NONE OF
THIS APPLIES TO THEM SO THEY'LL
GO OUT MAKE MORE CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS AND NONE OF THESE
RULES WILL APPLY TO THEM.
BECAUSE THE REAL DEAL HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IS FOLKS BIG
GOVERNMENT AND BIG BUSINESS
LOVE EACH OTHER. BECAUSE WHEN
THEY GET TOGETHER THEY CAN MAKE
THE DEAL BUT ALL THE PEOPLE ON
THE SMALLER BUSINESSMEN THE
MAMA POPS. THE INDUSTRIES THAT
DON'T HAVE LOBBYIST. THEY DON'T
GET CUT IN ON THE DEAL. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT HAPPENED. SO
WHEN ALL THESE PEOPLE STAND UP
HERE AND TELL YOU HOW THEY'RE
HELPING YOU. PLEASE JUST ASK
THE QUESTION READ THE BILL WHAT
IT ACTUALLY DOES AND WHAT IS
GOING TO DO IN THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE. IT REALLY DOESN'T HELP
YOU. BUT WHAT IT WILL DO IS
REDUCE SUPPLY HIM I DON'T WANT
TO GET A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THAT. I KNOW I
DON'T JUST BELIEVE I KNOW THAT
THE FREE MARKET BRINGS ABOUT
LOWER COSTS FOR ALL. THIRTY WE
DON'T HAVE A FREE MARKET. IN
CALIFORNIA NOT AT ALL WE ARE
BIG GOVERNMENT AND BIG BUSINESS
AND IT'S WORKING OUT GREAT FOR
THEM. MISS WICKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IS A
PROUD JOINT AUTHORED TO THIS
BILL AND I WANT TO TAKE A
SECOND TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION THAT HAS BEEN RAISED
AND CORRECT THE RECORD ON SOME
OF THE POINTS THAT WERE MADE
WITH REGARD TO MOM AND POPS
LANDLORDS RAISED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM NICHOLAS HERE I
SPOKE TO A LOT OF MOM AND POPS
LANDLORDS IN MY DISTRICT AND- A
LOT OF THE MOM AND POPS
LANDLORDS DISTRICTS THEY DON'T
HAVE FOR ONE CASE OR PENSION.
THEY HAVE THEIR ENTIRE LIFE
SAVING IN A SINGLE FAMILY HOME.
IN A CONDO IN A UNIT THAT THEY
RENT. THEY WILL BE. EXEMPT FROM
THIS BILL. UNLESS THEIR
CORPORATE LANDLORDS. RIGHT AND-
FOR THOSE WHO ARE SUBJECT TO
THIS BILL. IF THEY ARE A
CORPORATE LANDLORD. THEY STILL
HAVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBILITY TO RAISE THE RENT
UP TO EIGHT PERCENT. MOST
LANDLORDS THE AVERAGE JUST 3%
INCREASE. SO MOST LENDERS WON'T
EVEN RAISE UP TO THE 8% MOST
LANDLORDS WANT A GOOD TENANT
WHO PAYS THE BILLS ON TIME IS
IT GOING TO DESTROY THE
PROPERTY. AND IS GOING TO BE AN
EASY TEN IT TO WORK WITH BUT
THIS GIVES THOSE LANDLORDS THAT
FLEXIBILITY SO THIS BILL IS
REALLY AIM TO GET OUT THE MOST
AGREE JUST CASES THAT WE SEE.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. THAT WE SAW
IN THE FIRES. RIGHT WHERE
PEOPLE ARE RAISING RENTS
203-040-5060 PERCENT WE PUT
FORTH. LEGISLATION THEN TO
GUARD AGAINST THAT PRICE
GOUGING. WELL THAT IS ACTUALLY
BASED ON LAW FROM THE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT SAYS IF THERE IS. A STATE
OF EMERGENCY OR NATURAL
DISASTER THERE'S NO PRICE
GOUGING. WE ARE IN A STATE OF
EMERGENCY ON HOUSING RIGHT NOW.
IN MY COMMUNITY WE'VE HAD A 47%
INCREASE IN HOMELESSNESS IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS IN OAKLAND THE
COUNTY ALAMEDA DID RESEARCH ON
THAT AND ASK THOSE FOLKS WHY
OVER HALF OF THEM. ARE THERE
BECAUSE OF ECONOMIC
DISPLACEMENT YES THERE ARE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES YES THEIR
DRUG AND ALCOHOL ISSUES BUT THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE THERE
BECAUSE OF ECONOMIC
DISPLACEMENT I SAT DOWN WITH MY
SUPERINTENDENT OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOLS COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND
SHE WAS TELLING ME ABOUT. THE
HOMELESS TEACHERS THAT TEACH IN
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS. THAT IS THE
STATE OF OUR HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW. AND DOING
NOTHING IS NOT AN OPTION WE
HAVE CONSTITUENTS THE COME TO
THIS BUILDING EVERY DAY THE
COME TO OUR OFFICES THAT ARE
DEMANDING THAT WE TAKE ACTION.
ON THIS ISSUE. AND SO IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON US TO DO THAT.
AND FOR MY COLLEAGUE FROM LIKE
ELVES IN OR WHO IS NOT PRESENT
THE MOMENT. I AGREE WITH HER WE
NEED MORE HOUSING PRODUCTION. I
HAVE A BILL THAT YOU'LL GET TO
VOTE ON IN THE NEXT COUPLE DAYS
TO DO EXACTLY JUST THAT. AND I
HAVE MORE TO YOUR BILLS THAT
ARE GOING TO DO EXACTLY JUST
THAT'S ALL THESE DO YOU DO THAT
SPOKE OUT ON THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT ISSUE. ISSUE I EXPECT YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THOSE BILLS COMING
DOWN THE PIPELINE. IT'S ALSO
I'M A CO AUTHOR IN SB FIFTY I
WILL DO EVERYTHING IN MY POWER
TO MAKE SURE WE ARE BUILDING
MORE HOUSING AT ALL INCOMES.
BUT IT'S A FALSE CHOICE TO SAY
WE EITHER NEED TO BUILD. OR
PROTECT TENANTS WE HAVE TO DO
BOTH OF THOSE THINGS. TO GET US
OUT OF THE CRISIS THAT WE'RE IN
RIGHT NOW. AND WE CAN SHOULD
AND MUST DO BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS. NOW SOME SAY. THIS IS
GOING TO EXACERBATE THE HOUSING
CRISIS BECAUSE IT WILL SLOW
DOWN PRODUCTION. THE BUILDERS
DON'T AGREE WITH THAT. THEY
SAID THIS WON'T DO THAT. THOSE
ARE THE FOLKS THAT BILL THE
HOUSING IN OUR STATE. I THINK
WE ARE MORALLY OBLIGATED TO
TAKE ACTION TODAY AND TO PASS
THIS BILL THERE HAVE BEEN MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDER
STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS THE AISLE
ON THIS. AND IS IT A PERFECT
BILL NO BUT IS IT GOING TO
PROVIDE SOME BASIC PROTECTIONS
TO FOLKS THAT NEED IT MOST YES.
I HAVE BEEN TO MANY HOMELESS
SHELTERS IN MY COMMUNITY MANY.
MANY ENCAMPMENTS AND TALK TO
FOLKS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING THIS
CRISIS FIRSTHAND. TURN A BLIND
EYE TO THEM. IS CRIMINAL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS WICKS MR
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I APPRECIATE THAT
DEBATE I APPRECIATE THE SHARING
OF THE DIFFERENT. STORIES AND
EXPERIENCES AND THE RECOGNITION
OF THE CRITICAL IMPORT OF THIS
MOMENT THIS THIS IS AN
INFLECTION MOMENT THIS IS A
TIME WHERE WE EITHER ACT WE DO
NOTHING. AND I FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT WE MUST ACT AS A BODY FOR
THE BENEFIT OF CALIFORNIA I
WANT TO SHARE A COUPLE OF
REFLECTIONS ON SOME OF THE OUR
CONSENT WERE MADE. THERE WAS.
BASED ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THIS
BILL ON SUPPLY ON BUILDING. AND
THAT IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT LOST. ON THE LEAD
AUTHOR ON THE JOINT AUTHORS WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS. A POTENTIAL
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE AND IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THAT POTENTIAL
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE THE BILL
DIRECTLY ADDRESSES THAT ISSUE
BY EXEMPTING. NEW HOUSING FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS SO THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT. SLIPPED BY US
THAT WE DIDN'T WE WEREN'T AWARE
OF WE WERE AWARE OF IT AND WE
ADDRESS THAT. THIS BILL HAS
ALSO BEEN CALLED. A RED CAP AND
I THINK WORDS MATTER. AND. TO
BE CLEAR UNDER THIS BILL RENT
HIKES ARE NOT TO EXCEED 10% A
YEAR WITH CPI PLUS 5% AS THE
FORMULA THAT FORMULA ROWS OF
ALLOWS RENTS THAT ARE TWICE AS
HIGH AS THE CURRENT AVERAGE
INCREASES ACCORDING TO THE
BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS AND
PREVENT ONLY THE EXTREME
INCREASES THAT LEAD TO
DISPLACEMENT SO THIS IS NOT
RENT CONTROL THERE IS PLENTY OF
ROOM FOR TURNING A PROFIT FOR.
A REASONABLE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT. DOES PROHIBIT
SOMETHING WE CAN'T HAVE IN OUR
SOCIETY DURING THE STATE OF
CRISIS AND THAT IS RENT
GOUGING. SO OUT WORDS MATTER
THIS IS NOT RECONCILE THIS IS
AN ANTI RENT GOUGING BILL. ALSO
THE ISSUE OF COSTA HAWKINS IN
VACANCY TO CONTROL THIS RACE SO
LET'S BE CLEAR IN THIS REGARD.
THE BILL LEAVES LEAVES COSTA
HAWKINS AND FORCE. WHEN THE
UNIT IS VACATED BY TENANT
LANDLORD MAY CHOOSE TO RAISE
THE RENT TO AN AMOUNT THAT THE
MARKET WILL SUPPORT. THEY CAN
SEE CONTROL REMAINS INTACT. WE
ALSO HEARD DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW
THIS IS A- EITHER OR FORK IN
THE ROAD WHERE EITHER PROTECT
TENANTS ARE WE GO WITH SUPPLY
SIDE SOLUTIONS. AND I THINK
THAT FUNDAMENTALLY
MISUNDERSTANDS. THE OUR NEED TO
ACT THE SCOPE OF OUR NEED TO
ACT AND THE CHOICES THAT ARE
BEFORE US. THOSE CHOICES ARE
NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE IT IS
NOT EITHER OR- IT IS BOTH WERE
IN A STATE OF CRISIS WHEN THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY MORE IN THAT
STATE OF CRISIS AND EMERGENCY
WE MUST USE ALL THE TOOLS IN
THE TOOLBOX INTO EVERYTHING IN
OUR POWER. TO IMPACT THE
PROBLEM AND WE MUST TAKE ACTION.
AND PROVIDE SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE
THE IMPACT THAT MEETS THE SIZE
AND SCOPE AND DEPTH OF THE
PROBLEM THE PROBLEM YOU OF ALL
DESCRIBE. THE SUFFERING THAT
WERE SEEN. ACROSS CALIFORNIA SO
IT'S A FALSE CHOICE WE CANNOT
WE MUST DO BOTH. AND WE MUST TO
BOTH THE SESSION. AND WE CAN
AND WE WILL DO BOTH THE SESSION
THERE ARE SUPPLY SIDE SOLUTIONS
PENDING BEFORE US. YOU HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH HIS BILL
THAT YOU SHOULD VOTE FOR YOUR
OTHER BILLS AUTHORED BY OTHER
MEMBERS THAT ARE BEFORE US NOW
AND INTO THE NEW YEAR SO WE
KNOW THAT ARE SET A DESIRE TO
AND I NEED TO ADDRESS A PIE
SIDE SOLUTION TO MANY OF THOSE
WHO STOOD UP TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THE TEN PROTECTION BILL HAVE
BEEN CHAMPIONS. FOR SUPPLY SIDE
SOLUTIONS I WANNA JUST REMIND
EVERYBODY MANY OF YOU WERE HERE
NOT ALL BUT MANY OF THE MOST.
THAT WE ARE ALL HERE TOGETHER
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AND WITH
AN EFFORT LED BY OUR SPEAKER
AND- BY THE OFF THE LEAD AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL THE CHAIR OF OUR
FAMILY HOUSING COMMITTEE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO. TO BRING
TOGETHER. SOME OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT AND MEANINGFUL AND
IMPACTFUL SUPPLY SIDE SOLUTIONS
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE MIDDLE
OF THIS CRISIS. WE HAD A
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLAR RECORDING
FREE FEE. THAT ARE PRO TEM
AUTHORED WE HAD A MUSTER TWO
THIRDS VOTE FOR THAT. WE PUT A
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR HOUSING
BOND SB THREE BY SENATOR BILL
ON THE ON THE BALLOT. ANOTHER
TWO THIRDS EFFORT ON THE PART
OF THIS HOUSE. THAT I WAS PUT
ON THE BALLOT IN PAST WE HAD A
CRITICAL STREAMLINING BILL SB
THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR WIENER
ALL PASSED. WE PUSH THAT WAS
ARE LEFT FOR THE YEAR THAT WAS
TWO YEARS AGO. ALL THREE WERE
SUPPLY SIDE SOLUTIONS. NONE
NONE WERE TENER PROTECTION
BILLS. SO TENANTS WAITED. AND
THIS IS THE DAY THAT WE HELP
OUR TENANTS. THERE ARE SEVENTY
MILLION TENANTS IN CALIFORNIA
WHO AT THE PLACE THEY CALL HOME.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A TEN AND
THEIR HOME WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT A GARDEN VARIETY
RELATIONSHIP INVOLVING SOME
TRANSACTION OR EXCHANGE OF
WHICH IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOMEONE'S HOME. ABOUT THE
PLACE. A PERSON LAYS DOWN THEIR
HEAD AT NIGHT WHERE THEY FEEL
SAFE FOR THEIR KIDS FEEL SAFER
THEIR FAMILY FEEL SAFE. THIRTY
SECOND SPOT AND. WE CAN END
THEIR SUFFERING AND THEIR PAIN
THEIR ANGUISH TODAY BY PASSING
THIS BILL WE CAN REALLY PROVIDE
HELP THAT THEY NEED WE HAVE
FOLKS LIVING IN FEAR THAT THEY
ARE ONE RENT GOUGING INCREASE
OR ONE DISCRIMINATORY
RETALIATORY OR ARBITRARY
EVICTION NOTICE AWAY FROM
LOSING THEIR HOME. THEY'RE
ASKING FOR HELP THERE WERE THE
OF OUR HELP THEY'RE DESERVING
OF OUR ACTION TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU BOTH
I ON AB. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO.
THANK YOU RESPOND TO. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE COST OF HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA IS OUT OF BALANCE
WITH THE PAY THAT CALIFORNIANS
TAKE HOME WITH THIS BILL WE CAN
HELP TO RESTORE THAT SOME
BALANCE WE DO IT BY BALANCING
THE NEEDS OF FAMILIES WHO NEED
TO RENT THE PLACE WITH THE
RIGHTS OF PROPERTY OWNERS WE DO
IT BY BALANCING THE NEED TO
RATED UNSCRUPULOUS LOT
LANDLORDS WITH THE RECOGNITION
THAT MOST LANDLORDS ARE FAIR.
AND SHOULD ALLOW FARE INCREASES
WE DO THAT BY BALANCING THE
NEED OF RESPONSIBLE RECTOR'S TO
FEEL SECURE IN THEIR HOMES WITH
JUST BECAUSE PROVISIONS
ALLOWING LANDLORDS TO EVICT
ABUSIVE TENANTS HOUSING HAS TO
BE AFFORDABLE SO THAT FAMILIES
CAN BALANCE THEIR BUDGETS THIS
BILL HELPS US TO MOVE TOWARD
THE ACT. I ASKED PRIVATE ON A.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO. YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR THE VIBRANT DEBATE.
WITH THAT MISTER CHIU YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
LET ME FIRST START BY THANKING
ALL OF YOU ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE FOR VERY THOUGHTFUL
DEBATE. THEY ALSO WANT TO THANK
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE GONNA BE
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE. FOR
YOUR COURAGE. THERE'S BEEN A
LOT DISCUSSED ABOUT THE
POLICIES I THINK EVERYONE HERE
IS VERY WELL AWARE OF THE
POLICY ARGUMENTS FOR THIS.
HOUSE OF EVERYONE KNOWS WHO
SUPPORTING THIS AND WHO IS
OPPOSING THIS YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THE POLITICS. I'D LIKE TO
JUST TAKE A BRIEF MOMENT TO
TALK ABOUT THE HUMAN IMPACT. OF
WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON TODAY. THE
PRESS HAS REPORTED THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF US ARE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE
HOMEOWNERS. WE'RE NOT TENANTS.
IMAGINE IF YOU'RE A TENANT.
IMAGINE THAT AFTER A LONG WEEK
LIKE THIS ONE. YOU GO HOME. AND
TACKED ON TO YOUR DOOR IS A
PIECE OF PAPER. THAT SAYS YOUR
RENT IS ABOUT TO BE DOUBLE. OR
YOU'RE ABOUT TO BE EVICTED. AND
IMAGINE YOU'RE LIKE ALMOST HALF
OF CALIFORNIA THAT CAN'T AFFORD
AN ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH. EMERGENCY.
THINK ABOUT THAT IMPACT ON YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT IMPACT ON YOUR
HEALTH. ON YOUR PHYSICAL YOUR
MENTAL HEALTH THINK ABOUT THAT
IMPACT ON YOUR CHILDREN. AND
WHAT THAT MIGHT MEAN YOU MIGHT
HAVE TO PULL YOUR KIDS OUT OF
SCHOOL THINK ABOUT THE IMPACT
ON YOUR ABILITY. TO GET TO YOUR
JOB TO DO YOUR JOB TO KEEP YOUR
JOB. THINK ABOUT THE IMPACT. ON
YOUR PUBLIC SAFETY ON YOUR
COMMUNITY SAFETY. THERE WAS A
RECENT UCLA LOST LAW SCHOOL
STUDY THAT SHOWED OVER THE PAST
EIGHT YEARS. OVER HALF A
MILLION RESIDENTS IN LA COUNTY
RECEIVED AN EVICTION NOTICE
THINK ABOUT THAT FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIVE THOUSAND. EVICTION
NOTICES IN LA COUNTY ALONE.
IT'S NO WONDER CITIES ARE
EXPERIENCING DOUBLE DIGIT
HOMELESSNESS EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF US ON THIS FLOOR. WE HAVE
HAD HUNDREDS OF TENANTS IN OUR
DISTRICTS WHO HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED. WHO ARE HOMELESS
BECAUSE THE RENT IS TOO HIGH.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THESE HUMAN
BEINGS CYNTHIA BELLA FROM
HUNTINGTON BEACH WHO IN RECENT
YARS SAW 45% RENT INCREASE.
STARSHIP HOWL FROM REDWOOD CITY
WHO HAS A DISABILITY WHO THIS
YEAR RECEIVE A 1100% RENT
INCREASE. THOSE OF YOU FROM LA
KNOW THE STORY OF THELMA SMITH
SHE WAS A HUNDRED AND TWO YEARS
OLD SHE WAS EVICTED FROM HER
HOME AFTER LIVING THERE FOR
THIRTY YEARS. COLLEAGUES WITH A
SIMPLE CHOICE TODAY. ON THE ONE
HAND WE CAN STAND BY WHILE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF HUMAN BEINGS
ARE FORCED OUT ONTO OUR STREETS
OR WE CAN STAND UP FOR CYNTHIA
FOR STASHING. FOR THELMA. THE
QUESTION WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US
IS WHAT KIND OF A SOCIETY DO WE
WANT TO LIVE IN. AS A GOOD.
ASKS WHAT KIND OF NEIGHBORS ARE
WE. I SAY WERE CALIFORNIA I SAY
WE ARE BETTER THAN THAT'S WE
HAVE A HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY TO
STAND AND PROTECT OUR
CONSTITUENTS. ON BEHALF OF
EIGHT MILLION TENANTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ISSUE. WITH THAT CAR
CLUB THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
OF A- AYE AYES FORTY SIX KNOWS
TWENTY TWO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONFIRMED IN
. MEMBERS WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL BUSINESS BEFORE
THE ASSEMBLY. ON THE
CONCURRENCE FILE I'M SORRY
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
SB FIVE NINETY TWO WINNER FROM
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE REQUEST IS
GRANTED. AND NOW WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE UP MISTER LOW'S
MEASURES ON THE CONCURRENCE
FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
SEVEN FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN A.
B. FOR NINETY SIX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY SIX
BY SOMETHING MEMBER LOW AND
EXPLAIN TO BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS MR Là EMAIL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR SPEAKING
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THINGS LOS BEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CARPOOL OF
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER
ROLE TELL YOU BUT I SEVENTY
KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN
. THANKS FOR
YOUR PATIENCE MISTER LOW WE
WILL TAKE UP YOUR DISH ALL
MEASURE THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTY. FILE ITEM EIGHTY AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE COVERAGE
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY
ONE BY SOME REMEMBER LOW AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO ELECTIONS
MR LOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS
BILL IS BACK FOR CONCURRENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MISTER LO SI NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS. DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
ABOUT. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL.
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
KNOWS FIFTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. OKAY. MEMBERS
A FEW ANNOUNCEMENTS. THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES WILL MEET
UPON ADJOURNMENT BUDGET. IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO EDUCATION
IN ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX.
INSURANCE COMMITTEE IN ROOM
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN THIS IS UPON
ADJOURNMENT BUDGET FORTY TWO OH
TWO EDUCATION ONE TWENTY SIX.
INSURANCE ROOM FOR THIRTY SEVEN.
PLEASE BE ADVISED COMMITTEES
WILL BE MEETING. IN THE MORNING
PLEASE CHECK WITH YOUR
SCHEDULERS. SESSION SCHEDULE
SESSION IS SCHEDULED TO START
AT ONE THIRTY PM TOMORROW.
THURSDAY SEPTEMBER TWELFTH ONE
THIRTY PM. FRIDAY SEPTEMBER
THIRTEENTH IS TO BE DETERMINED.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION.
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. AND
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCER GERMANS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR AT THIS TIME
. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. MR
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF CHARLES BARRIER. THIS
WAS A VETERAN LINGUISTS
PROFESSOR FARMER. AND FAMILY
MAN. HE WAS BORN ON MAY TWELFTH
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE IN
ALBUQUERQUE NEW MEXICO. THE
SECOND SON OF GEORGIAN SYLVIA
BERRIER. HIS EARLY CHILDHOOD
HEARD YEARS WERE SPENT NEW
MEXICO HIS AUNT WAS ACTUALLY
THE FIRST WOMAN TO GRADUATE
FROM COLLEGE IN NEW MEXICO. IN
THE EARLY NINETEEN FORTIES HIS
FAMILY MOVED TO THE YUBA CITY
AREA WHERE HE ATTENDED YUBA
CITY HIGH SCHOOL. GRADUATED IN
NINETEEN FORTY NINE. GRADUATION
HE ATTENDED THE VIRGINIA
MILITARY INSTITUTE VMI. FOR TWO
YEARS BUT WAS A LITTLE TOO
RIGID FOR HIM. SO HE WENT UC
BERKELEY TO FINISH HIS COLLEGE
DEGREE. IN RUSSIAN AND EASTERN
EUROPEAN STUDIES GRADUATE IN
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR. HE THEN I
WANT US HE WENT ON TO SERVE IN
THE AIR FORCE HE HAD BEEN IN
THE ROTC AND WAS COMMISSIONED
AS A SECOND LIEUTENANT IN THE
U. S. AIR FORCE RESERVE. IN
JUNE NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR WAS
CALLED TO ACTIVE DUTY AND JOIN
THE FORTY SIX SO TO. FORTY SIX
SO TO SECOND AIR FORCE
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE SQUADRON A
I SS UNIT. WE NOW KNOW THAT
THIS UNIT WAS ACTUALLY. THEY
WERE THE ORIGINAL MEN IN BLACK.
THEY WERE COMMISSION TO.
INVESTIGATE FALLEN AIRCRAFT BUT
ALSO INVESTIGATE REPORTS OF
UNIDENTIFIED FLYING OBJECTS.
CHARLES SPENT HIS TIME THERE
WAS TRAINED AT PETERSON FEEL
COLORADO AND THEN WENT ON TO
AIRBORNE TRAINING AT FORT
BENNING GEORGIA IT WAS THERE
THAT HE MET THE LOVE OF HIS
LIFE. HOW TO LARA OCTAL. AN
IMMIGRANT FROM GERMANY. HE
MARRIED AND SOON AFTER THEY IN
THE NEW JERSEY. IN ONE ON TO BE
STATE IN THAT ELMENDORF AIR
FORCE BASE WITH THE FOUR
HUNDRED FIVE HUNDRED AND FOURTH
A I SS IN ELMENDORF A LOT
AMADOR FOR AIRFORCE BASE ALASKA.
HE THEN TRANSFERRED TO GEORGE
AIRFORCE BASE CALIFORNIANS
SPENT FIVE MONTHS IN SOUTHERN
SPAIN INTERPRETING SPANISH. FOR
HIS COMMANDING OFFICER HE SPOKE
FIVE. LANGUAGES. IN MARCH
NINETEEN SIXTY RETURN TO
CIVILIAN LIFE IN PORTLAND
OREGON WHERE HE AND HIS WIFE.
HOW LARA BOUGHT A HOME. THEY
RAISE TWO CHILDREN STEVEN AND
SABINA. HE WORKED FOR AS A IN A
PRIVATE ELECTRONICS FIRM AS AN
APPLICATIONS ENGINEER AND THEN.
A JOB AT THE REPUBLICAN STATE
CENTRAL COMMITTEE WHERE HE
CAMPAIGNED FOR MARK HATFIELD IS
THEN THE BECAME GOVERNOR AND
WENT ON TO BECOME ORGAN SENIOR
SENATOR. THEN THE RANCH CALLED
HIM HOME BACK TO YUBA SUTTER
AREA WHERE HE BEGAN TEACHING. I
YUBA COLLEGE IN RUSSIAN AND
GERMAN. HE DID SEVERAL
DIFFERENT PHD PROGRAMS IN THE
SUMMER OF NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
HE PASSED LANGUAGE EXAMS FOR
THE PHD THE ENDED UP BEING
OFFERED A TEACHING POSITION.
THERE IT YUBA COLLEGE AND FOR
MANY YEARS HE TAUGHT. MANY A
STUDENT. HE ONE OF THE THINGS
HE DID EVIL COLLEGES THE HELP.
FOUND IN WAS A SPONSOR OF THE
PUNJAB THE AMERICAN STUDENT
ASSOCIATION WHERE HE WOULD
BRING TOGETHER. NEWLY
IMMIGRATED SEEKS FROM INDIA WHO
WERE STUDYING AT AT THE
COLLEGE. AND HELP PUT ON MOVIES
AND THINGS TO IT AND THEY WOULD
MAKE FOOD THAT WOULD HELP KINDA
BRING A SENSE OF HOME. IN A NEW
LAND. ROSS THE YEARS HE ALSO
DID SEVERAL FELLOWSHIPS. TO
RUSSIA HE WAS A RUSSIAN
LINGUIST AND CERTAINLY DURING
THE COLD WAR AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT TO THE OF THAT
HELPED HIM IN HIS CAREER IN THE
MILITARY BUT THAT HE ALSO
BROUGHT BACK IN HIS TEACHING.
TO IMPROVE RELATIONSHIPS AND TO
HAVE. AMERICAN STUDENTS GO BACK
TO RUSSIA TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
THE COUNTRY IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE TOOK A SABBATICAL LEAVE
SPENDING TIME AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF LONDON SCHOOLS SLAVONIC
STUDIES AND TRAVEL TO THE USSR
DURING THE WINTER HE CONTINUE
TO TEACH ENGLISH GERMAN AND
FRENCH THROUGHOUT HIS REMAINING
YEARS. HE ACQUIRED FARMING
PROPERTY WHICH WAS ALWAYS VERY
IMPORTANT HIM GOING UP ON A
FARM. IN NEW MEXICO. HE
EVENTUALLY BUILT A HOME ON HIS
RANCH IN RIO SO. HE HAD TWO
CHILDREN SIX GRANDCHILDREN. AND
THIRTEEN GREAT GRANDCHILDREN I
WAS INTRODUCED TO HIM BECAUSE
OF HIS GRANDDAUGHTER WITH
ACTUALLY BECAME MY WIFE. I WILL
ALWAYS REMEMBER CHARLES SAYS. A
GREAT CONVERSATIONALIST. HE WAS
INTERESTED IN PEOPLE IN NEED
AND HE GENERALLY REACHED OUT TO
EACH AND EVERY PERSON THAT HE
MET WANT TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
THEM. ANY COULD CONVERSE ABOUT
JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING HAS AS I
HAVE DETAILED FOR YOU HE WAS
QUITE A RENAISSANCE MAN HAVING.
HAD A VERY INTERESTING LIFE
DONE MANY DIFFERENT THINGS BUT
HE USE IT TO CONNECT. TO
PEOPLE. HE WILL BE GREATLY
MISSED BY HIS FAMILY MEMBERS
BUT WE KNOW THAT HE HAS AT LAST
FOR YOU AND I REUNITED WITH HIS
WIFE OF NEARLY SIXTY YEARS.
MEMBERS ASKED THAT WE HAD. IN
MEMORY OF CHARLES BARRIER.
THANK YOU MUCH GALLAGHER OUR
CONDOLENCES. MS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GERMANY MEMORY
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. TO THEIR RISE AND
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF MY FORMER COUNSELOR AT SAN
BERNARDINO VALLEY COLLEGE MS
ELOISA MORON SEGOVIA. MR GOVIA
HAILED FROM ARIZONA AND AFTER
GRADUATING FROM AROUND SEE HIGH
SHE WENT ON TO ARIZONA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND MAJORED IN
PHYSICAL EDUCATION. WHERE SHE
GRADUATED IN NINETEEN FORTY
NINE. SHE WAS A SUN DEVIL TO
HER CORE. MISTER GORE YOU
BECAME AN EDUCATOR AND
COUNSELOR IN TUCSON AND THEN
CAME DECEMBER DINO WORKING IN
VARIOUS SCHOOL DISTRICTS BUT
SPENDING MOST OF HER
EDUCATIONAL CAREER AT SANDRA
DINO VALLEY COLLEGE. SHE TAUGHT
AND COACHED MANY SPORTS AT
VARIOUS SCHOOLS INCLUDE
INCLUDING COLTON HIGH SCHOOL MY
ALMA MATER. AND SAN BERNARDINO
VALLEY COLLEGE. SHE ALSO WAS AN
INSTRUCTOR TEACHER ABOUT LET
FOLKLORICO A TRADITIONAL
MEXICAN DANCE IN PARTICULAR. SO
NOT ONLY WAS SHE MY COUNSELOR
BUT SHE ALSO CONVINCED ME TO
TAKE THAT FOLKLORICO DANCE
CLASS. SO SHE ALSO WAS MY
TEACHER. MISTER GORE GAVE
ACTUALLY WENT ON TO WRITE AND
SELF PUBLISH A BOOK A BOOK ON
BALLOT FOR POLITICAL. BESIDES
MR GO IS ANY COUNSELING DUTIES
AT SAN BERNARDINO VALLEY
COLLEGE SHE ALSO WROTE PRODUCED
AND DIRECTED THE SINGLE THE
MARIO ANNUAL PAGEANT INVOLVING
FIFTY TO SIXTY STUDENTS FROM
KINDERGARTEN TO COLLEGE. THE
PAGEANT STARTED AS A SMALL PLAY
AND GREW TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
ANTICIPATED PRODUCTIONS EVERY
YEAR. THAT PLAY THAT SUCTION
WAS MUCH LOVED BY ALL IN THE
COMMUNITY AS WAS SHE- IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO SHE RETIRED
AS A COUNSELOR FROM SAN
BERNARDINO VALLEY COLLEGE. A
FEW YEARS AFTER RETIRING SHE
RETURNED TO OUR BELOVED ARIZONA.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER MISTER
GOVIA WAS MY COUNSELOR MY
PROFESSOR SHE WAS ALSO MY DEAR
FRIEND. AND MY CUBAN AS SHE WAS
THE ONE WHO INTENTIONALLY
INTRODUCED ME TO MY HUSBAND
FRANK. ON BEHALF OF MY HUSBAND
MYSELF AND ALTHOUGH SHE TOUCHED
DURING HER TENURE AT SAN
BERNARDINO VALLEY COLLEGE AND
COLD IN HIGH SCHOOL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MISS
ALISSA WHAT ON SINGLE VIA.
THANK YOU MISS RAY S. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEE HER ENOUGH FOR THE BUSINESS
SUMMARY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN MISTER MAIENSCHEIN
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS.
THAT IS HOW ENGINE CHURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY SEPTEMBER
TWELFTH AT ONE THIRTY. PM WE
ARE ADJOURNED. VOTE CHANGE.
CHANGE MULLIN. SB THREE NINETY
FIVE I DO NOT VOTING. VOTE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY FIVE I
IT'S NOT VOTING. I KILEY SB TWO
SIX SIX NOTE HIGH. THE. CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY SENATE
BILL TWO SIX SIX NO TÁI.
GIPSON VOTE CHANGE FILE ITEM
NINE NUMBER NINETEEN ON TEN
FIFTY SEVEN FROM I TO NOT
VOTING. VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON AS THE LABEL TEN
FIFTY SEVEN I TO NOT VOTING.
GIPSON VOTE CHANGE AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT I TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT I NOT VOTING.
COOPER FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
THREE A. B. THIRTY TWO HI TO
NOT VOTING. THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER SOME LEVEL THIRTY
TWO I TO NOT VOTING.
MAIENSCHEIN AB TEN NINETY TWO I
TEN NOW. THE CHANGES ONLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN ISN'T ABLE
NOT TEN NINETY TWO I KNOW. AB
EIGHT NINETY ONE I TO NOT
VOTING. THE CHANGES ON THE
NUMBER MAIENSCHEIN AS A LABEL
EIGHT NINETY ONE I IT'S NOT
VOTING AB SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE
NO TIE. THE CHANGES I'VE EVER
MAIENSCHEIN ASSEMBLE SIXTEEN
NINETY FIVE NO TIE. SB SEVEN I
WAS WHEN I A TO NOW. THE. MAIN
CHANGEABLE SEVEN A SEVEN NOW.
SB FOUR EIGHTY FIVE I NOW. THE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN SENATE BILL FORTY
FIVE I KNOW. BIGELOW FILE ONE
OH FIVE BILL SB THREE NINETY
FOUR NO TO NOT VOTING. FOR A
CHANGE AS A MEMBER BIGELOW
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY FOUR
NO IT'S NOT VOTING. IRWIN SB
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE I TO KNOW. THE
CHANGES ONLY MEMBER IRWIN
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY FIVE I
TO KNOW. LEE MONA VOTE CHANGE
AB ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN FROM I
IT'S NOT VOTING. THE CHANGES ON
A MEMBER THE BONUS UNABLE LEVIN
EIGHTY SEVEN I DO NOT VOTING